practice your web development skills by
building a social media dashboard with a
dark light theme Jess who runs the
popular coder coder YouTube channel will
guide you through a beginner front-end
Mentor challenge you'll improve your
skills in JavaScript HTML and CSS Jess
demonstrates her practical approach to
planning a website project and her
resourceful methods for researching
Solutions so it's time to dive in and
Unleash Your coding potential as you
build this Dynamic social media
dashboard
hey everyone in this video course for
free code Camp I'll be building a social
media dashboard from a design by front
end Mentor I'll be coding this from
scratch using HTML scss and a little
JavaScript and we'll be using CSS custom
properties to add a dark light toggle to
the dashboard
throughout this course I'll be showing
you exactly what I do in real world
projects which includes a lot of
research and troubleshooting no
developer knows every single thing off
the top of their head we all have to
look stuff up and use trial and error
I'll be sharing my own techniques for
doing this so that you can walk away
with some research and problem solving
skills that you can use in your own
projects if you like this video and you
want more I am currently working on a
course called responsive design for
beginners where I build a custom website
from aphigma design using HTML scss and
JavaScript you can find out more about
the upcoming course linked down in the
description alright let's get into it
all right so when I'm starting a project
before I do anything before I jump right
into the code and start typing away I
try to take a look at the project and
kind of figure out what requirements are
going to be part of this and what things
I would have to build let's pretend that
this project that I'm building or that
you're building this front and Mentor
challenge is something from work and
what's really cool about front and
Mentor is that they're actually giving
you almost like a real world experience
in terms of getting a design from a
designer and then having to build that
out because that's basically what I've
done as a web developer at my job or my
former job rather
so let's look at the front and Mentor
challenge so we're doing the social
media dashboard with theme switcher and
if we click into here we can see you
know the desktop design it has a series
of cards and it's showing data from a
different social media platforms and
then on the bottom part there is some
more cards showing you know different
engagement metrics and then of course at
the top right we have this toggle for
dark mode and light mode and we can see
here that there is both a light and dark
mode version of this website so what I
like to do usually is
write down what the functional
requirements of this project are going
to be this is really very similar to
what I would do in the real world so I'm
just going to create a new file here
call it notes.md
this is going to be functional
requirements and notes and you know
obviously this is just a casual like
note-taking thing let's kind of zoom in
a little bit more here okay so
functional requirements and notes so the
dashboard has a light and dark mode
toggle
so we're going to have to do a little
bit of research in terms of you know
what is the correct markup to use in
HTML so what HTML markup to use
as well as how to switch between
light and dark mode
and I believe we're using CSS variables
so that might be another
item that we're going to list out here
so CSS variables
or
variables or custom properties which is
I think they're
their formal name but it seems like a
lot of people are just saying CSS
variables like myself
the light dark mode is kind of the
reason that I chose this challenge it's
something that I'm not super familiar
with myself so I thought it might be
beneficial to just show you the CD
underbelly of building websites and all
the research and Googling that is
involved as well as trial and error so
just trying to keep things you know
honest and open around here
so here's the brief challenges to build
this landing page get close to the
design as possible which is definitely
important
the only JavaScript required is for the
color theme toggle users should be able
to view the optimal layout depending on
their device's screen size so you know
desktop versus Mobile versus tablet and
then hover States and then toggle the
color theme to their preference so
that's pretty straightforward one thing
I did was I actually tweeted about
building this project thinking about
doing this dark glide mode switcher
challenge in front of mentor
so I said I haven't built one before so
there's probably gonna be some live
Googling or duckduck going since I use
DuckDuckGo
so let's see I got some pretty good
replies um with good suggestions from
people for things that I need to keep in
mind when I'm building this out so
that's Matt he makes for an i Mentor so
this person is saying CSS custom
properties are the simplest native way
to do it that I know of
declare the theme properties at the root
which is what I have heard too and then
apply a class to the body or use a
prefers color scheme media query to
override them okay so prefers color
scheme media query that's something that
we're going to prefers color scheme
media query so we're gonna have to look
that up and then okay so everything else
I kind of know use the root thing okay
let's see and then I got this other
tweet from Grace snow she's actually a
really active member of friend and
Mentor
um she's very experienced so one of the
challenge I see most commonly is using
poor HTML semantics not just for the
toggle
I actually think the HTML is a way very
challenging theme so I was asking like
for the dashboard so she was saying
where the heading should be should
usernames be labeled a screen reader
only text Will the increased decrease of
followers be communicated to assistive
text okay so let's look back at the
design real quick so where the headings
should be I'm guessing that is for you
know making sure you're using the
correct H tags whenever possible so I'm
guessing here social media dashboard
will be the H1 and then I'm guessing the
overview today would be in H2 and then
each card would probably need an H3 tag
so you know page views likes
Etc
and the other interesting thing she said
was should usernames do label with
screen reader only text this is an
accessibility thing so if say you are
visually impaired he might be using a
screen reader to navigate the internet
and
that means that you need websites that
you build to be able to be navigable by
screen readers so they'll actually read
out loud to you what the content is on
the website so if we look at the design
for example on the first card here it
says you know Facebook and then Facebook
username Twitter with a Twitter handle
etc for the different platforms and if
you're visual you can see the Facebook
icon or the Twitter icon and you know
what platform this card belongs to but
if you have a screen reader it's not
going to say that so what I'm assuming
Grace is saying here is that we can add
some text that's only going to be I
guess readable by the screen reader but
it's not going to visually appear on the
page to say for example Facebook Nathan
F or Twitter anything F things like that
just to make things more accessible you
know for screen readers and do the same
thing with the bottom cards like you
know page views on Facebook or likes on
Facebook likes on Instagram so things
like that are unfortunately oftentimes
the last thing or even just forgotten
and I'm as guilty this as a lot of other
people are and accessibility is
something that I'm trying to get better
at so we'll try to keep these things in
mind and let's make some notes on that
as well so excess uh
ability
accessibility
is that right excessive
no I think there is two s's you know
like when you look at a word and you
like look at it for so long that it
starts to look weird
um that may or may not be spelled
correctly okay so accessibility makes
your headings
use correct heading tags
and then screen reader only text for you
know card
titles username
so just things to keep in mind there and
then another thing we actually might
need to research is the toggle itself
for accessibility as well so dark light
mode toggle I guess yeah what HTML
markup
accessible
we'll go into that a little bit later
so let's go back to the tweet
um let's see
this variables someone else says
and then at the bottom this is from
Killian
uh volkov he makes the polypane browser
which we're actually going to be using
later in this video so he's saying extra
credit if you had a 30 system default
option so a third option to the toggle
so let's check out his blog post here
okay your dark phone toggle is broken
so let's see what he's saying here so do
you need a toggle do you really need a
toggle to support dark mode not really
you can't support dark mode by using the
prefers color scheme option which that
other person mentioned earlier so that
that's another note to myself that this
prefers color scheme is probably
something that is accepted or a best
practice and we'll be researching that
later so
it gives you in building the browsers it
gives you one of three values light dark
and no preference okay so here's the
issue
the issue or the problem here is that
most toggles have two states you either
have light mode or dark mode and the
choice is forever stored in a cookie or
local storage which could break your
dark mode if if I'm guessing you've set
in your browser or your OS you prefer
either light or dark
so this is saying that the toggle
actually needs to have three states
light dark and system preference which
is what the user sets on their own
computer and then there's this prefers
color scheme media query so this is
mentioned again
okay so what I'm getting from this is
that the toggle actually so switching
between light dark modes via JavaScript
and then three option toggle
light dark and then system preference
and that goes into the prefers color
scheme media query
so this looks pretty good so far so you
know we're just making a list here of
all the things that we're going to be
doing research on in a little bit
okay so I think
and then this is an example of stack
Overflow giving you these three options
all right awesome
so
I believe that was all for the tweet
so now we have the items that we need to
research
we're just gonna kind of go down the
list so the first one is the light dark
mode toggle so what I need to figure out
is what HTML markup do I need to use and
how to make sure it's accessible
so if we go back here um so Grace snow
actually did a challenge on foreign
Mentor which I did find in my
pre-research research
and it's linked here so an accessible
toggle in htlcs and JS and this is for a
this other challenge which is a pricing
component with toggle so you can see
that here
and she made some notes Here using an
accessible component from this person
Scott O'Hara styled form controls so
let's check that out
foreign
form controls so I know a little bit
about this basically you know your phone
controls are like the checkbox the radio
buttons um form buttons form text boxes
things like that and what people
sometimes do when they're styling them
to make them look prettier is to instead
of using the actual radio button or
something they'll just build one using a
div and CSS and that's not navigable by
screen readers and it's a bit confusing
because you're not using you know the
traditional HTML form elements for that
so what I'm guessing this website is
telling you is and let's load the actual
website here okay so this is the website
zoom in a bit
um the accessibility style form controls
so what I'm guessing is is that this
person Scott O'Hara has created you know
HTML CSS markup that you can use if you
want to have these accessible formulas
just as a starting point
so what we want is to figure out the
markup for the toggle
okay switch check box toggle button
let's see what this is okay so this does
look like a toggle however keep in mind
we do need to use I think we need to use
a radio button list because this button
I believe only has the on and off
settings so I think we need this one
switch radio button group
pattern to create a two option radio
button group
okay
so there you go the toggle it's working
and there's some notes Here
okay so here is some example code which
is pretty awesome so we can see here
there's a field set which sort of
encapsulates the different controls and
then there is yes so for each option
there is a radio
button input type
so this is probably what we're going to
be using
now if you remember from uh Killian's
blog post we actually need three a three
option radio button toggle so
this example just has two
and I need to figure out is there a
three option toggles that even possible
so when I am looking for some examples
of UI elements a lot of times I'll just
go to codepen
so codepen
and we're going to look for toggle
maybe three and then just hope something
pops up
let's see what happens here Okay so no
no
oh here we go CSS multi-position radio
switch okay perfect
so what I'm really looking at here is an
example for you know what I can build
that I can use as a reference okay so
there's two positions three and even
four
that's pretty funny
cool
so we're using we'll probably do
something like this so my guess is I
would make the middle position the
system default and then maybe light on
the left and dark on the right
and we'll have the default be the
default
let's just check out their markup really
quick too
looks like
um they too are using a radio button
input which is good so that's another
sign that
you know this is kind of the way to go
in addition to obviously seeing it here
and I believe and then also with Grace's
challenge here
so this is just good to know you know we
might need to come back to this to see
how they style the three positions
because you know it has this nice sort
of animated thing
so you know we can kind of go back to
this when we need to so I'm going to
take that link
so here we go light Dark Moon toggle um
through option toggle we're just going
to add a link here and then the HTML
markup
we'll add a copy this thing here
just so we can you know go back and make
sure we're following what that's saying
so now we have the radio button toggle
markup research complete I think I have
enough references that I can work from
this later on when we're actually
building so let's move on to look at
using JavaScript to update CSS variables
so
I use DuckDuckGo update csis variables
with JavaScript and let's see what
happens
a lot of times I will just click on the
first result here but I also try to kind
of filter the results based on if I know
a website is considered you know a good
source of information
and I haven't heard of designsize.com
I'm sure there's a reason it's coming up
first but I look at CSS tricks a lot so
let's check that out
okay updating a CSS variable with
JavaScript so this is this variable up
here so you set the variable it's Mouse
Dash X and then Mouse Dash y
okay so here's some code examples how to
update it from the JavaScript so we're
going to say let root equals document
document element
and then to that document document
element here we go so root dot style Dot
setproperty so this is probably what we
would use
to update the CSS variable
so this is good to know
I guess switching between like light and
dark modes via JavaScript
so maybe for under CSS variables we'll
add a list link here
let's just add some spaces between these
two
make it look a little bit better
so that's probably right now just for
you know Just for kicks and whatever
let's see what this first result tells
us and we can compare what this result
is telling us with what the CSS tricks
link was telling us and just see if they
match up you know it's another sign that
this is probably the best approach
style set property
okay so this is again saying you want to
set it on the root pseudo class
which is what everything else we've read
is saying so that's a good thing okay so
this looks pretty familiar document
document element style set property
which is
you know they they created this root let
variable
I guess just let it sound variable
anymore so root style set property and
they're saying the same thing here so
that tells me that
this this is a good approach to use
so the other thing I think I need to
research is you know doing some research
on light and dark modes just because I
want to see how we need to sort of
format the colors
so let's say light dark mode CSS
variable
see what comes up
[Music]
okay so create a like like to create a
dark light mode switch with CSS
variables dev.to is I think pretty good
obviously your mileage may vary
depending on the actual author
so let's see what this person is saying
okay so adding custom properties
okay so this is
root primary color you know setting it
to different things
and then data theme dark I have not
heard of that
and I believe that people
had mentioned this prefers color scheme
media query so maybe I'll copy this
and do light dark mode for first color
scheme
maybe delete the mode so light dark
prefers color scheme
see if we can find some examples here
okay so
developer.mozilla.org that's usually a
pretty good source of info
the first color scheme CSS media feature
is used to detect if the user has
requested a light or dark color theme
and this is similar to what killing's
blog post was saying so
see
okay so they have a code example here
okay here's what we're looking for so in
the CSS there's a at media rule
and it's saying prefers color scheme
dark
and it has a set of colors using the
dark scheme class
and it's setting the background to a
dark gray in color to white okay and
then there's another at maybe prefers
color scheme light
and then that's using the light scheme
class
background white color it's like a
medium Gray
okay I'm actually curious to see one
thing that um Killian mentioned is that
you can set this in your Os or your
browser
[Music]
interesting okay so the no preference
you mentioned no preference I think but
it's not really it's only supported in
safari
not really supported anything else
um
ooh simulate prefers color scheme and
Firefox which is what I'm using
[Music]
okay
so I guess what I'm curious about is
like I haven't really set the color
scheme thing here but I believe I can
set it in Windows
um
[Music]
and display
let's make this one a bit bigger
I believe it was
under color
hmm
oh dark mode
here we go so under colors
choose your color dark
so if I change it to light what happens
oh everything turns light
interesting I'm actually curious to see
if that affected any of these web pages
that I was looking at
okay so here we go here
let's change back of dark and see if
this changes at all oh my gosh it did so
the day and the night changed
that's pretty cool changing the color
light versus dark
will sort of use this prefers color
scheme value
so what I think I want to do is going
back to the challenge so right now I
have my operating system set to dark
mode if I just load this website I want
it to use a prefers color scheme media
query and detect that I have dark
kind of what
they're saying here so prefers color
seem dark
like that
and then if I set it to light then it
would switch to that without having to
actually do the toggle but my guess is
then the toggle works because let's say
I have my things at the dark but if I
want to load this website in the light
mode if I change it to light then it can
change the light even if my OS mode is
set to dark mode so that's what I'm
guessing is a good ux so
you know if I'm wrong about this feel
free to Flame me in the comments
so let's write a little note on that and
how that all works so light dark mode
toggle
takes system preference
by default
but can override with toggle
this is just kind of a note to myself
okay so then the switching between light
dark modes via JS I need to add the link
that I did for that
so we'll just copy this
did I not do that before
oh yeah I did oh I did just the updating
the CSS variable but I didn't add the
link for
um
this thing prefers color scheme and how
that all works maybe I'll move this up
here to
so it's switching between light dark
mode via JS and prefers color schemed
media query
cool
so I think that's pretty good
um for the
dark and light mode toggle stuff so the
correct heading tags I think I know
enough to to just add the correct
headings and the screen reader only text
for cards and titles and usernames
so let's look at that screen reader only
text
okay so accessible360.com that sounds
that sounds pretty good
okay screener only text is great for
providing more context to a link whose
purpose may be obvious visually due to
its location but could be confusing
without visual cues
so this person is adding some additional
text to the add to cart button
saying you know info about the product
and it's adding a class screen reader
only that's interesting
okay screenware only position absolute
sting
um another thing I tend to do when I'm
looking up stuff is
so I don't know a lot about
accessibility so let's
look up here accessibility developer
guide see if they
you know they seem like a pretty
authoritative Source right
okay
let's check out their website welcome to
the accessibility developer guide nice
okay this is a good sign
it's content is based strictly on the
w3c's web content accessibility
guidelines
um okay it looks pretty good so let's
see what they got here so I'm just gonna
go right to the examples section
and
hiding elements
since we're going to add we're probably
going to add some text that we only want
to be readable by screen readers this is
probably what we're going to use since
we want to have some text that's not
visually visible on the page but it is
readable by screen readers
cool
okay hiding elements visually
we don't want to hide on some screen
readers so we want this thing
I think that once visually by moving
them off screen okay cool there's no
official technique for this but there is
a well-proven workaround so the only way
to hide an element visually while
retaining its perceptibility for screen
readers is moving them out of the
viewport using absolute positioning I
think that's similar to what that other
example was here
yes they're doing absolute looks like
they're also using clip path
um I don't know if that is actually
supported by all browsers
this seems like maybe it's a more
straightforward approach so basically
this is actually a good example
so I would take what this website is
saying over this website because I mean
this seems pretty good but
it just seems like this is like kind of
a Blog
you know it looks like they're some kind
of agency who handles accessibility and
I'm sure they know their stuff but I
think this clip thing is just not
supported as universally as just you
know position absolute so this seems to
be a little bit more of a simple example
so we're going to copy this
screaming only text for card titled
usernames we'll add that link there
okay so this is good this seems like a
pretty cool website so just for the heck
of it
let's see
forms
I just want to see what they what kind
of markup they recommend
look at the general good form example
it's a radio button this is what we're
going to be using radio buttons input
type radio okay that's good
radio buttons and check boxes of the
surrounding field set Legend structure
so this is something good to keep in
mind for the markup
just kind of go back to that example
from Scott O'Hara so field set and
Legend
um Okay cool so it seems pretty similar
so it's another vote in terms of you
know this using the radio button list
for the markup screen readers okay in
addition to the controls label
so each radio button will have its own
label screen readers also announced the
legend of the surrounding field set
code pen let's just check that out
I'm just kind of curious what the legend
is for
um
see a legend here oh wait here Legend
Hobbies
let's just kind of scoot stuff over here
all right so the legend says
instead of hobbies so where is that okay
oh so it's sort of like the title for
the set of radio buttons so my guess is
for the toggle
I would do something like set the legend
Fields or the legend tag to say dark
light mode or theme maybe something like
that something that's kind of just
descriptive of what you know what's the
purpose of this of these radio buttons
and then to make that only visible only
readable by screen readers
so that's a good
that's good to keep in mind
[Music]
so y'all make a note about that because
I want to forget about the legend thing
that's why that two dark light mode
toggle
um here htl markup
I guess we'll just make another note
here use
field set Legend and then radio inputs
okay so I think that's all the notes I
needed
so I think we have everything we need to
go from here so the first thing we want
to do when we're creating our project
files is to create our GitHub repo or
repository the reason we want to do this
at the beginning is because there's a
couple reasons one is that you have to
create a new GitHub repository in an
empty folder so if you've already
started creating your files and started
coding if you wanted to create a repo in
the middle of that you would have to
create it in an empty folder and then
manually move all your coding files to
that folder so just better and easier to
create it at the beginning the other
reason to create the repo at the
beginning of course is when we're using
Source control like git it's just a good
idea to make commits to your repository
as you're developing so to kind of save
your coding as you go along so to create
our repository I'm going to use GitHub
desktop app I know a lot of devs like
using the command line forget because
it's kind of faster and easier but I
personally like the the desktop app and
just the graphical user interface that
you get with that so in GitHub desktop
we're going going to go to file and new
repository and we'll give it a name of a
VM for from a mentor and this is the
social media
dashboard
dark light toggle I know it's kind of a
long name we're not going to initialize
with the readme and I'll show you why in
a little bit but for now let's just
create this Repository
and then we're going to go to vs code
and we want to open that folder that we
just created
so I have all my GitHub repos in a
GitHub folder in the documents
and we'll open the folder
and right now there's nothing here
except for this get attributes file that
get just kind of generates so now let's
start moving the files that we need into
our project folder so if you remember
last time
in the previous video we created the
notes markdown file so I'm just going to
take this and I'm going to copy it into
our
folder here
so now we can see that the notes that we
created last time is here for our
reference now the other thing I want to
do is I want to add the starter files
that front of Mentor gives you so this
is the fundamental challenge page and
when you start the challenge click here
visit challenge Hub and then it tells
you you can download these starter files
I am on the pro account so I have this
option to download the design files
which we will be looking at in I believe
a future video for now let's just
download these starter files you can
click this download button to get them I
have actually already done that so let
me show you what that looks like if we
go to our download folder we have the
social media dashboard zip file and I
have already unzipped that to this
folder here on my desktop so we check
out the files here we have a bunch of
folders and different files and I'm
actually going to take all of these and
copy them over to
my project folder here
so let's take a look at what we have
so in vs code we're looking at our
project now and we have an index.html
file from front of mentor and this just
gives you the copy for the website so
you don't have to manually type
everything out so that's pretty helpful
the other thing I give you is a style
guide markdown file and this is helpful
because it'll tell you the width of the
design that you have for mobile and
desktop it also gives you the colors
that are used in the design so we're
going to be using these when we create
our assassin CSS Styles so there's a lot
of different variables for colors mostly
and then it tells you the font that
we're using this font is called enter
and it's on Google fonts so we'll have
to load that as well
so this is just helpful to be you know a
reference as you go along the other
thing it gives you is images for the
website and then also there's a design
folder and this is if you don't have the
pro account for front inventor and you
just are kind of working from jpegs and
I have done this in the past just with
eyeballing and sort of estimating
distances and sizes and it works pretty
well so you can definitely get by using
the free front and Mentor plan but it is
kind of nice to work from a design and I
did kind of want to show you the real
world process when you're building a
website from an actual design file so
I thought that would be cool to show all
of you
okay so now that we have our starter
files I'm going to do a couple things to
just configure things so in this file
this is a git ignore file this is from
front of Mentor so this will tell git to
ignore any files or changes to files
that you don't want to commit to your
repo so this is so that you don't commit
the actual design files to GitHub
because you know it's for the paid plan
this is for ignoring DS store files
which I think is for a Mac thing
I always want to ignore the node modules
folder
and anything in that because
you install the npm packages from your
package.json file to your node modules
folder so you don't really want to
clutter your GitHub repo with the node
modules folder because anyone can
install them from the package.json file
[Music]
and I think that should be it for now so
we can just close these out
now the next thing I'm going to do is
create the other files and folders that
we're going to be using in our workflow
so this would be mainly SAS files I'm
using scss Syntax for SAS and some
JavaScript files and then I'm going to
set up the gulp workflow but let's set
up our files for now
so in our root we have the index.html
file and usually what I do is I'm going
to create a folder called app and this
is where I'm going to store my working
JavaScript and SAS files so in the app
folder I'm going to create another
subfolder called scss for the SAS and
I'm also going to create another
folder called Js
and I think I just need to drag that so
it's in the app folder
so here we have our JS and scss folders
so in the JS folder
let's create a file called script.js
and we'll add a little console
log message
saying hello
and this will use to test that our
website is working and everything's
getting loaded
folder
I'm going to create some more subfolders
there's going to be a lot of subfolders
here and this is just to keep things
organized this is one reason that I
really like using SAS because if we only
use a CSS file we would have a super
long file just with all your Styles
there SAS gives you a lot of different
capabilities and power really in terms
of organization and making things easier
for you as your writing styles
so we're going to be dividing out our
Styles into different folders as well as
different SAS files so inner CSS
so in our CSS folder will create another
sub folder and I'm going to create a
util this is for utility styles
and in the util folder let's create an
index.scss file and if you're not
familiar with SAS this might seem a
little confusing or overwhelming I will
sort of show you everything that I'm
doing in my workflow
um so hopefully that will help
so I'm going to create another
folder in the scss
folder called globals this is for Global
styles that I want to use
and in the globals we're also going to
create its own index.scss
then we'll create one last subfolder
called components
and again this will have
an
index.css file
and the reason we're doing things like
this is because
in this components folder in each of
these folders actually we're going to
create multiple other scss files and the
index.scss file will load all those
other files and then we will then load
those files in our main scss file which
we need to create here so style.scss
this will be the main file
so the way SAS works with when you're
working with partials meaning when we
split up the Styles into these multiple
files is we can load them
through our main style.scss file so the
way we're doing that here is we're using
some I guess SAS functions for lack of a
better word and what we want to do on
our main SAS file style.scss is we're
going to load all the styles that we're
going to create from components globals
I think just components and globals and
I'll show you what we do with the util
Styles in a little bit so to do that
we're going to use at use and we're
going to load let's load the globals
first
globals and then we'll add another used
rule and add add components
so this is all that we're going to add
in our main SAS file because we're going
to load all the globals and components
with these rules here
now let's start with the util folder so
let me close these other files out here
so this is the index SAS file in the
utils folder the utility styles that
we're going to add here are mainly
things like variables and functions and
mixins SAS mixins that aren't actual CSS
rules but rather things that we're going
to be using in the other SAS files in
our project so for example in the util
folder let's start creating our SAS
files here so I'm going to create one
called
colors
and we'll load our color variables in
there
we'll create another file called
break points and this is
going to be a mix-in that I like to use
in my projects for just a faster way to
load your media queries
and we're also going to add another
file called functions
and then I think I'll add one more file
for our font styles
so fonts.scss
this is going to be for the font family
mainly that Google font that we saw and
now our style guide from front of mentor
I am going to sort of cheat a little bit
and I'm going to copy
the breakpoint styles that I've used in
the past just to be a little bit quicker
but I'm going to explain this and
everything that
we're doing here
so what happens is when you're usually
writing a media query you write it
something like this so media Min Dash
width
and then something like 50 EMS and then
you're going to write your Styles in
here
[Music]
um what we're going to do is we're going
to use a mix-in so that we can reuse the
code every time we need to write a media
query so we don't have to type all this
out you know Min with a 50 EMS the other
advantage of this of course is since
we're using this mix-in if we want to
ever change the 50 EMS to like 64 EMS
then we don't have to go and do a huge
final replace through all our Styles we
can just change it in one place here in
our breakpoints file so this is why
we're spending a little extra time
setting this stuff all up
so what happens here is in the mix-in
The Mixing will basically load reusable
code that you want to use multiple times
in your code base so we create the mixin
by saying at mixin then we type in the
name of the mix and we want to use which
is in this case the first one break
point and then break point is going to
have a parameter so it's kind of like a
function and the parameter that's going
to use is size
so then when we're loading this
breakpoint mix in it's going to load the
code that we don't want to you know keep
typing out every time so it's going to
load the media query Min width and then
instead of typing the number we're using
a map get so this is a SAS map it's kind
of like a like an array or an object and
in this breakpoint mixing is getting the
map called Break points up
and then it is
putting the size variable in there
so what happens is it's going to load
the breakpoints up map and then whatever
size you want to use in your mix-in so
we have these saved here so it's medium
large extra large and I've already set
the widths and EM units here and then
the content is going to be whatever
content you put in the mixing one you're
actually using it in your Styles so just
as an example if we wanted to use this
mix and break point
we would in our other styles we would
say include
let me scoop scoop it here so if we
wanted to use this mix-in in our
code elsewhere we would type in include
break point
and then parentheses and then we would
choose the size that we wanted to set
this media query at so let's say we
wanted to do large and up
so we'll say include breakpoint large
and then you know whatever rule you want
to add in here so font size I don't know
three Rems or something and usually this
mix in for SAS would be included inside
it would be nested inside the actual
selector so we would
actually write it inside the selector in
this example we're using H1 so this
would load the breakpoint in the H1 tag
and the resulting CSS would look
something like H1 and then font size
three Rems and that would be in
immediate query so media Min width
and the large width is 87.5 EMS
so it'd be something like this
doesn't seem like a whole lot of
maybe benefit from just writing this one
time maybe it seems like it's almost the
same amount of work you know writing
include breakpoint large as it would be
to write out the media query and that is
kind of true but again if we ever wanted
to change this 87.5 EMS it would be kind
of a hassle to have to go through find
every media query and update that so
it's just easier in the long run to use
the mix-in for that
foreign and the other mixing that we
have here is break point down and this
is when you want to use the max width so
if we wanted to write some styles for
medium width and small but we don't want
to do it for large usually I try to just
stick with them in with media query so
this break point up mix in because
usually the desktop Styles have
additional rules at you know mobile and
tablet may not have because the mold
sign is usually a bit simpler than
desktop design for example mobile
designs all the content is often stacked
to one column versus desktop you have
the content in multiple columns so you
need those extra rules for you know
flexboxer grid to do that
so that's kind of a quick little crash
course in how this works
so now that we've written the first util
SAS rules we want to include this
breakpoints.scss file when we're
importing it from the util folder so to
do that we're going to go back to the
index.scss file in the util folder
and we're going to import the breakpoint
SAS file with forward
break points
and what this does is it doesn't do
anything to the color but it basically
just takes all these styles that we
wrote and then when we use the util
in our other styles it's going to take
all those Styles there so you can use it
in any file that you need to
okay the next file we're going to work
with is the functions file in the util
folder and again I'm going to sort of
cheat a little bit I'm going to copy
Styles I've used in the past and this is
the only thing that's going to be in
this file it's a function that will
convert pixels to grams
you can see here I included the link
here it's from a CSS tricks article
so to use this function let's say in
another SAS file we want to set the font
size of an H1 to maybe like 30 pixels
so in the past if you've seen my other
videos I would pull out my calculator
and divide 30 by 16 to get to rims
and this is because 16 pixels equals one
Rems by default on most browsers unless
you change that in your settings
so we need to divide 30 by 16 to get
rims
and we can use this function to do that
so
we'll say REM
and we just use the number here we're
not using the unit
so if we say that the resulting CSS is
going to look like font size
30 pixels or I'm sorry it's going to be
whatever Rems this is which I guess we
can pull out the calculator one last
time here 30 divided by 16 is 1.875
.
1.875 Rems
so
this is this is the only purpose of this
function but it is kind of helpful just
so I don't have to keep pulling out the
calculator I think there are other npm
packages or probably even vs code
extensions that will sort of do this for
you automatically but I just like doing
this here
um so that I'm not dependent on having
to install another tool but you can do
that if you want
so I'll just delete that since we don't
really need it now let's start adding
our colors actually before that let's
make sure the functions gets forwarded
into our util maintenance one so forward
functions
okay so let's close these since we don't
really need them
now let's do the colors and if you
remember we were just looking at the
style guide here
and we're going to create variables in
our colors SAS file for all the colors
that they've given us
so I guess we'll just do this one by one
I'm just going to copy each section here
and we'll edit out everything we don't
need
this is not correct syntax wise for SAS
but we just want to have everything here
okay so that's all the colors
so we'll start creating our variables
so when you're we're not going to use
Jasper Ables because CSS has come out
with CSS variables or css custom
properties and that's something that we
kind of have to use because we're doing
the dark light thing and it doesn't work
with SAS variables very well
this is because you can change the value
of the CSS variable with JavaScript you
know without having to reload things
so
root and usually we call it Dash Dash
and I think I'm just gonna yeah say the
colors
lime green
maybe you will say lime green one word
that's right is that right okay let's uh
let's check here see it says variables I
haven't worked with these
a ton so yeah okay I was right so dash
dash name the color and then the value
I just work with SAS variables for so
long that it just kind of sticks in my
mind
okay that seems Right add a semicolon
so we'll do bright red
and we're using hsl instead of the hex
colors because hsl which stands for Hue
saturation and lightness so that's each
of these three parameters here are it's
a better way of changing the lightness
or darkness of a color if you are using
hsl
so I think it seems like people are just
using hsl more nowadays than hex so
you know just trying to stay on top of
stuff
okay so we'll do Facebook
Instagram
oh sorry Twitter is first
this is a linear gradient so
Instagram start
not super creative with the naming here
but you know
Instagram and
[Music]
YouTube
just gonna delete these as I go so we
know where we've been
toggle
there's a linear gradient which my guess
is
I have the design open here
there's a toggle and then there's the
background gradient which is what I am
guessing this means
because there's a linear gradient and
then the toggle itself which I'm
guessing is the circle of the toggle
I guess we'll find out but maybe I'll do
toggle
background start
and we'll just have to remember that
this is going to be a linear gradient
and
the cool thing about vs code is that
when you put a color in it'll actually
give you a little
Swatch of what the actual color is going
to look like so it helps and I'll just
say toggle for this other one here
okay
now
Dark theme and then the light theme
I think I need to go back to my notes to
see how the theme works just so that we
can
make sure we're setting things up right
at the beginning
so
to work okay
now this is the prefers color scheme
thing
okay first color scheme dark we would
put the variables like here within this
prefers color scheme
media query
I think I want to find one for
light dark mode toggle
I think what I can do is
what I'm guessing is going to happen is
for the we'll make the light theme I
guess the default
and then for the Dark theme if you set
it to dark mode then we would still need
CSS variables for each color but we
would you know set the background to
this color when it's in dark mode so I
think we can still set all the colors in
here and then we will separate them out
with the dark and the light modes later
on with other styles and using that
prefers color scheme media query so
we'll just go ahead and do
this
and in terms of the naming naming is
kind of the hardest part I've found
maybe not the hardest but naming takes a
lot more time than you might think to
name things in a way that makes sense
and that you'll remember later or the
other developers will be able to
understand if they take on a project
that you know you're not working on
anymore so because these are going to be
the dark mode I might just say dark Dash
and then these are actually named so
very dark blue is for the background top
background pattern card background text
and then other text
and then we have the same names with the
light values on the second part so I
think I'm going to say dark and then
sort of use the same names here so dark
background
and then dark
uh top background yeah I think this
should work and dark
um card back or maybe discard
since there's only one card color given
here and then dark
text one
and then we'll say dark text two will be
this
so we can always rename things later on
if a different kind of name would make
more sense so we did the dark colors now
so I think what I can do is Ctrl D to
just duplicate that and we'll rename
things for the light mode oops oh I
include the toggle and I didn't want
that
just like the lines you need control D
will duplicate those lines
light
and then we will
copy these so the background light
top background
card background and then text one and
text two okay awesome and we're done
with these so this is all the Styles we
need for our colors so now that we're
done with this we just want to make sure
that we are doing the same thing so
forward colors
and the last thing I want to make sure
we have is the font styles
so if we go into our style guide
the fonts is this inter font here
let's get that font
and weights 400 and 700 so in Google
fonts
scroll down to 400 select the style and
then we also want 700 bold so we've
selected those Styles and now we're
going to just copy this stuff here and
we're going to go into our index.html
file
and we want to Glow the fonts
I don't know if I need to add this
comment but Google fonts just so we
remember
then we need to add the font family
and you know this might seem a little
Overkill but I'm going to create a
variable for the font
a font enter
and we just need the value and I didn't
add it to the root element
there you go so now let's say in the
body we want to say font family
and we'll call that variable by saying
VAR font enter
and that's kind of how you use CSS
variables so we'll be adding those later
on
okay so don't know the fonts so let's
close that
go into our index make sure we're
forwarding
fonts
it was
I think it was plural
check
yeah fonts plural okay so then let's
just double check this so in our util
folder we got our index file which is
open here breakpoints
colors fonts are there functions are
there okay perfect so now we are done
with the util styles
so we're done with our util Styles okay
the next thing we're going to set up is
our Global style so kind of in the same
way that we did with util Styles we're
going to go into our Global subfolder
and we're going to create some SAS
Styles so in globals I'm going to say
boilerplate this is where I put a lot of
default styles
and I'm going to create another one for
typography
this is for
styles for the text elements like the H
tags and the anchor links and things
like that
so I think it's just those two for right
now we might add more later
but for now we'll stick with these two
okay so in our Global index SAS file
we're going to do the same thing that we
did in our util and use the forward rule
so we'll say forward
and I'm just going to add them all even
before I add these Styles into our
globals
so boilerplate
and then we'll say typography
good there
so for the boilerplate Styles one thing
I do is HTML
and I like to say font size 100 this
helps with accessibility and I'm going
to say box sizing
Order Box
and this ensures that if you add padding
to an element the total width is going
to include the padding not be in
addition to the to the padding so let's
say we had like a div and we said width
is 300 and then we set a padding of 20
pixels if we have box sizing border box
the width plus the pen is still going to
be just 300 pixels
um if you don't do it I think content
box is the other option let's just let's
see here
yeah I think contact box
so we want border box if you if you
don't use border box basically and you
set the width 300 in the padding all
around to 20 pixels it would be the
width would be 300 plus 20 pixels on the
left 20 pixels on the right 40 pixels
would be 340 pixels wide usually you
want the width to be what you set it to
so it's better to include the padding in
there now we want to inherit this box
sizing property from all elements so
before
well B4
and then after
so box sizing inherit it's going to
inherit that from the HTML element then
for body I usually like to do some
resets so I'll say margin zero
padding zero and then we'll set the font
family
to that font that we just created so
font enter
and I think that should be good for our
boilerplate styles
okay so we're done with that and now
we're going to add our typography Styles
and we'll probably add some more stuff
here but for now let's just start with
the H tags and I personally like to set
the margin top to zero
just because in your browser default
you'll have a margin on the top and the
bottom I like setting it to zero and
then we'll set the bottom margins you
know later on the other thing I want to
do is for the anchor links
a visited
and I think a active
text decoration none so we don't have
the underline yeah all right so that is
good for typography
and let's just check one more time make
sure things are here and that's good and
in our Styles we are using globals okay
you might be wondering why I haven't
done a use for the util Styles the
reason for that is in utils I'm using
things like SASS mixins and functions
and variables and actually I think I
need to move these all the CSS variables
into the globals because what happens is
for the util something like the mix-in
it's not going to this is not going to
on its own generate any CSS so
we only need to include it when we're
actually using this mix in in whatever
SAS files whereas for things like colors
we actually do want this to get
forwarded in the main SAS file because
you know we need to access these
variables and this is not a SAS thing
so any of the SAS things like functions
which aren't going to generate CSS is
what I like to keep in the util
so yeah I'm just used to using SAS
variables
so we just need to change things out a
little bit so I'm going to move the
colors because we're using CSS variables
and the fonts to the globals
so that should be right and now we'll
delete it from the
util stuff
so yeah things are
always changing
um so now we need to forward
I might actually put these on top I
don't know if it matters but forward
fonts
and colors okay so this should work and
we'll find out when we start setting up
our gulp workflow
and compiling our SAS files okay so we
have our util and our Global setup and
the last we want to do is our components
so kind of in the same way we have we're
going to create a lot of components as
we build this thing I'm just going to
start with a couple that I think we're
going to need
so in the components folder we'll create
a new file
and I'm just going to say since we have
those cards in the social media
dashboard I'll say card
Dot scss and then we'll just create
another one called toggle
dot scss this is mainly so that I can
just add some test Styles so you can see
you know what we need to do so we'll
just make some
sort of fake-ish styles for element of
class of card we'll just say I don't
know padding REM
so we're gonna use that function that we
created REM let's say 20.
[Music]
so well 20 pixels all around
and this is something that we can use to
test when we're compiling our SAS and if
it doesn't cause an error and it it
outputs you know Ram of whatever 20
pixels is then we'll know it works and
so the other one will also do toggle
and we'll say
we'll add some nested stuff so maybe
toggle toggle button
and we'll say We'll Pretend This is the
styles for that Circle in the toggle so
border radius
50 percent
maybe we'll add the color too so color
we'll say width and again this is just
like made up styles so 16 pixels we'll
say this is the height of 16 pixels
board arrays of 50 and let's just say
background color
and we'll use our what that color was
toggle so it's just toggle
there we go
okay so we have talk we have card and
now we want to add the components so I
think we'll add four word
card
forward toggle
all right so these are the starter SAS
files we're obviously going to be adding
a lot more stuff in our SAS files later
on but for now let's just close all
these out
[Music]
and
oh actually one thing I forgot so in our
other SAS files what we need to do in
order to use this Ram function here is
we need to import the util Styles so
what we usually do is add use
and then we need to get to the util load
utils from wherever we are here so we're
in the components folder so we need to
go one up
and then go to util
just load it like that and when you use
use we have to give it a namespace
so I think by default it will add a
namespace
um
of whatever the name is but I kind of
want to not have to say you know util
dot whatever for all the styles that we
wrote so if you import it as a wild card
then you can just use the names of you
know the variables or the other thing
that you created
without having to use the namespace so
it's a little bit easier but namespacing
can come in handy if you're you know say
importing styles from a library or you
just have so many styles that they kind
of conflict you might have something
like a variable or a mixing that's
called the same thing from the two
different styles so it's in that case if
you have that many styles that they're
conflicting then you can use a namespace
to differentiate between which one you
actually want to use but in this case
since this is just you know a one-page
sort of web app we shouldn't have to use
namespaces but we can always add it
later on so we need to take this Rule
and we also want to add it to our toggle
styles
um because we're using the REM stuff
here
thinking about this variable here so
like I'm wondering if we would also need
to do a use of the globals I'm not sure
so you know we'll see what happens
because I think
the way the variables for CSS work is
it's set on the root element so since
we're loading the global Styles already
in our main SAS file it should be fine
it should be able to read that but we'll
see what happens when we compile
everything now we are actually done with
our SAS styles
it's going to exit out of everything
here
and we already have our script file
we're good with that and the last thing
I want to create is a new folder called
dist and this is where we're going to
put our compiled CSS and minified CSS
and JavaScript files to load that in our
index.html
so let me actually create a reference to
the both of those files that we don't
have in existence right now we are going
to generate them with our gulp workflow
so
so okay this is in the head
so after the fonts we'll load our styles
so link
CSS
and this is coming from the dist folder
of course so we're going to say slash
dist
style.css
and then we'll load script
source
uh dist
script.js and I think I want to either
set I think I might want to set this to
defer
um because in the past you would have to
load the script tag at the bottom of
your body
but I think
we can put at the top but just set it
defer to it so let's look that up
it's a little Javascript file
prefer
see what comes up
[Music]
Flavio coats it can always depend on
Flavio to have written a blog post about
something that you're looking at
okay so when loading a script on an HTML
page you need to be careful not to harm
the loading performance of the page
okay so yeah script is traditionally
including the page this way
if this is bad to put the script in the
head
because there's a lot of delay reduced
introduced
so very common solution to this is to
put the script tag at the bottom of the
pages for the clothing body tag which is
what I usually do
[Music]
oh I wonder if this is actually the best
practice here
oh so you have to do that if you need to
support older browsers that don't
support these new features async and
defer
these are the new things async can defer
you specify both async takes precedence
on Modern browsers while older browsers
that support defer but not async will
fall back to defer
so they're used they only make sense
when you're using the script in the head
okay
so let's see
so no defer or no I think we don't want
that
async blocks parsing on the page while
deferred is not neither is in order for
a guarantee anything on blocking
rendering
okay then the bottom to tell me the best
way best thing to do just be at your
page is to put them in the head and add
a deferred attribute okay
thank you Flavio
there we go
[Music]
okay so now that we're done with our SAS
files and loading our JavaScript file at
least for now we're going to set up our
gulp workflow and we're using gulp to
compile our SAS to CSS as you can see
the SAS files are very different from
when you're writing styles with CSS with
the functions mix-ins
and also the nesting Styles so browsers
can't read SAS files so you have to use
some kind of tool a build tool to
compile or convert your SAS files to CSS
there are vs code extensions that you
can use I used to use the live SAS
extension a lot however it doesn't
support the new SAS views and forward
rules it only supports the old import
rules and those are getting deprecated
by SAS sometime the next couple years so
you kind of want to get used to writing
the new syntax unfortunately that
extension the livestock extension has
not been updated in I think two years so
you know you can find a different
extension if you want to try the new
syntax with SAS or you can use the scope
workflow
so we don't really need this file so
let's open our terminal window
set up gulp and install a bunch of npm
packages for our workflow so the first
thing you want to do when you're working
with gulp is you want to make sure you
have the gulp CLI installed so you if
you don't have it
gold Dash CLI I already have this
installed but if you don't have gulp CLI
installed you can install it this way
using the dash G and that will install
it globally on your computer so you can
run gulp CLI from any
any folder on your computer so now we
want to First
create our package Json file so I'm
going to say npm this is very long it's
kind of bugging me actually
um let's just rename our folder here
close folder
I'm just going to rename this to social
dashboard I think or maybe just dark
light toggle because that's kind of the
main thing I was thinking about
okay so now it's the dark light toggle
we want to create our package Json file
so npm install sorry npm
init Dash I
so now we have our package Json file
we can now install a bunch of npm
packages that we need so npm install and
I am going to be using my gulp config
that I have from previous projects
so I will but I will still walk you
through how all that works so we want to
install a bunch of packages so the first
one is Babel
core and babble
preset Dash EnV and this is used for
auto prefixer there's some CSS
properties that need to use browser
prefixes like webkit for browsers that
don't support the sort of full thing so
for example one property for that is
transform so transform is a property
that is supported in modern browsers but
for older browsers they may need to use
the dash webkit prefix so Babel will
work with auto prefixer to determine you
know which properties get prefixed
automatically so that way you don't have
to type it out yourself so just another
way that you can save time so Babel and
then we're going to install post CSS
this is
a collection of plugins that auto
prefixer is a part of
so you have to install both of them I
believe to use Auto prefixer
then we're going to install browser sync
and this will
when we run gulp it's going to spin up a
local server and it will sort of keep
watching your files and reload the
website anytime you make a change so you
don't have to manually reload in your
browser then we're going to install CSS
Nano
for minifying our CSS and we're going to
install Dart Dash SAS
because this is the version of SAS that
supports this new syntax with the use
and the forward and stuff like that so
we need to install that specifically if
we want to use those new rules then
we're going to install gulp because we
need gulp gulp babble
for the Babel stuff gold oops gulp
post CSS
gulp SAS that will do the SAS compiling
and then gulp terser which we're going
to use to Minify our JavaScript files
so hit enter
hopefully I didn't make any mistakes
and we should see all those npm packages
added here in our package Json file
all right no errors installing which is
great so now in our package Json we can
see all the packages that we added in
here now one thing you want to notice is
found three vulnerabilities so kind of a
cool thing that npm does when he
installs it'll actually tell you if the
versions you've installed have any
security vulnerabilities so
I don't know if this is the right way to
do it but I will just write npm audit
fix if I can sometimes I'll type in npm
audit just to see which packages they're
talking about
so it looks like yards parser which is
used in Gulp and then glob parent which
is used in this gulp thing too
and then another dependency of gold so
I usually will just type npm audit fix
to see if this will work
but I think it may not because it says
three vulnerabilities require manual
review
um yeah fix zero so
not great but they're low and moderate
so I'm just going to kind of leave it
they're not high security
vulnerabilities so I think it's kind of
okay I'm not super familiar with this
part of npm
and all the dependency Securities so
feel free to you know flaming the
comments this is a terrible thing to do
um but yeah if it's not like a high
level I'm just gonna
just gonna leave and keep going yeah so
now we have our dependencies installed
the next thing we want to do is start
working with our gulp workflow so in our
route we're going to create a new file
called gulp file.js
and and here's where we're going to
write all our configuration for gold and
again I am going to cheat a little bit
and use a previous gulp file
configuration and just copy and paste
that here
but let me kind of walk you through
what's going on here
so in a gold file this is a JavaScript
thing that you run on the command line
using node and this is what we're going
to use to compile and Minify all our
files so at the top of your gulp file
we are importing all of the npm packages
that we just installed as modules into
this file so that we can access them and
any functions that they give us that's
what this top section is then if you
scroll down a little bit this is setting
the SAS compiler to use Dart SAS and
this is again so that we can use that
new use and forward syntax in our SAS
rules so the next thing we need to do is
we need to actually compile our SAS and
JavaScript files and that's what this
next section here is so we have a SAS
task and it's a function called scss
task and what this is doing is it's
running you know multiple different
things and they are using this pipe
function that's a gulp function to sort
of run them one after the other so what
this is saying is this first line is
taking the main SAS file so at
scssstyle.scss and it is going to do
stuff to this file and in here this
option is setting Source maps to true
SAS Source maps are it's an extra file
that's generated and they're really cool
because when you are testing your
website in your browser and looking in
the developer tools when you inspect a
certain set of styles it will actually
tell you the SAS the original SAS file
and the line number where it came from
instead of you know some location in
your minified CSS file which is kind of
impossible to find so Source Maps just
makes things a lot easier when you're
trying to debug and see where some style
rule is coming from
so we're saying Source Maps is true so
we'll create a source map and then after
that we are piping the next thing we
want to run which is the SAS function
this is coming from the gulp SAS module
so it's running SAS you compile the SAS
to CSS then after that we're going to
run the post CSS plugins Auto prefixer
and CSS Nano so Auto prefixer as I
mentioned before it will add the browser
prefixes to sort of support older
browsers for those rules for those CSS
properties like transform that need the
prefixes and then cesus Nano will Minify
the CSS file then the last line here is
it's going to set the destination of the
final compiled CSS file into the folder
called dist which we created beforehand
you can see that right here and then the
option here is to set the location of
your Source Maps file which this dot
means is going to be set in the same
location that we just indicated in the
dist folder
so that's what we do for our SAS files
now if we go into JavaScript we're doing
a very similar thing so we're taking the
Javascript file which is app.js
script.js setting Source Maps is true
which is a similar thing as our SAS
Source Maps next thing I want to do is
we want to run the file through Babel
and Babel is going to you know make any
modern JavaScript like es6
compiled to an older version that older
browsers can support because not all
browsers can read es6 I think the only
accession right now is IE 11 which is
losing support everywhere so
you don't have to include this but I
just like to do it in case you have
those edge cases where a user might be
using an old browser because you know
their company is still using Windows 7
for some strange reason because they
don't want to pay the money to update to
newer version of Windows so things like
that where people may not be able to you
know use the most modern browsers and
the next line is using Tracer to Minify
our Javascript file and then the last
line is similar to what we have with the
SAS task where it's setting a
destination of the compiled file into
our dist folder and then also having the
source map saved in the same location so
that's JavaScript task so next thing
we're going to do is we're going to add
our browser sync functions and this is
as I mentioned earlier browser sync will
spin up a local server and sync it to
your files and anytime you make a change
it's going to automatically reload your
local website so you don't have to
manually hit you know control R every
time you make a change that's another
way you can save time with build tools
like this so what this first function
does is it spins up the browser sync
server so this is saying
browsersync.init
server and we want to run the base
directory of the server from the root
location where the gulp file is which is
here
and then the notify options here are
just for the the styles that you'll see
in your terminal when you're running
browser sync and then it's using a
callback function at the very bottom to
indicate that it's finished running next
function is a shorter function it's a
browser sync reload so it's saying this
will literally just reload the browser
sync server that we spun up and we want
to combine this reload function with our
watch task so we're telling gulp to
actually watch these files so for
example this first watch task function
is going to watch our HTML files and
then if it detects any changes in them
it's going to run browser sync reload
which will reload The Local website and
then the second part of our watch task
is it's going to watch any SAS or
JavaScript files and if it detects any
changes it's going to rerun our SAS task
and our JS task and then also reload the
browser so those are all the functions
that do stuff at the very bottom of your
gulp file we're going to to export our
default gulp task and the default gulp
task is what gulp will run when you type
in gulp on the command line to start
everything off
and so in our default gulp task we want
to run all our tasks so SAS task JS task
then we want to serve up the browser
sync server initialize it and then we
want to run our watch task and the watch
task is what we'll keep running when we
are doing development detect the changes
and then reload our website and rerun
all of our other tasks so I know that
was kind of fast I hope this makes sense
I am going to include a link to this
whole project for on my GitHub repo that
you know I've created here so I'm going
to include a link to all that down below
in the description so you can refer to
it if needed so now we have our gulp
file
make our terminal a little bit bigger
so what we want to do is we've already
installed our packages so I think all I
have to do is just type in Gulp and see
if things work
okay error
in plug and gulp SAS it says gulp sas5
does not have a default SAS compiler
please set one yourself
um
weird
I thought I did said
in my gold foil
task compiler cold sus5 does not have a
default SAS compiler so what I do when I
see errors like this is I literally will
copy this
and do a go search for it this next line
says both the SAS and notes has packages
are permitted so I wonder if
maybe that's the reason I don't need to
say require I'm not really sure so let's
just anyway copy this
go to Firefox
do a search induct.go for this error
message and see what happens
okay
good old stack Overflow so this happened
eight days ago so this is a very recent
occurrence gulp sass recently updated to
version 5.0 they describe that it
doesn't use a compiler anymore you have
to install it in separately
so they have documentation on how to let
Globe flash require the compiler with
this piece of code
okay so I did do similar syntax to this
instead of requiring SAS I wrote
required Dart SAS
so I wonder if there's some issue with
that and I rolled back to version four
okay
so what I'm wondering is because I know
that the dart SAS version of SAS is the
one that has a new syntax I wonder if
maybe that's included in the default
stuff let's see okay
okay oh migraine you're using products
to version five
we need the migration guide
let's do this so you can read so I'm not
blocking anything
[Music]
where were we migrating okay golf test
version requires node 12 or later
including breaking changes
um additionally changes in note itself
means that we should no longer use node
fibers to speed up asynchronous
rendering with dart SAS
so I want to see what they're saying
about Dart says
you haven't saw sass which I did
in far south report okay so this is a
new syntax we used to recommend node
fibrouses away but node fibers are
discontinued
it's not saying that we have to
I mean I guess we can just try this
since this is the
default thing that they said
these SAS equals require gulps test and
then requires SAS
so go up here paste that in
I'm just going to comment this out for
now
so I wonder if darts house is now just a
default SAS version
so what I could do is do another search
for Dart SAS 5 Dart SAS
and just see if anything comes up
oh here we go Dart SAS is also
distributed as the pure JavaScript SAS
package on npm
all right so I guess I don't have to
explicitly say Dart SAS for the compiler
okay so now let's see if this works
we'll rerun gulp
oh
let's see what happened here
module not found
cannot find module SAS wait did I not
even install SAS itself
oh it's all dart SAS not SAS
I guess that was a mistake
let's npm install SAS
okay so now I have SAS in our
package.json
rerun gold
oh so the
okay so this is our website which is
good I did see an error
so let's take a look at that but I'm
glad this worked
um here we go
um deprecation warning using the slash
for division is deprecating we removed
and dart SAS oh my gosh
it's recommendation recommendation
math.div pixels and then context
oh they actually fix it for you
oh that's pretty smart
so I guess for some reason the slash I'm
guessing maybe this has to do with the
maybe SAS module or something I'm not
really sure
so instead of division
you just go math.div and then say
whatever and instead of the division is
just a comma so
go back into our code and change that
wow lots of new changes in SAS recently
is in our function SAS file
so okay let's just make sure so instead
of this thing here
we're gonna say
math.div
okay
and then there's another error there's
no module with the namespace math so I
think I need to import that it's a it's
like a separate SAS module thing
let me let's look that up so SAS math
I think we need to do an explicit like
import
okay sasmath
um so it's part of the built-in modules
here so let's look
if they tell you the best way to do this
okay so here's an example use SAS colon
color and this is for the color module
and this is the math module so I'm
assuming
use SAS math so we'll have to add this
at the top of this
for you SAS math so that this math.div
is accessible because before since we
didn't import the math module it doesn't
know this math.div even is so hopefully
I think that's the only error other
error that we saw
now I've hopefully fix this we're going
to have to do a control C
to exit out of our gulp task and rerun
it all right no errors yay so we loaded
the website so we just want to make sure
that everything is loaded so I'm going
to go back to the right side so I want
to make sure that our console log
messages yep hello
so that loaded which is good and then
the second thing I want to check is
going back into our code
and opening up
inner dist folder the script.js file so
that's there that's good and then our
final CSS file so let's take a look here
I'll do an ALT Z word wrap
so we can see our files here we have our
Global files from the boilerplate which
is great and then we have the card style
that I added and the toggle button
hey looks pretty good let's do another
test in our index.html file I'm just
going to use the H1 tag since I created
some
styles for that oops H1 enter
and I'll just say social media dashboard
we'll just do this for now just to test
the Styles okay so we noticed that when
we save the index.html file it did
reload so let's check here oh here we go
see if all those Styles we wrote are
added in here
the margin top of zero which is from the
typography
thing and then is getting the font
family
nice and then you can see the Styles
added here this is really good
so yeah it looks like everything's
working so now that we have our files
and folders set up and we have our SAS
and gulp workflow up and running we can
start actually building this website but
before we get too excited and jump in
and start writing code I usually try to
go back to design and sort of get a lay
of a land and see what my Approach is
going to be before writing code just to
make sure we're not making any wrong
decisions at the very beginning so let's
check out the design so I have the
design from fortnite mentor open here in
figma and if you've seen my other videos
you know usually I have a free plan a
front of mentor and they just give you
jpegs but I got the pro plan for this
one because I just wanted to show you
all what the real world experience is
you know getting the design from a
designer and then having to work from
that and build it and I actually haven't
used figma before I've always used Adobe
XD at work and sketch in the past as
well but I'm guessing it should be
pretty similar to Adobe XD and looking
at the design here we can see that it
has the desktop dark mode
and then it has the mobile design as
well and we have the desktop and mobile
for the light mode
and they're also
really nice and they give you some the
the hover Styles so that's very helpful
and I haven't always gotten that in the
past
and this is pretty normal in terms of
what you get from a designer usually
they'll just give you a desktop and a
mobile design
I have gotten a tablet design from a
designer maybe three times in my entire
life so usually what I've done is just
kind of merge the mobile and desktop
designs together for tablet view just
try to make sure things look okay and
sort of use your best judgment so even
though I'm a developer I do sort of have
to make some design decisions sometimes
you can always go back to the designer
have them look at what you've built and
have them give you any feedback on it so
now that we have the design what I like
to do is look at the design and see what
the sort of General container size is
how things change from desktop to mobile
design so in terms of the container what
I mean by that is
if you're thinking about someone who has
a really wide monitor you know how wide
is the content going to be because
obviously you don't want to go all the
way across because then that kind of
makes it not very readable
so if we look at the design here we
click on this rectangle it tells us that
it is 1110 pixels wide so that's what
our container Max width is going to be
so we're going to come back to this when
we start writing our Styles but just in
general it's good to see what this is
set up
and I want to see how this grid layout
changes from desktop to Mobile so on
desktop we have this four column grid if
we scoot over to the mobile design
it Stacks to one column and again this
is a very common design pattern going
from desktop to mobile for content in
multiple columns
so if we go back we can see what some
other changes are let's check out the
text sizes as well so
look at the headline here social media
dashboard if we look on the right side
it is using the inter font which we
added to the site already and it says
it's bold and 28 pixels tall
so that's the desktop style so let's see
if it's any different for mobile
so we'll just go in figma kind of Click
until we
select just the headline text and it
looks like it is inter bold and 24
pixels so the H1 tag this is going to be
the H1 tag goes from 24 pixels in Mobile
8 pixels on desktop so that's good to
know right and of course these are
probably going to shrink as well so this
is 24 pixels on desktop
and let's see here might be the same
actually 24 pixels on mobile so you know
these are just things that it's good to
see how they change from desktop to
mobile and I think just the last thing
was let's look at the sort of body text
for this this is 12 pixels it's pretty
small
so I'm guessing it's not going to get
any smaller on mobile
um yeah 12 pixels so the numbers look
pretty much the same as well so there's
not a ton of changes between desktop and
mobile there are some layout changes
obviously going from the four column to
one column on mobile let's look at one
more thing and that is you know when you
have items in Grid whether you're
building it with flexbox or css grid
sometimes the order might change between
desktop and mobile so for example here
the cards we have Facebook Twitter
Instagram and YouTube it's probably
gonna be the same so Facebook Twitter
Instagram YouTube on mobile so that's
the same and I did want to check on the
order of this bottom grid because you
can see it's Facebook has two cards
Instagram is two cards they each have
two cards so let's see what they do on
mobile for that
scroll down here
looks like the order is the same so it's
Facebook has two cars Instagram Twitter
and then YouTube and I did want to check
on that just because you know I could
imagine maybe on mobile I don't know why
they do this but you know what if it was
ordered by Page views
of Facebook and then profile views of
Instagram and things like that and then
grouping the likes together but
obviously it makes a little more sense
to group things by the social media
platform first and then inside the
social media platform the different
metrics that are being tracked so
this looks pretty straightforward
there's text changes from desktop to
mobile there are layout changes from
four columns to one column on desktop to
mobile and the order doesn't change
which you know obviously we could do
that if we had to but it's sort of nice
when you don't have to worry about the
order changing and I think the toggle is
the same as well so yeah so there we go
okay so now we can start kind of
building out our Styles and I think I'm
going to focus on just building the dark
mode version of this dashboard in
today's video and then we'll worry about
the light mode and then the dark light
toggle logic and all that in the next
video so let's just build this you know
make sure it has all the styles from the
design make sure it's responsive alright
so I'm going to start going from top to
bottom because that's usually how I
build things so the first thing we're
going to build is this top sort of title
bar with the title The follower count
and then the toggle itself and again
we're just kind of making sure it looks
like the design I'm not going to worry
about any of the logic right now we will
try to get the markup as close as what
we think it will need to be for when we
are building logic in but you know we're
just going to build things as best we
can to our ability and we can always
change things later on
so going into our code editor
if we look at our SAS files over here
we have
components and then we have globals and
of course I already made some Styles in
the last video with the card and then
the toggle Styles but we're definitely
going to be adding to that right now
so I think the first thing I want to do
is maybe set some styles for that
container so that we can set the max
width to that
so I think I'm going to add those Styles
um I could maybe add it in the
boilerplate or I can make another SAS
files and globals for layout so maybe
layout sounds better and this is just
sort of me making up files and names to
my best ability obviously you can create
your Styles any which way you would like
as long as you know they're organized
and kind of understandable for somebody
else
so we'll say layout scss and this is in
the global SAS file
so of course since we made a new SAS
file we need to make sure
that we set it in our index SAS file so
we'll say layout here
so in layout
um what I want to do is first we want to
I think we need to inherit the util
stuff right
trying to see if I can copy it from
another SAS file
here we go so use util as
wild card and that will let us
use the mix-ins and stuff that we
created in the last video
so like the function to convert from Ram
to pixels and then the media query
break point for break points
so if you remember I was looking at the
design and looking at the container size
so this is actually what I'm going to be
setting so I like to use a class name or
something for the container and then I
can reuse that class name to limit the
max width of any of these pieces of
content to you know the container of
1110 pixels
so we're going to say class of container
and I'm just going to say Max width
and it's 1100 pixels but we want to use
Rems because it's more accessible so
we'll use our REM functions so REM
11 110 and we don't need to use pixels
on that because it will automatically
add the unit to it
and this is Max width just in total I
don't need to worry about having a media
query for this because
you know 1100 pixels is pretty wide any
mobile device is going to be narrower
than that so we don't need to worry
about having a different style for
mobile
however we do want to check on mobile
and look at the container there because
there's usually going to be some padding
because you don't want this to go all
the way out to the edges because you
know you kind of need some breathing
room
so if we look at here if I select this
card and I hold down Alt
and then I kind of move my mouse toward
the outside of the element
um figma will tell you how much space
there is so it says 25 on the left 24 on
the right
we're just going to maybe say 25 on both
sides
so what I need to do is I need to add
padding
kind of a global padding because you
know it's going to be the same for all
the different elements so 25 pixels
there 25 pixels here so instead of
having to say 25 pixels of margin or
padding for every single individual
element you know the title the cards
everything we can set it globally in one
place probably with a helper class and
then we know that all the items are
going to inherit that so I think I might
just be able to say padding
um
and then this is probably just going to
be on the left and the right okay so REM
again we're going to use our function 25
pixels
and then we just want it to be on left
and right so I'm going to say 0 for top
and bottom and then 25 pixels for left
and right
now this is going to be our mobile
default Styles we don't really want the
padding for the desktop because then
it's not going to be fitting the design
and being 110 pixels on desktop so I'm
going to use my
breakpoint so break point
and large and up
and we're going to say padding here is
going to be zero so that looks pretty
good
um then I guess if you're curious let's
check out what the CSS the final CSS
looks like here
see here
it's a container class padding of zero
okay and then
um up here container class max width is
you know 69 yada yada rims and the
padding is also set and this second one
is inside this media query so media the
media query breakpoint mixing that we
created results in the immediate query
of Min width of 64 EMS which is what we
set in our
util breakpoint style so 64 EMS is what
we tagged as the large size so when we
set break include breakpoint with a
large parameter automatically makes your
media query for you at the 64 Em's width
so this is usually what I do for
containers where you know you have some
padding for mobile and then you have
zero padding for desktop but then you
sort of limit the width and I think I
also might need to center it because we
want it to be centered on the page for
desktop so I'll do that by saying margin
zero top and bottom and then Auto
and of course we're going to test this
out if things aren't working right we
can always tweak it when we get there so
let's kind of exit out of these other
files that we don't really need and
let's start now actually building some
of the markup
all right now when making the markup I
try to use semantic HTML as much as
possible so for this first thing I think
there's a main tag
and then inside main is I think where
you put all the other content so
let's actually do a little research
so semantic HTML so I'm kind of trying
to see when do you use the main tag
um so let's see what sources are good
all right we'll just go w3schools
because they're decent
okay so
um semantic elements yada yada so
section element Define the section in a
document okay the article element
um let's do a search for Main
okay
hmm that's not super helpful here we go
the HTML main tag specifies the main
content of the document
okay it looks like the main is really
encapsulating everything else
so that seems like something we can do I
just want to make sure
I'm gonna sort of
get a second opinion and look at another
source and see
oh here Mozilla I usually try to go to
Mozilla I'll exactly search for that so
Mozilla
HTML main tag
okay here we go
the authoritative source so the main
HTML element represents the dominant
content of the body okay the main
content area consists of content that's
directly related to or expands upon the
central topic of a document
this is interesting so the header
is separate from the main so it's like
the main maybe is the body of the
content and the header is separate
so I wonder if that means that in our
design
the social media dashboard this stuff
would be considered the header and then
everything in here would be Main and
then each of the grids of cards would be
in a section tag so something like that
so that's kind of what this seems to be
saying
okay that seems pretty good the content
of a main element should be unique to
the document
[Music]
um
so now this example is slightly
different in the main tag it looks like
the headline is here
I think maybe the
header I wonder if that would be more
like if there was you know like a menu
or something at the same time this is
the top and the toggle is sort of in the
header of the body so I think this is
one of those cases where it's not
necessarily one right answer and the
other one's wrong whether to include
this in the main or to have it in the
header tag again you know the purpose of
all these sort of guidelines and rules
for semantic HTML and other things is to
make sure that your code is readable and
understandable so you're not just
putting everything in a div in a span so
I think in this case I can sort of
choose what I want to do and I think I
sort of like the idea of having the
header be kind of separate so I'm going
to do that so
in the main
will be everything else and then we'll
add the header tag here
and we're going to add the social media
dashboard
and I think
the followers content was in there too
and then this dark mode text is I'm
assuming supposed to be part of toggle
so we're just we're just going to move
this around in here obviously we're
going to make some changes to make
things more understandable and then in
the main tag everything else is going to
be here
so let's move that
I think I can hold down alt in an arrow
to move it oh yeah there we go
there's a lot of little shortcuts in vs
code that I still don't know okay and
then you know in the main we're going to
have different section tags for each
section of cards but we'll figure this
out later on so we'll just leave that
blank for now and let's just focus on
the header so
save that
and again this container class that we
created I do want to use that for the
header so and the header will add a
class of
I like to say header or I will give a
class name that matches the the tag name
and this will help with some of the SAS
the bem approach that I use for my SAS
Styles and you'll sort of see this in
practice in a little bit but not a class
of header and I'm going to say add a
class of container as well let's see how
that looks
and it's probably not going to look
super different but
okay here is our website right now
obviously it's very Bare Bones I think
I'm actually going to exit out of this
console here so we have a little bit
more room
okay so here we go
so the header is here and you can see
that in the Styles it has all the styles
from the container class maxed with is
that padding and it should be zero
padding for desktop so let's see if I
just need to make it wider okay there we
go adding zero here
I think just because I'm zoomed in
um
desktop doesn't start till like right
out here it's me I'll make that a little
bit smaller
so let's change
our breakpoint SAS file here so large is
64 EMS and that is 1024 I believe
according to my little comment there
so let's make it smaller let's say maybe
desktop Styles will start at
not sure let me see what some tablet
styles are so let's go to maybe iPad Pro
ooh so it's 11 12. I mean just because
the tablet is using you know 11 12 as
its width doesn't necessarily mean that
has to be you know tablet styles
because
these sizes here it's not necessarily
you know small has to be mobile medium
has to be tablet large has to be desktop
it's more like depending on your screen
size how does the design change so
I think in the interest of making this
sort of reflect the design of it better
I think I'm going to say maybe 950
pixels for
where the large Styles start
so I might regret this later but we'll
see so 950 up and then 9 49 down
so we do need to do some calculations
here so 950 divided by 16 because 16 is
the base font size
and 16 Rems or EMS equals
um I'm sorry 16 pixels equals one rem or
one em based on the root so 59.375
let me just make sure this sort of looks
okay before I add it update the break
points down media query so reloaded I
think
inspect this okay so it's still using
the mobile Styles here let's see what
what point
it's a little bit you know I think this
is okay because you can still see the
inspector on the side so we'll leave it
at that and then we're going to update
the break points down so 949 divided by
16 is 59.3125
three one two five
there we go okay so hopefully we won't
want to change that anymore
Okay cool so now the header has no
padding because it's the desktop Styles
here and as we get smaller we can see
the padding changes you can see that
this kind of moves in with the padding
so that seems pretty good to me
now the second thing we want to do is
get the toggle stuff right because we
want this to be all the way on the right
side and when I'm building stuff I
usually try to kind of start from the
big General Styles and then slowly
progressively work my way down to get
the more sort of detailed style like you
know the font size and the the space
between the text and stuff like that so
right now we're just going kind of big
General so I want to make sure this is
two columns with this title on the left
and the toggle on the right
so
I think what we need to do is
um
I need to figure out what the
toggle markup should be and I believe I
did take some notes on this
last time so
open our notes
file here
um let's see what we said
here we go accessible markup
so this is
the radio buttons and it was supposed to
be a field set Legend with a radio
button list I believe
um
you see I feel like I just had something
else
check out this code pen
okay so the code pen uses a radio button
list
rear button list and then if we go here
the field set Legend and then it looks
like in this div is the on and off each
with an input and a label for each
option
okay so I think I might sort of copy
this approach
let's check out this link on designing
and building toggles which is
Sarah is a very like experienced
authoritative person in the world of CSS
so she is a good source for stuff like
this
see
I'm gonna find the more what markup she
was using
okay it's code pen for it
there we go make a little space there
um
she also is using a field set thing
so this makes me think that I should
also be using that and then there's a
div surrounding the toggle with both
options
and then again it looks like each option
has a label and then a radio input looks
like she wrapped the two inputs in a
span
which is a little bit different from
this one here
actually there's no div
Okay so
it's a little tough because I'm not
super familiar with the toggle stuff
so you just try to find good sources and
see what they do and try to understand
you know why they did what they did
so okay for the toggle I want to be in a
field set at an aria label this is for
screen readers theme switcher value and
then the role is Radio group
not sure what their role thing is
let's look that up so field set role
field Set Roll
and you know I obviously I'm not working
on a deadline per se but you know if I
was if this was a project that I'd do
for work and the deadline was like
coming up really soon I probably
wouldn't be spending as much time
researching these different things but I
have a time now and it's a good learning
experience because I can learn something
that I didn't know before
so let's do a S Ctrl F and search for
roll
the role is maybe an aria thing
it's hard
uh
see if they have a radio group thing
here oh
roll let's go with radio buttons
okay
so I think I'll probably sort of follow
Sarah's approach here so we'll do a
field set with Aria label
and then add a roll of radio group
so going back to our index.html
we'll go field set
I'll delete a dark mode here but dark
mode
okay so field set Aria label I believe
it was
um and this is theme
toggle
and then the roll
was radio group
thank goodness for autocomplete right
okay
so we got that and then she is
encapsulating both toggles in a div
and then each one has label and then
span label and it has a span with the
input type of each option
let me try to zoom out a little bit to
get it
formatted better okay so here we go span
is the wrapper surrounding the light
input the dark input and then
um this is background stuff the
background which is this gray thing I'm
guessing here and then the switcher
which is the pink like button thing
in other sets you are a hidden equals
true because you don't need that with a
screen reader so yeah I really like
Sarah's approach here kind of makes
sense once you delve into it and look at
the words that you don't understand so I
think we'll maybe do the same thing I
might actually put a div in here instead
of a span just because
I don't know I do that
so in here we'll do a div
um
see did a wrapper so I guess I could do
that
so dot and we'll say toggle underscore
underscore wrapper and this is a bam or
block element modifier way of doing a
class and I'll show you what that's
going to look like in the SAS Styles
okay so in the wrapper we have the
inputs and again we're having we have
three inputs based on our research last
time so we'll just do this I might
honestly just like
copy this
input and then the background which I
guess I do need
and then you got a light and dark label
so this one label four light means that
it will associate this label with the
input element of ID of light
and that's outside the toggle wrapper
yes it's outside the wrapper so do that
we'll add another one for dark
and then I think we can just delete this
dark mode
thing
so if we go back to the design
it says dark mode so how does this
change from dark mode to light mode
let's look at the design
hmm interesting
I might change this up from this design
um so that it'll actually say dark mode
in light mode
let's go back to our notes one more time
and look at the example of that three
option toggle here we go
okay so three ones it was like
one
on the left one at the bottom one on the
right so we'll probably we'll probably
do that too
yeah and then
the middle option is going to be the
system preferences I believe I want to
put that one I think it's going to add
it here for now
so let's make one for system preferences
to say ID of system and I think the dark
is going to be on the left side for from
this design yeah so light is on the
right
darks on the left
so we're gonna put dark oops
dark
and then system
and moving these elements around by
holding down alt and then you can use up
and down arrows to scoot it around
so that's a handy little tip that I
found out recently and then I don't know
about what should be default checked I
think we want the system preferences to
be default so I'll just say like that
and I'll add another label for system
preferences
maybe see some pref
and then we'll move the dark up to the
top
and light down to the bottom
this is gonna look pretty ugly I think
oh I forgot to the toggle wrapper so
instead of sea toggles it's going to be
toggle okay now look at our website okay
so we can see now that we have the radio
buttons for our toggle
and then we have the text here
um it looks like there's some default
styles with the field set
Ting a border so we probably aren't
going to set that to none
none
like that
so let's make sure we have our classes
correct in the markup and then we'll add
our Styles so
okay so this is good
I think I'll add a class for the field
set too
I'm gonna say toggle because this is the
sort of parent element of this whole
thing
so we got toggle for the field set and
then we have label and we got toggle
wrapper and we have each of these inputs
and we have the toggle background toggle
Switcher
now I could if I wanted to be really I
guess detailed about I could add a class
with a toggle underscore and a score for
the labels and the inputs but
you just kind of gotta balance out you
know how detailed you want to be I'm
okay just having this toggle thing and
then adding some element selectors so
let's add that now actually so in our
SAS Styles the toggle is it's kind of
our own thing right so I'm going to add
another oh I already made the toggle
component SAS file so here we go I don't
remember if this was something I
actually needed or not I feel like maybe
not oh this is supposed to be the circle
thing toggle underscore underscore
button
so I guess I can add that in here button
so we got toggle
for the field set
and I wanted to get rid of the
order so border none
and then actually let's
um
try to put both of them on the screen
we got the toggle
then we have toggle
wrapper
so this Ampersand means it will inherit
or for lack of a better word what the
parent selector is so the Ampersand in
this case will be toggle and then
underscore underscore wrapper which is
which is what will match the markup
class here so wrapper and then we got
um the input type radio
which I guess will need something so
input
input and then type equals quote
radio
and then we got toggle background
and toggle button we
okay and then I guess we can we'll do
label at the bottom
so I usually try to follow the order
um what else to do sometimes is sort of
sort it by the element so I might put
the label up under the input but let's
just go by order in this case
so now we've got our style name set
let's go back to our site so we can see
in the header we've got our H1 total
followers field set
now I want to group together the H1 and
the text total followers because
looking at the design
[Music]
the social media dashboard title in the
followers Texas groups on the left and
toggle stuff is on the right so I need
to probably put the H1 and the text in a
some kind of container thing so I will
create a div and I'll create a class of
maybe header
underscore underscore title
press enter
select those and move it up there
so now we got header title and then
toggle now for this header stuff here
I'm going to create a new SAS file
called header.scss so you can kind of
see how we break apart the website into
different components and then make sure
we add
header
you will put header first it's going to
put header first in the markup
and then toggle a second
we'll save that
and then in header and this is why I uh
I'll show you here this is why I added
the class of header to the header
element this is so I can do this I can
say dot header
and then again Ampersand for header
underscore underscore title
for this so I do this because if I
didn't have the header here I would have
to say header element and then here I'd
have to I couldn't use the Ampersand
thing so maybe there's another way
around that in terms of making your
Styles you know follow the bem model if
there's a better solution please let me
know in the comments because I don't
have things right all the time but in
our case we're going to say header and
then header title so now what we can do
is for the toggle I'm actually going to
add another class using the header name
and we're going to add the styles for
the layout in the header assess thing so
header toggle oops not tiggle toggle
I know this seems a little bit redundant
but it's going to allow us to keep
things
here in the header Styles and this is to
control the layout so having that title
on one side and then toggle on the other
side so now what I'm going to do is I
think for this header stuff I'm going to
make the header element be a flex parent
and you can also use CSS grid for some
reason just reach for flexbox maybe
because I learned it first before CSS
grid but it's kind of my go-to when I'm
doing layout stuff especially if I'm not
super complex so we'll do header element
it's going to be a flex parent and then
each of the header title and the header
toggle are going to be Flex children now
again we want to do the column stuff
only on desktop so not mobile so I'm
going to use the breakpoint
include break
Point large
and then set display Flex
now
they're going to be on either side so I
think I want to do justify content and
that will control the alignment along
the axis
I want that to be I think space
between
so we'll add any extra space between the
flex child items and then for title and
toggle I think by default if I don't set
the flex property explicitly it'll just
set it to flex of one
so let's check that out
um
thing happened
see if my
my header styles did anything
okay something is not look down here in
our terminal
there is a error the error it says
undefined mixin for the include
breakpoint large and that is because I
didn't do the use
rule
this is the probably one of the biggest
differences with the new SAS module
thing so I kind of forget about that
okay so now
okay so now it worked there's no errors
I'll put this back down here
and
still not
oh wait it only has class container
where's the class of header did I not
save something oh yeah I took I forgot I
took it out
uh
okay
there we go
so now we got the title on the left with
header title
and we got the header toggle on the
right
you can see the max width thing is
working
so
yeah and then on mobile it goes to one
column and two columns here so I know it
doesn't look pretty but we're really
just focusing on these kind of
functional sort of bigger broader Styles
first before we get into each item
so I'm pretty happy with how this is
working yeah it looks pretty good
um
let's see so the next thing would be
probably to start styling the header
title
so obviously this is very different from
what the design looks like right
and I think what we need to do is
actually set the background of the
entire page so let's see what that is so
I'm clicking on the artboard itself and
then here's the fill 1d1 f29 and I
should have
all the colors
um where would the oh and globals colors
here we go
okay so here's the colors
I think this is yeah dark background
so right now I'm just gonna do this and
for the background of the body I will
probably put it in boilerplate yeah
let's do that
foreign
color of white
the dark text too
okay
see how that looks
yay so it's dark now
so let's style this title thing here
so we got the font of inter bold and 28.
let's see this compares to this one here
this is 24.
28 and 24 for the H2
so okay let's add that is this going to
be an H the H1 tag so I'm going to put
it in the globals typography SAS file
so we'll add under the H1 tag style that
I already set
font size and this is for desktop so
we'll add the mobile one right after so
include break point
large font size
Ram function 28.
now at the same time let's check the
mobile one
24.
so font size REM 24 and we'll save
oh
oh I forgot the thing again
there we go okay
I thought that's gonna happen a lot
until I get more used to it
oops here we go inspect
is this the same as a design
I feel like
font the same
is just bigger on here because I'm
zoomed or something like that
the font is inter
see
Georgia
make sure it works
yeah it seems to be loading the font
so if I make this name something that
like doesn't exist it will skip this and
go to the next option which is Georgia
which is a serif font so you can sort of
check and make sure
it's actually working but it seems to be
loading I think maybe it's just the zoom
is a bit different from the design or
something
because like you know I'm zoomed in
quite a bit on page yeah that seems
pretty similar actually
okay cool
so I don't like that it's like
um
right up to the edge like that because
when is this padding that I added okay
so it has a padding now and the padding
goes away
up here this is because the max width is
1110 which I'm
under right now so the problem is I need
to add padding when the viewport's below
1110 so that's why
so I wonder if that means I need to
change my uh break point thing think
about this
so that's in the layout SAS file so I'm
going to do I could do one of two things
I could have this padding no matter what
viewport it is or I can make the large
breakpoint 1110 which maybe I should do
at this point yeah I think I need to do
that because if I add padding on desktop
Styles it'll sort of cut into the width
of the content and
you know in the design file itself this
is like
the whole the con is going all the way
to the sides so
yeah let's adjust this
so this is again something that's very
common
um so let's change this to 1100
10.
and then I'll just zoom out on my
browser so you can see the desktop
Styles better
divided by 16
69.375 so we can just change this like
this
this 1109
all right let's check out our website
again
Okay so
good so now you can see there's padding
right when it gets
to here
it's actually here there's still a
little bit of
I wonder if I make it one pixel less
then it'll um to make this 1109
see if that helps
no I want to go the other way so 111.
oh boy
do you like the weird little things you
kind of get hung up on so 69.4375
so I'm doing is I'm trying to trigger
the desktop Styles which has no padding
a little bit later so that
um hopefully
yeah I don't know what's going on here
I'm actually the air on the side of like
giving it a little bit more
say 11 15.
69.6875
okay
I'm probably spending too much time on
this little thing
it's kind of bugging me when it's like
almost to the edge like that
let's say 11 50.
just really like
go 71.875
71.875
another much later
you can see this
so this is still with the padding there
we go
okay that makes you feel a little bit
better
let's go back and fix the other one so
1150 so this is going to be 11 49.
71.8125
okay much better
yeah so just kind of bothers me when it
was going all the way to the edge like
that
but now we can see it's happily
going up here
I wonder if medium maybe I want it to
have
two columns for medium two
yeah let's do that
um
or was that in the header so include
breakpoint large so I want this to
actually start doing the flexbox thing
at tablet size which is medium
there we go
so now it's going to say two columns
just for a little bit longer
so this is just one of those things
where
you kind of make your best judgment
based on how things sort of end up
looking
all right we're getting somewhere people
okay so we got the text set here now we
want to control the spacing so right now
this is using the default browser
spacing here so it's setting about 16
pixels of margin on the bottom
that looks like it's more space than
what we have in the design here so let's
see what the design actually says oops
so hold down Alt
um this is hard because it gives you a
font size but is there like a line
height thing because this only says
three pixels of space which seems like
very little but maybe that is what it is
try to match the zoom on the design and
the website
see what three pixels of margin bottom
would look like
and I like testing things in the browser
because you know you can just test
things
here
um that looks sort of actually it does
look pretty close
oh does it tell you the line height so
it tells you the font size but oh weird
there's no hey because it's like just
going to be one line
I actually like to set the line height
to
um 1.1 did I do that here
I didn't
this line height is sort of the space
that each line of text takes up so if I
increase that
you know you can see it kind of gets
bigger and bigger
like that
that's obviously too much
I sort of set a line height of 1.1
globally
for H tags
and then that's sort of like a ratio so
it'll as a font size changes it'll the
line type will change with it so that's
one thing I like to do
globally
okay so I think the H1 margin bottom of
three is fine and I'm guessing it's
probably going to be the same for mobile
so let's just set it here
Martian bottom Ram three
[Music]
here we go that looks close to the
design now we do want to also maybe add
some spacing between
the top of this
and the body looks like if we compare
these two looks like it's sort of
centered vertically so there's a bit
more space
up here 49 pixels to the top from the
toggle and 36 here yeah because it's
centered
vertically so to Center vertically we'll
do
the Align
items Center
obviously this is not looking late
should later on
but we're gonna do I want to add some
space so it's not just flush to the top
so I think I'll add maybe space
um
should be in the header element yeah I
think it should be in the header
elements then whatever's taller we'll
have this space
so 36 pixels to the top
um yeah I'll just do header add a margin
top to that
oh let's check on mobile
36 all right it's the same that makes it
easy so the header element
I want margin top of 36.
now
there is some nice space here
looks like
um there is 46 pixels of space under the
header into the cards actually let's
just take a quick look at different
spacing here
30 and this is going to change because
of
you know and it's responsive it's just
gonna be four columns okay so there's 46
pixels of space
vertically between sections
then 24 between the title to here
and there's more here okay so
what I could do is add that 46 pixel of
space to The Container class I think
see what mobile has
40.
46.
let's just say 46
globally in the container class
so that is slightly different from the
design but I think it's probably going
to look okay and we can always tweak it
to be more more exact matched to design
later on so for margin it's going to be
zero Top Auto on the sides and then 30
46 I believe and I think this function
should work in here
should still be fine
so now you can see it's 46.
in the container all right
cool so
yeah a little more breathing room here
so let's do the total followers text now
you can also click in the left sidebar
so it is inter bold and 14 pixels tall
and then the color is this sort of
grayish blue color
so 14 pixels so
let's go to our index.html and I think I
just need to put this in maybe a span
header subtitle
and I could have also called this header
underscore underscore followers but
we're just going to do header subtitle
font size is 14.
and we need to set the font weight
explicitly
the browser will automatically make your
H tags bold but we need to do this here
and I personally like using numbers for
the font weights
um and then we need to do the color too
what's that sort of grayish
oh it's this one dark text one
VAR dark text one
there we go
it's getting a little closer to the
design with every little thing we add
okay now let's look at the toggle and
sort of get that all set up so again
we're going to make the toggle look a
bit different we're gonna go with the
see where was it here we go
so this three position toggle here it'll
be dark a system preference I might just
say system and then light on the right
side so
so obviously we need to do a few things
when we look at what we have now because
right now it has the default radio
button selected
and we need to hide them in some way and
then add the markup and styles for the
actual toggle you know with the toggle
background and then the toggle button so
let's look at the examples that we have
here and check out these styles that
they had
so let's see what we got here
let's just inspect the toggle here
let's put this on the right side
okay
so if we look here
here's the label
so we have this wrapper thing
it looks like the
wrapper has the background color okay
and then
the radio buttons this is what we have
the input type radio is set to display
none so that's probably what we're going
to also have to do
um and actually let's look at
this is Sarah's
example here let's see how she treated
the radio buttons so she did something
interesting she said display inline
block opacity set to zero
and my guess is because maybe
how should we do this maybe on the
bottom
I'm trying to like display this stuff
but then not have it block my little
camera thing
so yeah she set it to display and then
block margin right negative two we'll
see what happens when we uncheck the
opacity
okay that's interesting
you can see you can actually see the
radio button is like really big
and then
see where's the toggle okay so that's a
toggle this is the circle switch thingy
um interesting so
I'm not sure why she set the height of
the radio buttons to be the same size as
a toggle I'm sure there's a good reason
for that
it's really interesting
um
and my guess is she didn't want to do
display none because I think
not positive I think that would sort of
interfere with how screen meters or
maybe if you're navigating the website
through the keyboard
you want to be able to select you know
if you if you're tabbing through stuff
so this lets you oh that's interesting
so I hit tab
to highlight the toggle and then I'm
using the right and left arrow keys
and up and down works too to navigate so
I wonder if this other example will
actually do the same thing so let's tab
oh yeah this is not tabable
interesting
huh
is it really not towable at all oh here
we go
and navigate it oh here we go
so you can do this
but let's do display none
yeah I think maybe
yeah
so my guess is we don't want to do
display none because if you have someone
navigating with a keyboard you want them
to still be able to
yeah navigate you know if they can't
click on the radio button itself so I
think for that reason we're going to
maybe
go with Sarah's examples
so let's kind of open that up okay so I
think we did do very similar markup to
what she had here so again the radio
button Styles which are also right here
in the right here displayline block
margin right is negative two I'm just
kind of curious why she did
you know where these styles are coming
from so I guess maybe that's to put them
both
on the same row let's look at the toggle
and I'm actually going to maybe
set opacity I'm sorry you can't see that
here but
opacity
set to 0.5
so we can sort of see the radio buttons
through
the things
um
let's go back to the radio button
I guess since since the it was set to
with the 50 oh I think I'm guessing she
did that so that you can
navigate a little bit easier let's maybe
set the
so this way
yeah I don't know why it makes a
difference but either way
being able to navigate it with the arrow
keys is huge so we're going to use her
Styles I think I don't know if I'm going
to need to do display like the style
that she did here sure there's a reason
for that but I think I'm just going to
make sure I'm setting the opacity to
zero instead of display none for the
radio buttons so let's just start adding
the Styles there
so this is for the toggle so let's close
these out
split the toggle to the right so we can
see both the toggle and then the
workout
so input type radio we're going to set
opacity
opacity to zero
go to our site
you hear that it is indeed
um
seems like it's hard for me to tab into
that
foreign
just click on the page
click on Tab
let's reload this just to see how it
looks like default
Okay click on the page
click tab to tab through the different
controls
um
it's interesting
there's some kind of highlighting Styles
Focus maybe changes to Red yeah okay so
thank you
sorry I'm just kind of playing around
with the focus States
you can see here the focus on the toggle
is
has some additional Styles too
where's the focus style set
there you go Focus see toggle switcher
so this is the sibling selector so the
focus pseudo
um pseudo class
I think it's called is this
the focus pseudo selector sibling to
toggle Switcher so is it the background
that's being selected let's see Focus
oh it's the inputs so we'll just kind of
remember that to add a different style
for the focus if one of the radio
buttons is
um focused with the keyboard I'm
guessing I need to build the background
of the toggle switches now
sorry this is like really annoying
we're doing this there we go now you
should be able to see everything
okay still figuring things out people
okay so let's toggle wrapper has the
background Styles and the wrapper is
what is containing everything like the
inputs the labels
and then these spans for the background
so that is what I have so maybe we'll
start with this setting these styles for
that
so if we look at the design
background is going to be this linear
gradient thing
and here in figma
tells you the linear gradient
a way to export this style is CSS I
wonder
um
so
I feel like they do
there should be a way in fing I think to
get the actual CSS rules for like a
linear gradient
um
yeah let's see oh here we go export
I mean I can obviously do it manually
but I would kind of like to see if figma
has that capability so figma export
linear gradient CSS
looks promising
copy is CSS
gradient
copy as CSS
let's check here figma handbook
exporting CSS code
the code tab in the properties panel oh
this is exactly what I want okay the
code tab in the properties panel
so here it is
um
so the code tab in the properties panel
where is that
oh inspect oh my gosh this is amazing
I actually don't know if Adobe XD has
this capability but this is sweet so
linear gradient yes it has a degree
which is the angle of the gradient and
then it goes from zero percent for the
I'm guessing blue color to this at 98
now this is great
this is a huge Time Saver
I kind of can't believe that it's that
easy
so this is going to be the toggle
background
so the toggle background element
this will set the background
and we're going to replace
this with the CSS variables
off word wrap really quick
so the green color looks like toggle
background end is the first one but it's
fine
far
and then toggle background start
okay now let's see if that
Works let's check out our site
nothing's there
um here toggle background and it's
probably because there's no height or
whatever
so let's find out what the height is
24 pixels tall
so height
24 pixels
it's not working probably because it's
not displayed
see if
there we go
so maybe I should set the height on the
toggle wrapper and then sort of set the
height to 100 for any of the elements
inside that need that
that way I'm only having to set it once
so toggle wrapper that is a
div so I don't need to set this way
block because it's display block by
default
so I will set height to
end with 24 I don't remember
yeah 24.
okay so save that
and then oh yeah I probably also want to
set the background to
height 100 don't remember if I need I
might need to set a display block on
that too
yeah I need
display
play block
okay
now we have a nice little gradient there
now it has a rounded Corners there so
maybe I'll put that on the toggle
wrapper as well and that was 12 pixels
of Border radius
so we'll do it on the wrapper
order radius
man this function is a huge Time Saver
and I think I need to do
overflow hidden so that it'll get it'll
cut off the linear gradient according to
the Border radius that I just set
so here we go okay
um something got cut off
I'm guessing because this toggle thing
hmm so I might not be able to do this
so I think I need to move all the Styles
into the
background
I think that's how Sarah had done it so
here we go yeah we'll set it here
okay there we go
and it's this width because of the text
inside here I'm guessing
because the background since it's a two
display block
is taking the maximum amount of width
from its parent which is this and the
width the toggle wrapper is getting its
width from the content inside which is
you know the text here
from the labels so we'll figure that out
in a second
let's go back here
and yeah so it looks like I'm just like
copying Sarah's code which I guess I
kind of am but at the same time I'm sort
of studying it and trying to understand
the principles behind it so I'm not just
blindly mindlessly copying and pasting
code and just hoping it works which I do
do sometimes but we're just studying
existing code to try to understand you
know how it works under the hood
I think that's a completely valid thing
to do in the essence of being kind of
honest here
what I might actually do is add a little
comment
with where I got the code here so one I
think people have different approaches
for how I do comments some people don't
like comments at all I personally would
find things helpful like this if let's
say something's not working knowing that
this is where some of this code came
from will help in terms of being able to
bug fix more quickly and efficiently
secondly it it's just sort of giving
credit to where where this all came from
so it's just something that I do I think
it's always good to give credit whenever
possible okay I see toggle wrapper we
need to figure out I think how to
position the labels
so
again the radio buttons are set to
opacity zero
and then we have the background the
toggle switch
and then we got the labels so how is
this laid out because I wonder if she's
using flexbox for this actually I bet
she's just using relying on inline block
because
if you have display block elements each
one will take up
100 of the width so they sort of Stack
one under the other but for display
inline block or display inline elements
the browser will try to fit them next to
each other to sort of have them fill all
the horizontal space before going to the
next line so it's kind of like the
difference between you know words versus
like paragraphs so my guess is she did
she's relying on inline block for that
yeah so that's probably why she set this
to inline block so oh hold on a second
so this is the toggle parent then she
has labels
and then the wrapper has the radio
buttons in the background so I think I
need to change up my markup because
I
have this whole field set thing here
which is the parent
um no that is what I did okay so that's
okay so I think I just need to sort of
position the labels you know in the
right places so if we go back to our
design actually back to this design
which we're going to be again sort of
copying how what would be the best way
to position the labels because there's
one underneath
I could use CSS grid to do that it might
be a little Overkill but maybe not I'm
not really sure the other option I think
would be to maybe I guess you could use
flexbox so you'd have a lions
the first label the toggle and the
second label on one row and then third
label the middle label on its own row
but if you use CSS grid for this I can
sort of just position the labels where I
want them I wonder if that might be
better so yeah even though it might seem
like a little bit of Overkill let's
let's use CSS grid for this okay so in
our grid we're going to have three
columns so label toggle middle label and
then last label then we'll have two rows
so let's start doing that and the parent
for that is going to be
I think this the field set the header
toggle
Okay so header toggle
remember we added this header underscore
underscore toggle class to position the
toggle the whole toggle Block in
relation to the headline in the header
for these styles for positioning the
toggle elements I'm going to put them in
the toggle
scss file because it's not really
related to the header layout but it's
only related to the toggle component
layout itself this is useful if we want
to reuse the toggle on another page we
could just you know add the same markup
again and we know everything will be the
same as on this page so toggle I'm going
to say display grid and we're doing this
by default because we want the toggle to
look the same on mobile and desktop so
display grid and then grid template
columns is going to be
three columns and
I don't know if I would need to do one
FR but
I can kind of see why Sarah did inline
block because it's a little bit simpler
in some cases but let's just try grid so
repeat three
let's just do three one FR for now
there we go
and now with grid we need to kind of
position the elements explicitly Hmm
this might be a bit complicated so it's
going to be
this is the parent and then
the toggle wrapper
so label dark and then light
and then system preference
so
I might just like move these all the way
up so the label there together
um there we go okay so that label label
label toggle wrapper I think I'm gonna
have to
um
add classes to the labels which I think
I should be able to do or actually I
think I can do based on the four
attribute so let's change this to system
okay so toggle grid here and then
where's the label styles
so one of the label Styles up
here because I want to be kind of closer
to the grid Styles just in the file so
label
four
how do we do the four selector
CSS
um label for selector
let's check out Mozilla first
four
um
[Music]
what is this called it's like a pseudo
selector attribute selector it looks
like I could just do four equals and
then whatever let's just see if that
works
so
Ampersand because we want it to inherit
label so ampersand
square brackets four equals I don't even
know the quotes are necessary but I've
just seen it done that way so a dark
so let's see if this works I just want
to test to make sure this selector works
so okay no errors which is good
check out the site oh it is red
yay okay
so four dark
and then we're gonna have to do a
separate one for each of the labels so
let's duplicate twice with Ctrl D dark
system
and Light
so now and then we have toggle wrapper
let's go back to design and check out
the layout
oh we're back to the this design and
check out the layout so it's going to be
first label is going to be in the First
Column the toggle itself is going to be
in the middle column and the last label
will be in the last column
so this one will be in the first column
so I haven't done this in a while grid
column
and this will be the first column so one
and it ends in two which I think is the
correct syntax
so let's just test that out
so we can do is select the parent grid
element
click on the layout tab
and then select the grid inspector
so I do want to highlight the grid yay
look at that
and then now if I
select the dark will tell me
I mean I think that's right let's just
put in all the Styles so
the last the light labels in the last
column so grid column
uh so what was it
one two three so it's from three to four
so three two four
then the system is
I mean the middle column so from two to
three
grid column
two to three and we have to designate
explicitly the row so grid row
and that's going to be
two to three rows
so hopefully that'll work and then the
toggle
is going to be grid column and it's in
the middle column again so
two to three
and then I'm just going to not designate
the grid row right now and just see how
it looks
okay
so here we got our looks like things are
positioning correctly
okay sweet and system is there now the
toggle itself looks like it's not I'm
not sure what's going on there toggle
wrapper it's me I do need to set the
rail let's let's test it in the browser
grid row
from two to three or no no that's from
one to two
okay now where'd the system label go
let's look like it's under there too
okay let's just copy this
and the toggle wrapper yes toggle
wrapper
and let's explicitly set the row I'll
just hit the row for the system and I
think I maybe need to set the grid
template rows explicitly but let's just
see what happens
yeah I might need to Let's sit out here
so
grid template rows
sheet two comma one fr
o
it's not working
let's make this just system
so why is the label I want to toggle
wrapper not up there
could calm two to three that's right and
grid Row one to two
maybe I need to set the height so the
toggle wrapper is 24 pixels tall so
maybe I need to explicitly set the
height of the row
[Music]
and four pixels one fr
ay repeat two 24 pixels
I don't know what's going on here
let's just make it really big just to
like be super obvious okay so that's
working
so if I make the rows really tall
it does look like the system is in the
last row which is good I wonder if
there's oh I bet there's some weird
Styles in the toggle wrapper
that's like
yeah here we go yeah they're taking up
space that's the problem so see if I did
display none yeah it would fix the
layout but obviously I can't do display
none
um that's why Sarah did it like this
[Music]
so each input is
still position relatively it's
interesting oh and maybe the toggle oh
there we go toggle back on its position
absolute
so I wonder if I can do that but instead
of making the background absolute I
wonder if it would work if the inputs
were positioned absolute
but then I'd have to like
it might be hard to tab through them so
maybe that's why the background was set
to position absolute
okay so we figured that part out uh
let's figure out a way to fix this so I
set the background to position absolute
with a hundred percent oh nope that's
bad
um such an absolute and then because
it's positioned absolutely I need to
sort of I don't know what the word is
but like ground it to the parent by
setting this the parent to position
relative
so if I do that then the background
should be limited to the parent which is
good
if I said the top to zero
see there we go
okay so let's do this so toggle
background
we added
that
to toggle background
didn't need that
and then the toggle wrapper
and then you need to set it to position
relative
there we go there we go now the inputs
are still you know they're still there
okay that looks pretty good so we also
want to maybe Center do we want to
Center them or do we want to maybe align
the dark to the right light to the left
it is already and then Center the system
so let's maybe do that
we can do this a couple ways so if we do
text line right that'll work I think we
can also do
self
I don't know sorry uh justify self
to the right
or to end so that works too I don't
think it really matters I might just do
justify self and because
we're using grid stuff anyway
and then for the system we'll do justify
self I think Center should work
nice
cool okay let's add a little space here
um so we got 13 say I'll do 12 pixels of
space so what I think I'm going to do is
add it to the Gap property
so Gap will be 12 pixels so that'll add
space
on all sides of each cell
let's do that
this is something that you add to the
grid parent so go Gap
rem12
all right it's looking better and better
every time now the last thing we want to
do is add the toggle like Circle switch
thing
so that one is looks like it's the same
color as the background so again we'll
look here
see how they did it
um
is this it
yes okay
so the slide
the slider thing that's interesting
okay so they're styling this by
saying if you if the third option is
checked then
the left property will change
so I'm guessing this is just left Zero
by default
okay let's check out saris
so the switcher looks like it is
displayed okay so it's it's an absolute
left to zero
now we check this again
uh is that right
left is still zero
hmm how do they control that
interesting
you have to reload move something like
got broken or something I'm not really
sure
so the Switcher
top zero left zero right 100 percent
okay
but now
it's still zero still left zero how does
that even work
let's see if we can look in her Styles
and see stuff that's there
so it's the switcher that we're looking
for
[Music]
Switcher
okay
now 20 Styles changed oh here I have the
checked see how switcher is right
maybe the fire so that's Firefox I think
has doesn't quite like update the
inspector sometimes so if I switch
between tabs there we go
so it's checked right is zero left to 50
and I'm guessing there's a transition
element on the
right and left properties to make it a
more smoothing yeah so transition all so
we can remove the transition they'll be
they'll just kind of blink
it's actually not that bad but it's a
little bit nicer to have that okay
so that's what we need to do
um so be absolutely positioned thing
in here so if we go back to our code
it's going to be this toggle button
that's where we're going to add the
styles
so toggle
button
that's not what I wanted absolute
and we'll just say left zero
right 100 percent
and let's go back to the design because
I think we probably need to explicitly
set the height of this thing
oops
uh stop here we go 18 by 18.
and the height of this is 24. so
oh there it is
in the background we're going to set it
to the
the toggle I think right
it should be the background color
this was a light mode color oh yeah okay
so
it's light mode is still the color of
the background but the toggle background
is this thing
hmm yeah I'm not sure if toggle is the
right word for that because it's kind of
like the toggle light
um but anyway we can just reuse this
dark background variable
foreign
what the height of the toggle is
18.
okay so you can kind of see it up there
so let's position this thing correctly
um
toggle button
maybe top zero
make us left should be a little bit
you know put to the side
it's about I think it said three pixels
okay
um left should be
round three
top
hopefully that will look correct
oh wow look
oh nice
and like this is a bit long because it's
getting the width from the system label
so I think what I might do is make the
system cell take over all the rows and
then set the the width of the toggle
background a bit differently
to that
so it's going to be the
label for system
so the grid column we want to go from
one all the way to the end so I think I
can just go one and
instead of having to set an actual
number that should work let's see here
we go system where's the label
system
one two
four
maybe it's just like showing that
because of this
hmm
okay so it is going all the way to the
beginning of the row so grid column one
end
oh interesting I do end instead of four
it adds another thing there
maybe one to four is actually better
that's kind of weird I'm not sure why
it's doing that
and then we want to maybe set the width
of the thing oh I think I wonder if
that's why Sarah had set this
like making the radio buttons the same
size of the toggle so that the width of
the background will be the same that's
going to be my guess it's also going
toggle wrapper
so you can see we have the different
radio buttons here and they have a
margin so maybe
what happens if we get rid of the margin
yeah much much smaller
so let's check the design and see how
wide the background is it is 48 pixels
wide
so now this is about 50 which is
actually pretty close so I think I'm
going to take that
margin zero
from the radio buttons
and then I sort of set the height
explicitly on the background so I think
I don't need to set the height of the
radio buttons to match the height that I
want the background to be okay so last
thing we need to do and we're almost
done here which is kind of nice let's do
the styles for when the different
options are selected
so the selected selector is the checked
for the radio button
so for example this first radio button
is dark and then checked
so when it's checked then you change the
right and left values of the toggle
little
toggle button thing
so let's do that so
um
here we go so radio button so if the
dark label I'm sorry it's the input
radio dark which is this one
is selected or checked then we'll change
the styles for the button
so normally you'd do something like
maybe I would add
thing here for dark
checked but
[Music]
I wonder if I can
add a sibling selector in the toggle
button thing
not sure if this is going to work
so
let's just get this selector right so
the toggle button sibling
if the sibling selector for the toggle
button is ID dark
checked
so sibling selector
I guess I can just do the same thing
dark
checked
and then I'll say well actually dark is
the default so let's say light checked
to make it go all the way to the other
side
so we'll say right zero left a hundred
percent
that even works
so check the light
oops
um
okay I think maybe
these need to be on top of the
background it's made the labels need to
go after the problem here is like I'm
clicking here but nothing's happening
which makes me think that the background
div
you can't click through and I think
there's a CSS property for that
there we go pointer events none yeah so
I think if I set a pointer event none
to the background
which is the one pulling your gradient
I think that will let us click through
to the radio buttons
ah
explained on this just to like
and then opacity one
so I can click them
looks like the light thing isn't working
the uh
I think I need to do
actually let's leave this here let me
check the the uh final CSS
check the checks
okay so toggle button light
talk about instilling light checked
that looks correct to me I think
yeah I'm not sure why it's not working
anywho let's reload this
silly toggle I've selected a light radio
button
and looks like there's no
the Styles aren't coming through so let
me add maybe an explicit
see toggle button
let's go
idea of light
sibling toggle button oh light checked
toggle button
um left 100 right
zero or three pixels
okay this looks like something did
change so let's see here
where'd the button go okay so good news
is it's working that is is the button's
like way off over here I'm not sure why
maybe left Auto
okay right three pixels
um
this could do a calc
so I could do calc 100 minus 18 pixels
then add three for the space
oh boy y'all this is tough
okay so it looks like it is moving yay
so I'm not sure what's going on here but
let's just copy this style
um
and maybe the ceiling selector needs to
be first maybe maybe order matters with
the sibling selector because
the label actually comes
first before the button
so I actually wonder if
um
yeah so I'm going to leave this here
just to have it so we don't lose it but
I might actually move all the labels
down after
the toggle wrapper that'll kill two
birds with one stone because this will
make the radio buttons on top of the
toggle wrapper because by default Z
index will look at the order of elements
and so elements that come later will be
on top of elements that come before them
unless you set Z index explicitly oh
wait I know why the sibling sucker
didn't work because I said it on the
toggle button which is here but it's
inside the toggle wrapper
um okay so this probably won't really
work
so let's save that
and then see if this works now oh this
makes me so happy look at that
okay so now the next thing I'm going to
do is see if we can add that transition
state and let's test it again in the
browser
the toggle button
we'll just say transition all 150
milliseconds he's in out which is my
favorite one
[Music]
it's working
okay
that looks pretty good
so we'll do that
and that's on the button itself
nice
and then we need to do the positioning
for the center one
so system
checked
sibling
toggle button
oh wait a minute system checks which is
this and then sibling oh yeah toggle
button which is there I don't know why
the other one didn't work I think
sibling the order does matter
okay let's just fix this and then I'll
see if there's a way we can add these
Styles under the button thing because
we're not having to manually type out
toggle button
because it kind of goes against what
them is supposed to be able to give you
so for the center one
I guess we'll just do sorry remind me
again this is position absolute okay so
the center of is an absolute you need to
do the old left 50 percent
and then
I guess I'll say right Auto and then you
need to do a transform Translate
negative 50
so what this does is the left 50 will
put it to the left of the width of the
parent but because it starts measuring
from the left side it's going to be a
little bit more to the right
because of the width the 18 pixels at
the button itself is so we want to do we
want to use translate which will
translate it'll shift the element based
on the width of itself so we want to
shift 50 or half of the width of itself
back the other way so that will make
sure it is actually centered
here we go and there we go
okay I think I know why Sarah made the
radio buttons um the height is because
if I don't click on the exact right
place it's not gonna go so you know
everything is there for a reason
let's take away this opacity for a
second
okay so now I'm just doing this so I can
see the radio buttons
so height of
18 pixels
um
it should be the height of the track
[Music]
so 24 and 24.
so going back to the input radio
room 24
for the width and for the height
so now
yeah so now see here
why is the spacing like that though
oh maybe that's why she had margin of
negative two
oh my gosh
where is it the Switcher
margin right of negative two that's why
because I guess it must be a browser
default or something
yeah so by default has a margin all the
way around so I'm going to go margin
zero
Zero's the top so negative two pixels
zero zero
now let's make sure the height the width
of this 69
supposed to be 48 so
maybe make them a tiny bit narrower
uh I said 24 pixels
or if we go 20. so what was it what's
supposed to be supposed to be 48.
so it's 57 right now
for
okay so with the 20 pixels for the radio
buttons
it's a little bit taller than they are
wide
oh yeah then the margin of zero you have
two pixels zero and negative two
okay now it's more clickable
sweet
I guess I can Rim this to REM
2 I don't know if it matters if it's
just like so small but might as well be
consistent right
oh boy okay now let's turn off this uh
grid stuff here
wow looks pretty good
okay so I'm gonna fix this thing here
check out the mobile so mobile is
actually quite different
but we want this to always be 48 pixels
wide
the toggle background so I just need to
maybe
set this to
yeah so this should always be 48 so I
think I'm gonna go
repeat
I shouldn't do the repeat I think so
maybe one of far
48 pixels one FR that's a little bit
narrow
it's right
you know I might make this a little bit
wider just because I think the three
options
toggle is making things a little bit
iffy
so we'll do this
so going back up to the grid
or place this
and then of course we'll do Ram
okay
let's go on desktop
nice I'm quite pleased with how this is
turning out
now let's fix the mobile style so in
Mobile
um
so this thing I think we want it to look
a little differently I'm guessing I
probably want to have the same thing we
just sort of centered
or maybe just left lined maybe right
aligned we'll keep it on the right
and we need to add a bit of space there
between them
oh there's a line there too
there's no line on desktop so
let's just align the toggle and we'll
add go back and add the spacing so this
is going to be the toggle
and if we remember
the header container I think
was using flexbox for desktop
yeah and then
not for mobile because it's too narrow
right it's like that
margin left Auto
I was trying to think it's like usually
do you float right but then you don't
want that because it collapses the this
stops taking up vertical space so you
don't actually want to do that
I shouldn't I think I should have done
CSS grid for the header thing because
then I could just sort of place it so I
might need to change that because I
think for flexbox
I mean I think I could let's just let's
see how difficult it'll be with flexbox
so header
display Flex
um
and then to make it this go on the
second row I think I'd have to make
header title
with the hundred percent
oy V
oh I think rap Flex wrap
there we go so now it allows you to wrap
if you don't turn on wrap it'll just
even if you set this to 100 width which
I did it won't wrap the items so let me
go wrap
and then for this one I think I would
want to do I think if I do margin left
Auto there we go
yay so
I guess that wasn't too painful
so let's do header container
make that a flex wrap thing too
so header
and then we're gonna go I'm trying to
remember if I wanna use put all those
things up there do I want justify
content online items to also be on
mobile I don't remember
[Music]
and then title is going to be with the
100 percent
but only for um well
break point medium
with
let's just see if that works for now oh
and then the toggle wrapper or sorry the
header toggle
we're gonna go margin left Auto
I think I can keep that for desktop I
think it won't mess anything up okay so
cool
so we got the flex wrap property
got this so if we got on a mobile looks
kind of like this
and then yeah that looks pretty good
actually
looks like it's not perfectly centered
here with this label
oh maybe that's just from the line
height
I mean the difference is so small
doesn't matter
so that's fine
just make sure it's working
[Music]
that's okay I feel like from mobile
maybe it should just be centered or
maybe just like left so it's the same as
the uh title
[Music]
uh
yeah I feel like it might look better if
everything's just on the left for mobile
yeah let's let's do that so let's not
mess with the you know making it look on
the making it go on the right side
I think that's okay
I'm kind of deviating a bit from the
design but you know you just gotta make
things look a little bit more balanced
and I change things because we're adding
three option toggle
we'll just remove that and we actually
don't have any Styles here so I'm just
going to delete this selector
key
okay I'm gonna
remove some of the space down there so
the gap
I think Gap column
or if I do Gap
not even sure I'm doing this right
so the first get property is
the Rogue app
[Music]
it's gonna be 0.3
whatever that ends up being
um
two pixels or no the
what was it
column Gap is 12 pixels row Gap is 4.8
pixels
so we'll change that on the toggle
so that should add it in there we go now
it's a little bit spaced better
just an awful lot of space on the bottom
of that
is the margin on that anyway 5.6 and 10.
this must be browser defaults for the
field set yeah
if we go margin zero
is that looking
any batteries are centered
let's do that
margin zero to the toggle
and you know actually I would bet this
text needs to be a lot smaller
so yeah
it is 14 pixels
um that's for the label
Ram 14. foreign
looks a little bit smaller which is good
it will reduce the Gap again
see the cool thing about having the
labels on the radio buttons is that
clicking the label will also select the
button in addition to choosing the
button so you leave a lot of options
here
I'm just working with the arrows I think
I need to add a focus state for that
so maybe this is okay for now
reduce the calmed up a little bit
0.3 and 0.5
uh
that would be eight pixels
okay I think that's better and I think I
also need to Center these labels
yeah
line self Center
okay
so this can go
for the toggle labels to do both of
those and then we'll align this a bit
differently
the system aligned self we want to be
start
there we go so then this is going to be
at the top looks pretty dang good I'm
pretty psyched about this
okay so the other thing we wanted to do
was the
um
when it's focused right so Focus
toggle Switcher
so it's the ceiling to the toggle
Switcher
and that was this one
um
so I'm guessing it was when the any of
the inputs are selected
this will
have that sort of extra outline there
which you can't see
here we go have an extra outline
reload this for good measure
as you can see it's like
okay so what can we do about ours and
this is again a little different from
the design let's play around with some
Styles and just see what looks good
so the toggle button
so we do a border
I mean I guess that looks fine let's see
let's look at our colors and see if
there's a color that might look good
red
maybe the yellow
and of course white always works I might
just do maybe lighten this a little bit
[Music]
yeah so
toggle Switcher
is toggle switcher is at the end so
input type radio Focus C toggle Switcher
let's try to figure out what the
selector is so I'm selecting light
um
it's a toggle input type radio selected
Focus
sibling
toggle
button
in order to pixel solid white
oh it is working okay I guess that
worked so we'll add this to the
toggle input thing
so toggle input
let's just make sure this works right
now
so where these Ampersand Focus
this works
nice
oh yeah look at that so I'm using tab
two and the arrow keys to select that so
that's pretty awesome
so what I want to do is
can I and I think this is what I
mentioned before I kind of forgot about
I don't think it'll work any other way I
was trying to see if I could put the
Styles in here and use like
um a different selector but I think it
won't work I think I have to use this
so this is pretty good we're in a good
place with the top nav section
coming up with class names is a
deceptively tricky part of working with
CSS and if you're using SAS and
following the bem or block element
modifier naming convention it can be
even more difficult so in today's video
I thought I would show you how I come up
with class names for this card component
in the front and Mentor challenge that
we've been building and also how I
structure all my Styles in my scss files
so to start off we have our design in
figma open here and I'm going to before
we start writing any code make some
notes out here in the margins just
showing you what I'm going to name each
of the items in this card
now before we get into that let's talk
about what bem actually is so let's make
some notes Here with a text thing so
them stands for Block element modifier
is over here so we can see better
so block element modifier and what that
means is when we look at the design
we're not writing styles for every
single element in this design you know
all in one place what we do especially
with our SAS files and the SAS partials
is we kind of break apart each of the
design components into their own file so
we did this in the previous video
creating these styles for the header and
the toggle and they each had you know
the Styles in the header were in
header.scss styles for the toggle were
in the toggle.scss file so you can see
that SAS and bem are a really good
combination in terms of writing your
Styles in an organized and structured
way so if we look at the design the
block is kind of the name of the
component that your writing styles about
it's the sort of parent component or the
parent element so in our example here
we're writing styles for this card so
the Block in this instance is going to
be card
so I'm going to say lock will be card in
this instance
and then the element
and usually a block will have more than
one element inside it so the card is
kind of the apparent and then the inside
the card it has child elements so for
example
we have you know the platform the social
media platform and the username on the
top then we have like a follower count
and then we have at the bottom it's like
a change in the number of followers for
today so we have these sort of three
elements here we have the platform then
we have the count of followers and at
the bottom we have the change so those
are going to be the three main elements
that we're going to write styles for so
the elements are going to be platform
and then also going to be the count and
then the change and this is just to
start we're probably going to add some
more elements later on as we go and then
the modifier is a different style or
appearance and that can be attributed to
I think either the block or the element
so for example if we look at the design
the cards have slightly different
designs based on the social media
platform so you can see the Facebook
card has this blue stripe up at the top
the Twitter has a slightly different
blue color Instagram has this orange
looks like it's a gradient as well and
then YouTube is red so you can see the
different styles for each platform can
be written in a modifier class so for
example
modifier could be Facebook for the
Facebook card Twitter
Etc and Etc
now the other thing to keep in mind is
when we're writing our Styles we're sort
of combining these things together and
this is where you may have seen the
whole underscore and hyphen thing so
when you're writing an element you are
going to start with the block name so
card the card is going to have a class
of card so I'll write card
and then let's say we're writing styles
for this top part let's say maybe for
the icon so that could be another
element so we'll just add this in our
notes Here icon so the class for this
Facebook icon could be card underscore
underscore
icon
and then if we look at the design we can
see that there's multiple kinds of icons
based on the social media platform so in
this case we can use a modifier so for
example the card icon
dash dash Facebook would have Facebook
specific Styles and then there might be
some more generic styles for example
maybe the width of the icon that we
could put under card icon
and we kind of just go down the line
here so I might actually make some more
elements as we kind of look in our
design so after the icon there's going
to be you know the username so maybe
that could be another element so card
underscore underscore username and then
that's it for the sort of top part now
the next section is for the follower
count so we'll say card underscore
underscore maybe count just try to keep
things as descriptive as possible and
then under there is this followers label
so we could say card underscore
underscore label now if we're looking
down at the bottom it's this sort of
change of number of followers either up
or down today so we'll say card
underscore underscore change
and if we look at the design we can see
that it's green if it goes up and it's
red if it goes down so this could be
modifiers since they're different styles
of the change so we can say card
underscore underscore change Dash Dash
um I guess up
and then it will also write some stars
for dash dash down so this is starting
to make sense how we're kind of breaking
things apart and you might be wondering
you know why are we even bothering
writing these pretty long class names
you know card icon Facebook like why is
that necessary why can't we just say you
know Facebook or icon without having
this card preface one reason is that
having these card prefixes for each of
these class names it kind of helps to
ensure that all the class names are
going to be unique because if we're
thinking about the website that has
multiple pages and templates and styles
there might be another icon element
somewhere else in design that's
completely different from what we're
working with here so this ensures that
these styles are writing for this card
icon only applies to this element that
has this sort of long class name the
second reason that we'll see a little
bit later when we're starting to set up
everything in our scss files is that
having this underscore with the prefix
of card it works for really well with
SAS and the nesting feature of SAS and
again we'll see this a little bit later
when we start actually writing our
Styles but for now let's kind of go over
and see if there's any more classes we
want to make so I'm going to just mainly
focus on this big card right now but we
can see in the card below it that a lot
of the elements are the same so for
example the social media icon looks
pretty much the same size as we have in
the big card the number you can see is
actually different like it looks like
it's the same font and color but it's a
much smaller size and then the change
looks like it's pretty much the same
color and size as we have on top so for
the number since we have kind of a
bigger number up top and a smaller
number on the bottom we could maybe make
that also a different modifier for the
count so let's see here
so card count
dash dash small
and if we wanted to be really sort of
detailed about this we could actually
make separate ones for
the big modifier and the small modifier
and then we would have the styles that
are shared by both big and small like
the font family and the color and
probably the font weight in the card
count element selector so I think that's
pretty good for now we'll probably be
adding more styles to this as we as we
get along but for now I'm going to start
writing kind of just building out the
structure of our SAS Styles so if we go
to our vs code I did make a car.scss
file at the beginning in the last video
when I set things up this style rule
wasn't really anything it was just for
us to check and make sure that it worked
so again the card is going to be the
block
so let's start adding styles for the
elements so under card we got card icon
card icon modifier Facebook and then
there'll be a different modifier for
each of the social media platforms so
let's start with that so card underscore
underscore icon now in SAS we have
nesting which is a feature that native
CSS doesn't have but this is what we can
use the Amber stand for so the Ampersand
symbol means it'll reference the parent
selector which in this case is the card
class so the Ampersand will be card and
then underscore underscore icon
and then we can add the modifier class
with another Ampersand so this Ampersand
stands for card underscore underscore
icon because that's the parent selector
then we'll add hyphen hyphen Facebook
and we can do the same thing for
Twitter
Instagram and YouTube
so we'll just add those out here
instead Instagram
and YouTube
okay so let's go back to the design so
the next thing we want to do is card
underscore underscore username so kind
of in the same way Ampersand underscore
underscore username
and we're really just kind of making our
way down the design here
so then the next one is card count with
a big and small modifier
so count and then in count it'll have a
modifier of big
and small
I think that's it for the count
then after count we got the card label
which is the followers text so
underscore underscore label
and then at the bottom is that change
number so it's change with a modifier of
up and down
underscore underscore change then in
change we'll have
dash dash up
and dash dash down
okay so this is pretty much all these
styles that were going all the class
names rather that we're going to be
using for this card element and again we
might be adding some more Styles
um because you know we can see that the
cards are in a grid so we'll probably
use either flexbox or grid to make sure
that there are four columns on desktop
and then of course when you get to
Mobile it's stacked to one column so we
do need some additional styles for that
but we might make some more generic
class names to control the layout
because I think I did add
yeah so I have a layout SAS file here so
this has a container Styles right now
but we could add some more classes for
you know a grid because we know that
both of these are four columns on
desktop so we can kind of use the same
classes for the layouts for these cards
but in terms of the cart specific styles
I think these should cover most of the
things we're looking for
so
going back to the card SAS file
and this is kind of the approach that I
use when I'm you know building a website
for work or whatever I just try to write
all the different class names that I
think I'm going to be using and all the
different selectors and then I kind of
fill them in as I build things out
so now the next thing is we need to
write the HTML markup for these cards so
I'm going to split this to the right
side
so we can have HTML on the left and then
this styles on the right so let's start
adding markup for the cards I'm going to
minimize the header here since we don't
really need this
so the card content is going to go in
the main tag and I think yeah I added a
section tag so I'm probably going to
have each of these card grids in its own
section tag so this will be one section
tag and then the bottom grid along with
this overview today is going to be
another section tag but for now I'll
just say section
and we want to add a class of container
and that's again to limit the max width
of the content to 1110 pixels wide and
Center it so basically every section
we're going to need to add the class
container to that
and this is similar to what we did with
the header in the last video
so in this section
you know we might also add the classes
for the grid for that four column look
but we'll worry about that a little bit
later on right now I'm really just
focused on writing the markup and
getting the Styles working for one
individual card and then we'll worry
about fitting them into the grid layout
afterwards so it's another thing I try
to do I try to not do everything all at
once like try to come up with all the
finished markup and styles but I kind of
break them down into steps so right now
I'm doing the card don't worry about
doing the layout later you could of
course do this in whatever order you
want you could maybe create a multiple
card elements and then you know make
make the grid layout work from there but
when I have a group of multiple items I
usually start with just one because if I
create multiple divs for the cards and
then things change because they probably
will change because you know you're
never going to get things perfect the
first time around then you're gonna have
to go back and change the markup for all
the three other card elements that you
made so I just start from one I think
it's just easier so here's the container
now let's make our first div for the
card so I'll say Dot card this is using
the Emmett shortcut here
it will just generate a div with a class
of card now let's go back to our card
SAS file and let's see
so at the beginning I'm going to handle
the uh the blue bar at the top probably
in the cart element itself maybe I'll
make a border a top of 10 pixels or
whatever so what I might do is start
adding the you know I might need to
actually add some modifiers for the
social media platform in the card
element itself
so it'll be similar to the icon but this
is going to control the color of that
bar at the top
so for card
let's look and check out what these
styles are here so in figma we're just
going to click in here
and keep kind of keep clicking until we
see that the element we want is selected
Okay so
um
I'm trying to get this background color
here
not sure if I have it selection colors
looks like it's this sort of purpley
dark blue gray thing
is that right two five two before two
change to register see if it changes
oh
okay maybe not
oh I'm selecting The Mask here so I
don't want that
um
sorry
let's see I'm not super experienced with
figma so this is kind of weird
what if I accidentally changed something
I think it's this color here so
8c98c6 so that's gonna be the card
background color so let's
open the colors SAS file here
it looks like
maybe dark text one does that seem right
I think a text the text will not be this
actual text color
it's probably this dark card color here
some copy of that variable
and then in our card SAS file we'll save
background
VAR
dark card
and you might as well say color
it's going to be the dark text one
okay
now I'll start adding some markup to the
cards so we can see we can start
building things out so the next step is
the icon and the username and I think I
might need to maybe wrap them in an
element so we might have to create
another element here if I could just say
card top perhaps
so good card
top
I don't know if that's a great way of
doing it but yeah we'll just we'll just
do that
um just seeing what I did here
maybe we'll make it a little bit more
descriptive because it's like what is
this it's the the Facebook and the
username so like maybe the social media
platform or whatever
did I not write this in my notes I guess
I didn't do that
um so we'll add card platform and that's
going to be the top element there with
the icon in the username
so
platform
and then
we'll add the markup to match that so
card underscore underscore platform
then in card platform is going to
contain the icon and the username so
card
icon
and then card
user name
there we go then move on to the next
section so it's the follower count so
card underscore underscore count so card
escort underscore account
and in the account it's going to have
the number and then the followers label
so I think I need to put the card label
inside the card count
card label
and then after that is the change
and I think I can just do card change
for everything
card
change okay so now
you kind of have our HTML element set so
let's move the actual text in there
to card platform contains the icon
and then the username so username is
here
and then the count is 1987.
I think I'll just put it straight up in
the card count element
and the card label is that followers
text and the card change is 12 today
so we'll do that
okay
so this is the markup
for our first card now we do need to add
card icon thing so I'm hoping that
they've given us either pngs or svgs
for this
I'm going to select the icon itself oh
yeah it looks like it's this could be an
SVG
can I export this
actually let's see if they included that
in the front inventor images anyway so
that's a design oh here we go images
okay icon Facebook okay so we can use
those
so in the card icon I guess I'll add an
image tag and we'll say images icon face
book SVG
and then in the alt text it'll be
Facebook
okay so why don't we check out our
website and see what it looks like oh
and in this video we're going to use
instead of Firefox which I have been
using we're going to use this other
browser called poly Pane and this looks
different as you might notice um and the
really cool thing about poly pane is
that you can load multiple devices in
the same view so it helps a lot with
when you're debugging responsive
websites and it's cool because it's like
synced so for example if I click on the
toggle here on desktop you can see it's
also changing on the mobile and vice
versa so everything synced
um also you know as we get more content
on the page you can scroll down on
mobile and then it'll also scroll and
match it the position the scroll
position on desktop and vice versa so
you know I still like using Firefox but
I think when you're comparing the mobile
and desktop views when you're developing
a website it can be really helpful to
have something like this so you can see
both views so let's see where we are
reload this okay so you can see the card
here so it looks like the background
color is correct with what we have in
the design obviously we need to style a
lot of stuff but the Facebook icon is
showing up which is great so the next
thing I do is I usually try to get the
layout fixed first inside the element
and then I'll worry about you know the
text colors and font sizes and stuff
like that so if we look at the design
for the card you can see all the content
in the card is centered and then it's
kind of spaced out seems pretty evenly
like if we click in here looks like
there's 28 pixels of space on top and 25
on the bottom I make that the same just
for you know make things a bit more
consistent and make it maybe 25 on both
sides let's look at what we got in our
browser
so obviously this car is going all the
way across because it's a block element
so if we do this
and poly pain is written in I believe
the Chrome uh browser engine so this is
the similar Dev tools to what Chrome has
here's card
um uh oh I made a mistake here
color I forgot the VAR function
[Music]
there we go
okay
so
because it's going all the way across I
think I might just add some temporary
styles to limit it
so let's say card
um with now let's see what we have in
the design
255 pixels
so Ram 255 and this is a temporary style
so I'll just add that so I don't forget
to remove it later on
okay so now we can see it's a little bit
better let me zoom in a little bit
you can see that a little bit better
okay so we got the card and we want to
make things centered and then evenly
space it out so let's maybe add a text
align of Center and see if that does
what we want so that's pretty good
so let's try that for now so text align
Center
and then yeah so that's we're getting
there
and maybe we'll add some padding so
let's see what the padding inside the
card is 32
24 so maybe let's do 25 as the card
batting
padding Ram 25 let's do it all the way
around
okay so it's getting there
now things are centered but obviously
this does not look super close to to the
design
problem is I want the card platform to
have the icon on one side and then the
username on the other side and then card
count and card change and then we want
the same thing with card count where
it's
um
one on the left and one on the right or
no I'm sorry with the follower I think
it's it's the followers text is under
the 1987. so let's do card platform
right now
so again look at the design the icon is
on one side and the usernames on the
other side so let's see we could do
something where the icon maybe we could
say display inline walk
and then card username is also a display
online block
so that works to put them next to each
other however we want to vertically
Center it so right now you can see the
text is kind of on the bottom so I think
I might need to use flexbox instead of
inline blog let's try that
so we'll make
card platform display Flex
that's pretty good and then justify
content Center
and align item Center
[Music]
it's like looks like the text is still a
little bit to the bottom
I wonder why that is looks like there is
cardacon is 20 by 24. the image looks
like it's not going down all the way
so I don't know if that's an SVG thing
or I don't know the images like that
not sure why it's adding that extra
space at the bottom
I wonder if we could just make the image
the card icon maybe I'll try that so
let's add the flex styles from card
platform
we'll try to fix the alignment on that
image thing
so card platform
display flex and we want this to be the
same for mobile and desktop so we don't
need a media query here
okay so now
let's go back to our markup and maybe
instead of a div class card icon we'll
get rid of the div
move the class to the image element
itself so remove that
and then remove that so the image itself
and this might look weird I'm not sure
if this is going to work oh it looks
good
so now things are centered
and we'll add a little bit of space I
think
zoom in here
face so there is eight pixels of space
to the left of the username to the right
of the icon
so I'm going to
say margin right on the icon
of eight
[Music]
okay that looks pretty good now we need
to style this text here of course
so if we go here let's see looks like
this is bold so let's check out the
styles for the text oh yeah here we go
text it's inter which is the font we're
using everywhere I believe old and 12
pixels
[Music]
so right now what do we have
card username doesn't have any Styles
explicitly set and it's 16 pixels I
think because I set
um the default size is like one REM
which is 16 pixels so card username
needs to be
font size
12 pixels converted to REM and then font
weight is old
[Music]
there we go
that looks pretty good okay now let's
look at the spacing I think we said 25
right oh 28 uh 25 and 28.
I guess we'll try to stick to the design
so 28 on top so we want to add 20 pixels
of margin bottom to card platform
margin bottom Ram 28.
there we go all right now let's do the
followers section
so if we look at the design here this is
obviously much bigger than the default
16 pixels it is inter bold and 56 and
the color is white
so let's do that and that is the card
count
here we go so card count oh yeah then we
have the big and small version so the
color is going to be the same
um I guess light background
is white
far light background
and then the
big modifier is going to be font size
REM 56.
and then I want to make sure that I did
add that modifier in my markup
so what I have to here because I have
some styles for card count I need to
keep that card count class and add to
that and say big
okay let's see how that looks
um okay so obviously followers is too
big but we can fix that later and this
needs to be bold I'm guessing too
font weight
balls
okay I think that's better
I see this is a little bit big I'm
zoomed in
yeah I guess that does seem right
now let's fix this followers text Styles
enter regular 12.
and it's that gray color again
card count
and then label
and then the font size is
12. and it is all caps but I'm going to
do that in the CSS versus the actual
text so font size 12 I think I said
then font weight's going to be normal
and then
I'm going to add a text transform
and I like making things uppercase in
CSS versus doing uppercase in the HTML
because if things change later on and
they want to not be all uppercase you're
gonna have to go back and change all the
instances of the uppercase to regular
case and I'd rather just be able to
remove the text transform if they ever
want to not have uppercase
here
maybe some letter spacing going on too
seems pretty oh yeah here we go five
pixels of letter spacing
let's see I gotta say I have used
I've used Adobe XD most of the time when
I'm working with design files just
because that's what the designs would
give to me this is the first time I'm
using figma and I do like a lot of the
things they give you it's a little bit
more intuitive in terms of getting the
Styles out like I could be wrong but I
don't remember seeing some of these it's
not an export panel
the ui's just a little bit different
and I love how figma gives you the
actual CSS for stuff I don't think I
could be wrong I don't think I ever saw
that in XD
um unless it's just a feature that I
never found out about but another kind
of pain point with XD when I was using
it is
the letter spacing thing because they if
I can even get into here but like it's
telling you here the letter spacing is
five pixels I'm not sure what units they
were using in Adobe XC but it was like I
think they're using maybe an illustrator
thing which doesn't really help for
developers because I would just
basically have to eyeball it and again
maybe there's some kind of conversion or
whatever but it was just a different
number different like there was no unit
for letter spacing so I'm really liking
figma all right enough chatter okay so
the number looks good the followers text
looks pretty good let's check the
spacing right now
thank you
so I think the line height here maybe
should be one
that's a bit closer
let's see what the what it says here
nine pixels
oh there's a little letter spacing of
negative two pixels so let's add that in
um count
I'm negative two
and I'll just set the line height to 1.
and then for
margin bottom I think it was eight I
think I said
let's check that nine
okay
is this working
let's see
oh I need to add the margin to the top
of the label because it's inside
the card count
somewhere in top
there we go it seems like a lot because
there's already space from I guess the
the
line height
I think maybe I'm having issues because
I put the label inside the card count
because I was trying to make things a
bit easier on myself
um but yeah I usually yeah I might need
to add another selector here for the the
number yeah so let's do this let's make
this
oops
let's move this
here
so card count is just encapsulating
1987. card labels here and I'll put both
of those in a new parent element and
I'll call this card underscore
underscore followers
and I'll move both of those
in there
okay
and then we'll add some of the styles
from the count to probably followers so
followers
oops
followers and I personally like using
margin bottom versus margin top
just because I try to keep things
consistent with all my elements and only
add space between Elements by adding a
margin bottom to the first the element
before
this is a personal preference okay see
how that looks
okay not bad I think so yeah we got the
margin bottom there I feel like there's
still a little space even though I set
the line height to one so I think I
might just need to maybe reduce this so
instead of nine pixels
foreign
pixels see how the design looks
so things aren't always perfect in terms
of what is in the design versus what
ends up being in the browser so it's
that much space here that seems okay so
we'll change margin bottom to four
pixels
okay seems pretty good is this centered
I can't tell
seam centered okay I think it's centered
and then let's add space under the
followers and before the change so
followers
this 25
so we'll add that space to the followers
selector
so a margin bottom Ram 25 I think is
what it was
okay looking pretty good
and then let's add the 12 today styles
so in the design it is green and that's
going to be for the up modifier but
let's add the styles that are shared
with both the up and the down Styles so
they're different colors but everything
else is the same so let's check out the
font styles for this
it's interbold 12. okay
let's do that
so for the change
font size is 12.
and then font weight is bold
and then we'll add the colors here as
well
um
colors is lime green I think yeah that
must be it
so color far
lime green and since we're here I might
as well add it for bright red too
further down
oops
far bright red
and why is this not
the Styles aren't coming through
card change
oh I didn't add the modifier thing
card underscore underscore oh card I'm
just going to sort of change dash dash
up
there we go now I know this might seem
really like extra to have these two
classes here
um what you could also do if you don't
want to do that is do something like
this where you only include the modifier
class in your markup but then for both
up and down you could say extend
a card
underscore underscore change
styles
so let's save that and what extend does
is it'll just copy the styles that are
in whatever selector you see
so you can see here oh did I save the
HTML no I didn't
and if I did things right
things will still show up oh there we go
so card change up
and now we see that it is using the
styles
the problem with this is that and this
is kind of where people just had
different opinions on things but a lot
of people don't recommend using the
extend rule in SAS because you end up
adding these styles to three different
selectors you're adding it to card
change then you're adding it to card
change up and card change down versus
if we went back to what we had before
card change
get rid of this
save both of these things
then what you have is it looks the same
but you can see the styles are sort of
separated out so it's like car change up
it only has the lime green color and
then the other styles that are shared
with both the up and down styles are in
card change and you're not having
multiple selectors for a given set of
rules so it just kind of helps to keep
your CSS a little bit more compact
obviously you know the trade-off is at
now instead of one class you have two
classes in your HTML and some people you
know they don't like doing that but I
think I I used to use extend a lot
because it was handy for this very
purpose but I think you seem to be
careful when you're using it I'm kind of
nowadays just using these multiple
classes in my HTML even though it seems
kind of lengthy um just because I would
rather have my CSS be a bit more
structured and not you know
unnecessarily share styles between
selectors
of course this is my own preference if
you want to use extend you know you're
more than welcome to
um just if you do make sure you're not
using it with super super nested
selectors and that's one of the
guidelines when you're using SAS
actually is that I think they recommend
not going more than like three layers in
so card is the first layer
and then these elements platform is a
second layer and then icon the second
layer and then the modifier in the
element is the third layer so you don't
want to make too many nested things
because that just makes your selectors
and your final CSS really long which can
make your file bigger and it can make
things a little bit more confusing when
you have a lot of different styles and a
lot of different selectors
so we're actually doing pretty good here
um I think for this change we do need to
add that Arrow
icon that we see here so it's obviously
an up arrow for the up and then down
arrow for the red
and let's see if they oh yep they gave
us an icon up and an icon down SVG which
is interesting let's see if the colors
included in here oh yeah it is that's
probably why why they did that
down icons there
um another approach you could do if
you're trying to save on svgs is just
have this one icon up and then set the
fill based on the CSS class and then you
can use a transform to rotate it 180
degrees for the other class but
obviously this works just as well
and then that way we don't need to
necessarily create additional CSS styles
for the up and down versions so so
I think what we're going to do is in
here
it's sort of like what we did with the
icon up at the top so we had an image
with the icon then we had the username
so we might need to do the same thing
and add a few more
um selectors here
so I'm gonna say image
Source let's see if I can get away
without having to create a new class for
this
um images
oops
images
and then icon up
shoot
there we go no
I'm used to this new keyboard that I got
um the placement's a bit different from
what I was using before
alts up
Arrow
okay so I think what's gonna happen is
I'm gonna probably have to create
another div to enclose the thing the 12
today similar to what we did with the
follower count just to make things align
a little bit more neatly vertically
see I can see the icon is at the bottom
and you know I could do something like
you know position
absolute top and then set like a very
specific pixel width and I have to set
the parent to position at relative so it
doesn't fly up the page
[Music]
um
so you can kind of Center it that way
but then of course you need to
when it's positioned absolute doesn't
take up space on this on the page so
we'd have to say something like oh man I
don't even know this is going to work
but display inline block
and then set padding left to something
I'm just using pixel just for the ease
of it and then you would position
the icon
left zero pixels
you know and then just kind of eyeball
it to center it
but I feel like that's kind of a lot I
try to avoid using position absolute
unless I really have to I feel like you
could just as easily
fix this by using you know flexbox which
is I think we did here with the the
Facebook icon
and the only difference we'd have to do
is create another div here for the 12
today content so
we'll create a new
selector card underscore underscore
number
for lack of a better word
it's 12 today
so now we can set card change to display
Flex
and I usually try to put my flexbox and
or css good properties first
um but
you can do whatever order makes sense
for you okay now this is a problem
because
having an image as a flex box child will
make it stretch automatically unless you
explicitly
um set align items I think so let's see
if that works align items Center there
we go
if you don't explicitly set a line items
I think it'll say like stretch as it
yeah so you can see that
so we just had a line items to Center
and everything's happy let's see if it
actually tell us let's look so I
uncheck this so This rule won't take
place let's check the computed and see
oh yeah online items is normal which I'm
assuming is stretch based on what we
just saw here so we'll do that justify
content Center because by default
Justified content will be at the
beginning
select start
so we don't want that so Center
slide those styles to card change as
well
again we're sort of grouping the flexbox
style rules together
okay looks pretty good I think we need
to add a little space between the arrow
and the number
yeah so let's double check that
four pixels so what I want to do is
maybe add a margin right to the number
so
under card change
underscore underscore number
and you'll notice that in my style I
sort of try to follow the order of the
elements in the HTML markup so because
card change comes first it's the parent
to card number I'm putting card number
after the card change set of rules so
what we're going to do oh yeah add space
to margin right
and it was eight I think I can't
remember
four
wow totally off
man I'm so glad I added this Ram
function to convert from pixels to Rems
for me because if any of you watched my
previous selling previous videos I would
always have to pull out my calculator
every time and it was kind of a pain
um
okay that margin right's not working and
I think it's because
I have an image tag which is by default
display inline I think
so I need to set it explicit to display
Block in order for the
margin two happen no that didn't work at
all oh you know why it's because I added
it to card change
now added to card number
yeah
so I wanted to add it to the image tag
here
so I could create another class here
card you know card I'm just going to
score Arrow or whatever but sometimes I
sort of balance out creating you know
the need to create new classes and new
selectors with using an element selector
especially for images so this image tag
is in the card change div so if I add
image tag there
there we go save that
it's I know that this style rule is only
going to affect image tags that are
inside the card change div so you can
see again that using Bim really helps to
avoid you know conflicts in naming
because everything is a very unique
a unique name there we go so that space
looks a lot better this car is looking
pretty good
see what else we need to do here so we
got all the main elements here I got the
padding set I think we need to do a
little border radius here you can see
the corners are slightly rounded
then we need to take care of the bar
hello
let's see where it tells you about the
Border
it's mixed okay that's
how do you oh gosh
um
well tell you the Border radius
rectangle
oh it looks like it's five five pixels
Corner radius
it's something they call it Corner
radius so Corner radius of five which is
border radius in CSS speak
of the card
to go all the way back up to the card
selector and we'll go border radius
oh gosh can't type at all
REM five and it's I think the same all
the way around
okay so we can
kind of hard to see this but you can see
that it is a little bit rounded
now we want to do the stripe so let's
see
how tall this is
maybe this is it here we go four pixels
tall
so let's just try and see
if I can add that through
order
top
um five pixels so round five solid and
then we want that Facebook color
so Facebook
okay let's see if this works oh wait
need to be dash dash Facebook
come on
there we go now I can see everything
all right let's check our browser okay
that didn't do anything
really
let's try reloading
hello
should I add it to the right place in
card
oh card dash dash Facebook I didn't add
the modifier
here we go it's a card Facebook
all right now it should show up
oh there we go it looks pretty good
yeah it looks very close to the design
I'm pretty happy with that okay so now
let's create the other cards and the
good thing is now that we know that this
is correct we can just copy and paste
these selectors here so in container is
the card element
so I'm gonna go like this
and is that right yeah so one
two three
when I save this
and you know I might honestly add some
space just to be able to parse it a
little bit better myself
so now we should have four Facebook
cards
let's remove the space here from the
change element just so we know what
belongs to what card
okay so now we should have four Facebook
cards on our website
okay and we do
now of course we didn't add the grid
stuff we can see it they're trying to
sync the scroll
it's a little bit buggy anywho
let me think about this so yeah let's
just let's do the grid layout now so
obviously
we mentioned before this is going to be
four columns
I guess we can add the space between
them 30 pixels I would usually use maybe
grid for this but I think you can also
use flexbox
I think the main advantage grid is head
over flexbox among other things is the
gap property but I think flexboxes
slowly going to get the Gap property
see let's see if that's available
can I use.com
oh so Gap actually is using a flexbox
unless you're using IE 11 but
if you're using i11 you're gonna have
way bigger problems in flexbox gap so
let's just see how this looks with
flexbox just because we did use grid for
I think the header stuff so we're going
to add the grid stuff in the parent
section tag which is a container so I
guess I'll have to add another class to
make this a flex parent and because we
know there's a two sets of grids so the
top cars and the bottom cars and they're
all using the same four column layout
might want to reuse that class so
let's add a new class Flex Dash parent
and then in the layout SAS file
we'll add another
set of rules here for Flex parent
and it's stacked to one call on mobile
so the display Flex needs to be in our
breakpoint Nixon
medium
display Flex
now let's see what we got all right so
now they're all in the same line
which is good
let's kind of focus on the desktop
version for now and we want to add space
so we'll say gap of RAM 30.
now we have a nice cap now let's see if
it really goes if they only add the Gap
space to the between the items
sweet
oh that's interesting chrome doesn't
have
a flexbox inspector I guess we don't
really need it since we can obviously
see it's working
um cool there's a lot of Gap I think
between rows as well now let's see how
it looks on mobile
not great
so this needs to be centered I'm
assuming
yeah as you can see here
so how do I want to Center these I could
center them by saying card
margin Auto
but then to add space I would have to
say like margin zero Auto 30 pixels Auto
but then that would this would need to
be only for
um small and then it wouldn't happen on
desktop so I have to cancel it out on
desktop which is a little bit annoying
so I wonder if it might be better to use
flexbox for mobile also but have it be
wrapping
and maybe I'll do that
okay let's go back to here I need to
flex pairing because that's a little bit
too generic because you know I'm using
flexbox in multiple places
say cards oh gosh
um card
grid
this is one of those things where
you know I don't know what the right
name for this is
um
card grid
I think what I would sometimes do in the
past is because everything's in the card
Styles here I would do something like
card
underscore underscore
grid and then add some more Styles here
which works with the bem stuff works
with the bem approach that we've been
doing but then kind of goes against my
my personal approach of having this the
order in the SAS file follow the order
in the markup so it's kind of weird to
have the parent be a child the parent in
the HTML be a child in here I could also
just break another Rule and instead of
having this be the car be the only block
I would add cards
and then make this class name cards
so there's a lot of different approaches
I mean
honestly you know what is what's the
easiest to understand and just kind of
maybe pick an approach and try to be
consistent with that I might just do
cards
in the HTML class in the HTML yeah class
name and then add just another selector
here just for cards so then I'm not
polluting the layout styles with
something that's specific to the card
grid
so you know you can kind of see it's a
little bit of an exact science
so we wanted to
move the display Flex to mobile also
and then Flex wrap we want to allow it
to wrap
and then I guess we'll move the Gap
property up to mobile 2. we'll probably
need some more Styles in here so I'm
just leaving the the break point there
um what's the next thing we want to do
if we're using cards to use flexbox
what we could do is set Flex Direction
to column
for mobile
and then for
medium and up we'll say Flex direction
is row
so that way it'll stack reading flexbox
actually stack the items so now you can
see
stacking nicely and we have the four
columns on desktop now obviously this
needs to be centered I think let's go
back to the design uh Here We Go Mobile
so it looks like the mobile cards are
going all the way across they're wider
than what we have on desktop here so
this is 326 and this is 255.
so I guess what we could do is have the
cards be 100 with on mobile and then
maybe on tablet have it be two columns
and then on desktop before columns would
that work
see
so I think I had this temporary thing
here
so I think I might need to cap the max
width of the cards well let's just see
what happens when we remove this
I think things might be strangely
yeah this is a bit weird I need to I
think set the card width on desktop to
25 oops 25 percent
um
so I think what I should do to do that
is card
um and set the flex property to one
so Flex of one means
each flexbox child which is each card
has the same ratio of dividing up the
horizontal width with each other so that
means since there's four cards they'll
each get 25 of the total widths and now
it's going all the way across which is
good so I think maybe that can just fix
our problem for us
but we'll have to test on tablet and see
how that looks okay let's just see what
happens Flex of one I'm not sure what
it's going to look like on mobile but
we'll find out
okay
okay I guess that looks pretty good
mobile also looks pretty good
so let's add a new layout for tablet
how do I do this that's interesting
create three paints from website
breakpoints let's see what happens when
we click that
[Music]
oh
below 640
and then yams of 40 which is sort of
tablet and then the desktop
pretty cool
must have read my Styles yeah that's
pretty interesting
okay this is 480 with which I guess
would be a very big phone I mean I guess
that's okay what you could do is set a
Max width on the card and then sort of
Center it but is everything else in the
mobile design centered
no it is left aligned
so it might look weird if the cards are
centered but then the text is like
aligned to the left
this is pretty wide for a phone I think
yeah
maybe we'll change this manually to
the 11
change this to a tablet size
I'm not really familiar with tablets but
I guess this one seems okay
oh boy
oh yeah that's that's different
happens with the iPad
810.
yeah still doing the stretchy thing
and then desktop is fine I think the
mobile styles are okay
um we'll just have them go all the way
across now for tablet
I don't know if we would really want the
card to go all the way across like this
it's because I turned Flex wrap on and
actually what if I don't want flexbox
crap on
if I don't do that then it's too wide
to fit so I do want flexbox wrap
but what I would like is to have it be
maybe two columns on tablet so let's
kind of test this out in the browser so
Flex of one is for mobile and this is a
shorthand property that will take up the
flex grow Flex string and flex spaces so
Flex basis is the default width and it's
zero percent
um when you just set using the flex
shorthand property Flex screw is the
sort of the speed at which the element
will grow in width to fit you know the
parent width and the shrink is how much
it'll shrink so what I think I want to
do is
um
to limit it to two columns I could set
something like
Flex
basis
uh 50 I think
and then don't let it grow so set Flex
grow to zero
oh gosh don't tell me
no 50 I want it to be two columns but I
think maybe the Gap property is
making the fifty percent be too much
yeah
oh that's annoying that's not cool I
think CSS grid won't do this like I
think if you set the Gap property to
this grid it'll just sort of nicely fit
everything
since he says grid if we did that we
would set the grid template to one
column for mobile we would set it to two
columns for tablet and set it to four
columns for desktop and it's kind of
looking a little bit better than what we
have here yeah let's let's switch over
to um CSS grid for this oh boy
foreign
grid and I think Gap still works for CSS
grid grid template
columns
is I guess one FR for
mobile and then for medium
we'll say grid template columns is
repeat two one FR so that means that
there will be two columns 1fr is sort of
like the flex amount ratio so the space
each one will have the same amount of
space and then we'll do include break
point
large
grid template columns
and we'll say four repeat four one FR so
it'll be the same width in four columns
and we'll delete this Flex one thing I
think that's all the flexbox Styles we
added
okay
[Music]
oh boy you know as much as I like
flexbox I think grid definitely has some
advantages so now this is very easy it's
a four columns on desktop
we got two columns on tablet and we got
one column on mobile nice so the layout
looks good I'm happy with that the next
thing I want to do is add these styles
for the other social media platforms so
let's go into our markup and
the first card is Facebook and then
second cards Twitter Instagram and
YouTube
so we're going to change the modifier
classes to match and then also the image
obviously
so this is the first card the Facebook
card
and here's the second card so card
Twitter
and then
change the image next one is Instagram
[Music]
and then last one is YouTube
and I think there's some other copy we
need to change too
so Twitter is 1044 and 99 today
[Music]
click up here
10 44.
99 today
and we're just hard coding these values
if this was you know an actual app you
know using data and stuff then we would
use
you know the framework or JavaScript and
the API to generate the numbers here but
we're just using hard-coded stuff
Instagram is 11k and then 10.99 today
11k
10.99
and what you might do if you are
generating a data from somewhere is in
order to be able to Target just a number
when you're changing it you might do
something like
wrap it in the span
and then you could Target the card
number
span child and then make that a number
but
we're not really worried about that
right now so we'll just kind of leave it
like that
okay and then YouTube is 8239 144.
eight
two three nine
144.
oh and it's down so
down
and down
and then we'll have to um I think add
some styles for the different modifiers
too
let's just see how this looks right now
Okay cool so yeah icons are showing up
um and you can see we did edit styles
for the down so it's red and we just
need to add the styles for the top bars
so because we have nicely organized our
Styles and our SAS file we can just look
down our file and we can see card has
this modifier here
oops so
we'll just copy that
and paste it here
and then replace the colors and I'm
assuming the colors have been named you
know
the name of the thing
okay
let's see if that worked
oh okay Instagram didn't work for some
reason
Instagram let's check our colors
um oh Instagram start and oh right it's
a linear gradient let's go to our design
again kind of take a closer look at this
this is the grains going from left to
right sort of and it's angled up a
little bit
oh there's three colors in there oh gosh
I'm so glad they do this this is amazing
it's seriously amazing
I'm gonna copy that
um
can I put a linear gradient in a border
top
I guess we'll find out
not sure if you can
oh boy yeah I don't know if you can
oh yeah
oh man this might make things a little
more complicated than I was sort of
hoping
well it didn't make an error so
let's see
yeah it didn't work
yep
let's just let's look this up CSS
linear gradient in Border I'm pretty
sure this doesn't this will not work
probably to fake it somehow let's see
foreign
yeah they're using pseudo Elements which
I think is what I'm gonna have to do
I mean it looks really cool
okay
um
I feel like they didn't give us the
colors we wanted or like there were
three colors when I look at the design
except right that's the Instagram and
color okay
and this is the
five the middle color is not listed so
we'll just have to add that in
copy that
okay and the angle is 225 degrees so
let's think about this I want to add it
in a pseudo element so we can't use the
Border thing so let's comment this out
[Music]
Okay so
with the card
that has
um
okay so with the card
with the modifier of Instagram
we want to add a pseudo element that
will look like the Border but it's not a
border it's a pseudoelement
so let's get the pseudo element working
first
so we'll put it in the before
pseudo element now for pseudo element
you have to set the content to something
whether it's an empty string or
something else otherwise it's not going
to show up at all on the web page and I
learned that the hard way
okay so the four student element content
is blank we'll set the height to
I believe it was five based on what we
have up there width I guess will be a
hundred percent and I'm gonna have to
set this to you I think
position actually let's just see what
happens if we don't have anything I
think I might need to use position
absolute for this but I'm not sure I'll
set the background to
what was it Instagram
start
and we'll just worry about the linear
gradient later we're just trying to
figure out
how to make this element at all for
Instagram
so again we're kind of breaking things
down
doing things step by step so the first
step is just getting this pseudo element
working
okay so here it is
um with the zero why is that maybe
position relative
we actually set to display block oh
there we go that worked
oh my gosh and the other problem is
because it's relative the padding in the
card is limiting the width of this so
that's kind of annoying I mean I guess I
could do
manually add the padding in so it'd be
calc 100 plus I think it was 30 pixels
so times two is 60 pixels
um but then obviously I'd have to
I think I might have to do position
absolute
and then width is 100 percent
and I think I need to set this to
position relative to limit
the absolute thing because otherwise
if you don't set the parent of an
absolutely positioned element to
position relative it's going to just
sort of keep going up your tree until it
hits whatever position has positioned
set
or we'll just go all the way up to the
top in the body that's why it was so
long earlier so position now salute and
we'll say left of zero top of zero
the problem is when you want to it's not
taking the Border radius so I think I
need to set overflow to Hidden there we
go
now the other problem is I'm a little
worried that because it's positioned
absolute it's not actually taking up any
space on the page it's just kind of like
floating wherever you stick it
so I think that's made the content in
the Instagram card go up you know five
pixels
so I guess we could fix that by setting
you do padding top
of
1.565 grams plus five pixels
or we could try doing something like at
a margin top to take up that space so
margin top of five pixels
so that seems like it's better it's a
little hacky but I think to make this
linear ingredient work we kind of have
to do that so
let's do this so card platform is going
to have a margin top of 5 pixels
and then I'm not saving because it's
going to automatically update my style
and update this website and I want to
make sure I copy everything so the card
will just set all the cards to position
relative and overflow hidden because
that's not a terrible thing
I'm gonna be a terrible thing for all of
them to have that
and then the before element is all this
stuff here I didn't add any of this to
the Styles yet so card
oh I did here
something under background
content height width and background
this is the position absolute stuff
okay save that I like putting the
position stuff first
after content
and that's like putting width first
okay
I think that it's not the same I like
can't even tell
let's add a guide
and then brutal guided 100 pixels
[Music]
I can't see anything
um
let's get rid of these other ones here
okay guys
hover over the rulers to show a guide on
the side of the guys are never swing on
any pixels it is Click anywhere on the
road add a permanent guide there okay
so hover
over
let's go to desktop view
hover over the ruler oh there we go
these aren't perfectly lined
I think it's because of the icon height
oh man okay so let's fix this I guess is
the icon of different heights so it's
like
slightly misaligning and then of course
this one is like really different
so first maybe I'll set a height for the
platform element
yeah
this is 20 pixels let's see how tall
Twitter one is
I'm just testing my theory that the icon
height is responsible for the weird
alignment yeah it's 17.
so I think I need to say
which one's the tallest one
Instagram looks pretty tall 20.
YouTube
is
YouTube is 20. so if we say card
platform height is 20 pixels then you
can see the Twitter one kind of went
down a little bit
and let's see I'm just doing this to
sort of debug
make sure everything is centered
correctly that seems good so we'll set
height of 20 pixels for card platform
here we go all right
REM 20.
so now
see that uh
so everything except Instagram looks
pretty good
so for Instagram what happened to that
margin top that I set
uh five pixel I think
oh I need to be specific to Instagram
duh so maybe
card Instagram card platform hmm
a for card Instagram I'll add a specific
padding top of
five six two five
plus five pixels Ram
there we go cool thing about calc is
that you can combine units so I think
this is
awesome so go back to card
and originally the padding was Ram 25.
so we'll have to remember that and we'll
see
oops
padding top calc
it's the ram 25.
let's see if this works uh plus Ram five
okay there's no error which is good see
if this actually happened
looks a little bit more centered which
is great I think I added it to the here
we go the padding oh didn't work
oh golly
um
so it's really 25 pixels plus five
pixels
which is 30 pixels
wait I can just do Ram I don't need the
calc
dumb
Ram 25 plus 5 is 30. so 30. there we go
there we go
okay there we go
so now leave the guide here this is
actually a really cool feature of poly
pane making sure things are aligned yes
everything is centered now this is a
wonderful day okay
so you go back here tab looks pretty
good
mobile looks pretty good so there's
padding around everything okay I did
notice that I forgot one thing
um the Instagram card I just put that
temporary orange color and it's supposed
to be a linear gradient if we look at
the design again see it's supposed to be
this thing here so let's put that in
let's go back into our code
so I had set the that color bar on the
top of the cards as a order top but for
Instagram because it's a linear gradient
you can't make a border like a linear
gradient you have to use this
what a pack you work around and put it
in a pseudo element
so here's the temporary color the
background thing so I think I can just
replace that with the linear gradient
that I copied from the design file so
we'll just copy that
and then
let's cut that out for now reel in your
gradient stuff and we want to replace
these with the variables that we made
and let's just go back and see what we
did okay so it's Instagram start
Instagram middle Instagram end so copy
that first one
um actually it looks like this might be
I might have it backwards so I think
this is the end middle and then start
try that
oh yeah VAR
and then
middle
and
let's make sure we're not throwing an
error okay good so
there we go and what this is saying is
the linear gradient
I think if you don't set
um some of the parameters like the angle
it'll be like a horizontal gradient I
believe right but you can set options so
like this is 225 degree angle so you
know it's slightly angled up I think
and then we can set as many colors as we
want and then the percentages sort of
tell you where that color starts so
let's load the website again see if
um oh
nice that was pretty easy right
I just had to I think it's one thing I'm
really liking about figma how you can
just copy these styles from figma itself
like it has that export option yeah so
cool okay so that was a little small
thing that we forgot last time and
another thing that I want to sort of
update here is in poly pain it's a
little bit of a pain for me to have to
like try to horizontally scroll between
the different things so if you go up
here I have it set on horizontal layout
but I think I'm going to try let's see
what vertical does
I guess that sort of works do you want
it all the same page and then there is
focus
so you can
it creates tabs for each of them at the
top which maybe I think I might like
this better yeah let's stick to this one
um the vertical one also seemed pretty
cool okay let's look back at the design
and see what we want to do next and I
think we need to work on the other grid
of cards down there so if we look at
that second grid of cards it has some of
the same items as the top row of cards
as we mentioned earlier so like the icon
and the the number for the percentage
change
is the same
there's a new thing it has a subtitle
for page views so we need to figure out
how we want to build this out and each
card is divided into four I guess you
could say four quadrants it looks like
so I might use something like CSS grid
to create a template where it has two
columns and then two rows yeah let's do
that with CSS grid
so let's take a look at the markup and
figure out how we want to build those
that second grade of cards out okay so
this section tag is the first row of
cards and let's kind of minimize each
card so we can take a better look at
everything so I'm probably going to do
is create another section tag with
these same classes because the container
class is what sets the max width and
centers it on large viewport centers it
on large viewport widths and then the
cards class I believe if I remember
right yeah so this one sets a display of
the creative cards in a four column
layout on desktop two column on tablet
one column on mobile so yeah I think we
want to create another section tag has
the same classes so
section dot container Dot cards
and it generates that for us
and then each card will have the markup
for each of the items and I think what
I'm gonna do is let me think about this
do I want to just copy this and then
just change it or do I want to start
from scratch and I think I might want to
start from scratch because the design is
pretty different like these top cards
everything is just in one column and
centered versus this grid down here
so I think I can probably reuse this
card class
let's see so the card class it has the
background color which is the same the
color of the text
the padding border radius and then the
text line is Center which I don't need
but we can take care of that later but I
think there's enough properties here
that are shared between the top cards
and the bottom cards that I'm going to
want to use the same class for that
then we can differentiate it with you
know either a modifier or a helper class
so
yeah let's do that yeah this stuff is
just all pretty different
um
Okay so
put some space there so with this second
set of cards I'm going to do sort of
what I did in the previous section and
I'm going to start just building one
card out and then once I have that set
make sure all the Styles and everything
are correct then I will you know copy
and paste to create the other the other
cards so let's make our first card so
card
I'll start at the very beginning
um and then we'll move the markup into
there so it's page views the Facebook
thing the number and then the change
so I think this is what we want for the
first card now here's where I need to
figure out how I want to lay out this
stuff
so what I think I want to do is create
a grid template for these second cards
now where do I want what should the
class name be for this and where should
I put it in our SAS file
so if we look in the card SAS file
we have these modifiers for the top
cards to control that um that colored
stripe at the top and I think I might do
another modifier for the grid inside the
individual cards and you know this is
again one of those situations where
there's not one right answer at least in
my opinion you could do this you know
multiple different ways so I think my
options are either creating another
modifier to make that grid layout or I
could create a helper class so meaning
instead of doing card and then let's say
we make a modifier class for card dash
dash grid
for like a better word
and then making
this be another modifier here we could
do a helper class which is doing
something like
I don't know card Dash grid so this will
be the second class name and I'll set
all those grid Styles in this card grid
class and it's kind of the same thing I
think maybe for readability because
we have these modifiers are ready for
the different social platforms
I don't know if I want to just add
another modifier maybe that would be
better in terms of the bem approach but
I think yeah I don't know
[Music]
um
yeah the uh the naming and organizing
part of your style I think is maybe not
the most difficult part but it
definitely takes a lot more thought than
you might think at the beginning trying
to figure out what do I want the class
name to be and where do I want to put
that okay I think I'm going to try to
stick with the
um
bem methodology and just say card dash
dash grid and make that another modifier
here
so that way they're just all like under
the card selector here okay so now that
we have this selector let's just save
that really quick
and then I think I probably need to put
each of these things in their own child
div of the card grid so that they can be
you know laid out in the grid template
so
so let's think about this
card grid and then in the card grid will
be the children
what I'm sort of thinking through in my
mind right now is
if I create a separate div with the
unique class which of these things
then it's going to create more classes
and stuff that I'm gonna have to create
like what I have to make another element
in here I'm not really sure
alternatively I could do a completely
different approach and put all these
grid Styles in a new SAS file and call
it card Dash grid
and do something like this or it's a
card Dash grid make a new SAS file
called card Dash grid scss and put all
the styles for that in that new file and
that is actually sort of appealing
because then I'm separating out the
different styles yeah so it's just one
of those things where you just gotta
kind of choose choose one approach and
and just follow it yeah I think I might
want to do that just because adding more
modifiers and elements along with the
existing card elements and modifiers I
think might make things a little bit too
confusing yeah let's do that I don't
know if that's the best way but I think
I'm gonna do that
so we'll make a new SAS file
card Dash grid scss and I do want to
note that the single hyphen is not
something that's really part of them but
I just do that with names that are a
little bit longer I could say card grid
with no hyphen but it's a little bit
more readable so card grid
is going to be the block name for this
so we'll save that
and of course since we made a new SAS
file
we need to
forward card Dash grid
there we go
okay yeah this feels a little bit better
I think just separating things out will
make things less confusing hopefully
when when if we have to go back and
change things
so we're going to do this card grid and
then in here so we could say something
like uh
card Dash grid is that and that's a
block underscore underscore for the new
element and for the first one we'll say
maybe username
and then this will go in there
and then maybe maybe because a car
that's not super long we'll just do it
like this so I guess prettier just
automatically modifies it like that okay
and then card grid underscore underscore
number I think and I'm sort of using I
want to use the same element names as we
had up here
um yeah so let's follow our account
platform and username and this is just
so
um actually I don't know if this is
going to I don't know if this is a great
thing because
um
I want the styles from the card
greetings you need to actually be
similar the same as card underscore
underscore username right because they
share a lot of the same styles
so I think I need to
separate out just the styles for the
grid stuff with the card grid thing but
for the child elements I think I need to
do you know card username
and then
the number
so this is the number here
let's make sure it matches up with the
selector up here so card username and
then card followers card count
big so I think I wanted to do card count
small for these cards here
let me double check and make sure that's
the class I made
um card
count small yeah so we're going to use
that here so I hope that makes sense but
I'm trying to put all the styles that
are shared between the top cards and the
bottom cards in the card SAS file
because otherwise I would have to if
they have a different class name like
card grid underscore underscore username
or account or whatever I would basically
be having to copy and paste the Styles
over there so I would rather they just
had the same classes and keep everything
as minimal as possible so this is just
this is pretty normal back and forth
when you're building something because
you don't always get it right the first
time so there's just a lot of trial and
error
okay so this is better and to take care
of the the grid child items because you
know I do need to set some grid styles
for these elements here I'm going to put
it in card grid and I might do something
like just you know nth child one nth
child two three and four so that I don't
have to create additional classes for
these in the card grid so
I don't know if that's the right thing
to do but I don't want to create more
classes than I really need okay so 1044
followers
so if you look at the design oh this is
interesting so I think this is going
back to some of the accessibility things
that I mentioned in the research video
because this is just giving you the icon
for the platform and this is just giving
you the number it's not actually saying
you know username here and then this
many followers and I'm guessing they
included that in the copy because wait a
minute is this even the right copy
so the second the second card here is
supposed to be page views 87. I might I
don't know if I copy the right thing I
might have just copied what was in the
first card oops
1044 where'd that number come from
now this is from Twitter 11k
8239 oops
yep I copied that wrong so kind of
forget everything I just said
um
oh my gosh all right delete that and
then we need to find out where the copy
starts for these second cards
so it starts with this
sub headline overview today
and that's here
okay so this stuff
I don't need
okay
so the overview today the sub headline
I'm probably gonna make that an H2 tag
because the social media dashboard
that's in an H1 tag and you want to kind
of keep the hierarchy
going down the page
um so because this is a subtitle it's a
bit of a smaller font so that sort of
tells you that it's a sub headline and
you only want one H tag per page so this
is going to be an H2 tag and we figure
out where we want to put this because in
the grid thing
in the container cards grid each of
these divs each of these child divs is
in the grid
so I feel like I want to include the h2
tag inside this section but
um you know I obviously want it to take
the full width of everything not be part
of the card grid
so let's think about this let's go back
to the cards rule here
um Here We Go Cards display grid yada
yada
yeah so all the child elements in cards
is going to be part of this card grid so
what I could do is
move the cards element
[Music]
to its own div here
so then in here is where
the second row of cards would be and
then that way when we add this h2 tag
with overview today
it won't be part of the grid it'll be
full width and its own thing
so yeah okay now in this first card we
want to add markup for page views the
icon 87 and then the three percent so I
don't get confused again we're gonna
oh man he's doing that
um let's just move this in here
okay
now
we want to create a div for each of
these things
[Music]
so page view is going to be the first
child
and the second child is the Facebook
icon I believe yeah
so let's just copy it from where we had
it up here
um
here we go
what did I do
okay and then 87 will go up here and
then three percent
will go in the last child
okay so now we have our first card
obviously I haven't really made many
styles here
so you can see
um
I can't see that
okay I guess I need to go back to
let's go back to the horizontal thing
and that's a vertical also has a
horizontal scroll
[Music]
to do that and there's space for the
screen
can't put it on the left side this is
annoying
so you can't see this I'm going to just
quickly add some temporary styles to
boilerplate
and I want to say
[Music]
in height
150 VH so we'll hopefully add some extra
space
there we go
yay all right here we have the card and
everything's showing up it's taking the
card Styles so now I need to add the CSS
grid styles for the grid part
so it's going to be card grid
so in card grid we'll say display grid
because we're doing the grid for all
breakpoints mobile tablet and desktop
we'll say grid template columns
good template
repeat
four
um I guess one fr
and then grid template rows
and we'll do
are they the same it's probably the same
repeat two one FR I just kind of start
with this and then if we need to change
it we can
okay so now let's see if that changed
anything here
oh something's wrong
so that space shouldn't be there
okay cool
here we go
oh wait I want two columns
yeah there we go
[Music]
two columns
all right so now it's in the layout
General layout that we want let's copy
over some of the classes that we created
for the top cards so that they'll be in
the bottom cards now
so the first one was the page views I
actually don't know if that I think that
might be its own style
[Music]
let's see
this inter bold 14.
so I think we might need to create a
title for that
think about this
[Music]
card
subtitle
let's put it at the top so subtitle
font
font size RAM 14. font weight 700.
and then for the card icon
[Music]
let's see where that was here card icon
um I don't really need this margin right
thing because that was just for the main
card so I wonder if I just leave it
without a class
what that would look like
[Music]
actually seems okay so let's just leave
that
87 that's the number
so before it was card count card count
big so we'll do this
and then instead of big it's small
because the number is smaller and we'd
already created this style here
small
so we just need to add this style for
smaller number
let's enter a bold 32.
[Music]
there we go
and let me just make sure what it is on
mobile
32. okay it's the same
[Music]
and then the number thing
and that was
card change I believe
yeah card change card change up and then
card number so I'll need two dibs I
think
actually I need I will need the image
too
uh where was that here we go and then
card number
foreign
[Music]
thing
and then we need to add the class for
the card change card change up
[Music]
all right now let's see what we've got
okay so we can see these styles are
taking effect and they pretty much match
and this number is smaller here which is
good let's see what else we need to do I
think we need to align these things on
the left to the left and the line of
things on the right to the right
yeah
um the pattern looks about the same
24.
it's about the same the top card so yeah
I think we're just going to align things
to the right to the left and the right
and then the top row looks like it's
aligned in the middle vertically and the
bottom row it looks like it's aligned
on the bottom so we'll have to take care
of all those alignment issues here
I went to card grid
and
[Music]
so I'm going to do is I don't want to
create
I mean I guess I could say card subtitle
there
yeah so let's do that we're going to
create
rules for card subtitle card count card
change
within card grid
I don't know if it's the best thing to
do but at least it will be a little bit
more descriptive when you're looking at
card grid
yeah let's do it now I might be straying
a little bit away from strict bem format
here but
I do
card subtitle
card count card change
subtitle card card change oh yeah and
then the image
um
the class on that
I think I didn't want to because
this is adding new styles that I don't
need
so because there's just an image here
um
actually I think I do need to add a
class here
so that I can identify it
um
this one was card platform
card icon
like I could reuse it I guess
um
card platform was a parent div which is
the same hierarchy as what we have here
so card platform what styles did I write
for that
oh yeah I do not want this because this
is a lot of this is the flex stuff that
made this centered vertically so yeah I
don't want that
[Music]
um
I wonder what would happen if I just had
an image by itself without having this
div the wrapperative
there we go let's see if this messes
anything up
okay I guess that looks okay
so let's add some of the alignment
issues let's add some of the alignment
rules to the card grid so justify
content which is the horizontal since
our grid is going this way
to find content I want this to be
do not space between
it's a flexbox thing but let's see if
that works oh that did not work
um
align items
that looked like it worked yeah so oh
wait a minute
let's turn on the grid
uh card grid
there we go
all right what's going on here
um external on items centered in the
cell
oh this is because I did
um taking both rows the same height
because they're both 1fr and they're
taking the height from this 87 thing so
okay there's a couple problems here one
is that I think the card may not
actually be tall enough it's 122 pixels
right now
foreign
height but
I think I seem to align each cell
individually if I'm not mistaken
okay let's just go to CSS tricks grid
guide
CSS tricks has these very very very
helpful
resources for flexbox and grid so let's
see
let's look for justify
okay so justify items and justify
content so align screwdimes along the
inline row this value applies to all
good items inside the container start
aligns items to be flushed with the
start edge of their cell oh this is what
I need to do
so I think Justified content is the
cells themselves just for atoms will
align each cell content within the cell
so let's do that let's just see what
this how this works
um
all right
I think it's supposed to be start
okay
this is going to line everything to the
left if if this works
okay yeah looks like that's what's
happening
so I need to align the other things to
the right so this is going to be the
image and then the change
so I can override that with justify self
and
for card change let's just make sure
that's working okay that is working
and
I think I might need to do a compound
selector here so image comma card change
so this will affect the image tag for
the icon and then the card change
divot as well
okay
good now let's use these handy little
guide here and it does look like it's
centered vertically which is great and
then here
it's like sort of
I think they're both on the bottom
let's see
oh I guess it's centered
um let's see if we can
do this card number
um align self and oops
oh geez
oh it's a
not card number card change
going on here
okay so I'm gonna have to do card change
and then card
number I think it was for the 87.
let me see if I even got that right card
count
I don't quite look the same I think
maybe because this is sort of
determining the height of each row
and I want to get rid of that for sure
margin bottom
yeah margin bottom
so card count and card change will be
aligned self end
um
card count I want to get rid of that
margin bottom
zero
and then
card count
card change
itself and
foreign
so the top row is centered vertically
bottom row is aligned to the bottom
okay great
let's check the height of this card too
114 so I think I need to add some space
between the page views and then the
number
yeah there's a lot more space here you
can see this
20 21.
so I will add space
and I kind of want I don't want the
first row to be the same height as the
second row so I think maybe
I think there's a property called like
fit content or something
that didn't do anything oh what if I do
Auto
just the
oh that actually kind of worked okay
good so now the rows are only taking the
height of the content in the row so
let's change that so in card grid grid
template rows repeat two
Auto
okay good and then now I can add the
space with The Gap property so Gap
um I think it was 24.
let's double check that
21 and the whole card we want to be 125.
so we can adjust that
oops
um what the get property's not working
oh I think I did something wrong
oh it's not using the
um
it's not taking the function
there's also not throwing an error which
is weird I think I didn't remember to
add this util thing because that's where
the REM function is but I'm really
surprised that it didn't throw an error
in gulp
okay now the space is there
interesting
okay let's check the size of the card
so maybe we'll add two pixels to that to
make it 125 to match a design
there we go
all right looking pretty good
not bad
all right let's add the other cards to
our markup so there's four times two
there's eight cards oh wait I forgot the
subtitle
let's take the Styles here
inter bold 24.
it actually looks pretty close
um I guess because I made that in H2
so since it's an H2 tag I'm going to put
the Styles in the typography SAS file
here we go h two
font size REM
24.
it says 24 on desktop
let's see if it's the same on mobile
slightly smaller
24 nope it's 24 all the way around
okay
boom that makes that pretty easy
and I might need to add a margin bottom
to this 24 margin bottom and let's check
what it is on mobile
usually you have more space on the
desktop version
let's just say 24 for both I think
that's close enough
all right that's looking pretty good
cool
cool okay
I think that is good for this card Style
so let's go close these things out
and so here's a card grid
sorry card card grid so this is for the
Facebook card so
I'm just going to
two
three four five six seven eight
so let's see how that looks
nice
yeah looks good
cool
and this is the benefit of creating
styles that you can reuse because I
create all the grid styles for the cards
for the top row and I can just reuse the
same classes for the bottom row
so it makes things efficient and it also
makes things easier on me I don't have
to you know write the Styles every
single time
so now we just need to update the copy
in each card to match the design
so
second card is likes
it is still Facebook 52.
and it's a down of two percent
and then we need to change this
oops I changed the wrong one I think
I'll just move that up
there we go
okay
then it's likes Instagram five four six
two
five four six two
and the percentage was two two five
seven
and it's green
okay
then the next one is Instagram again
so let's copy this
and it is profile views
Instagram and then it's 52k
1375 percentage change
and then this one is retweets 117 303.
[Music]
303 and it's up
then likes
also for Twitter
uh 507 and 553
okay and then YouTube like oh their
YouTube's not doing so well
YouTube likes
107 and down 19.
seven
down
um what was that 119 there we think I
need to change
the down arrow for the other down arrow
it's alt text
okay and the last card YouTube Total
views
let's copy the YouTube
icon
1407 down 12.
and then down
[Music]
that was caught the whole selector there
12.
hey
and I guess I can just delete this
foreign
y
looking pretty good
you calms
yeah
one column on mobile
sweet
yeah I mean that looks good
go back to the design make sure we
didn't miss anything yeah it does seem
like it's matching design pretty well
and
I do need to do the hover state so let's
do that
so the hover state is
on the cards when you hover over a card
it looks like it just changes the
background color
see if anything else changes
three three eight a three three eight
five five
foreign
it doesn't look like there's anything
else like it's not
scaling up and there's no box Shadow at
least that I can tell
okay so it's really just a color change
and I'm assuming this is the same color
three three a five five yeah
I think that's kind of it for
the hover States
so let's find out what that color was
three three eight five five
so the dark background was there
is that right
[Music]
what is this in uh
hsl that's kind of funny I wonder if you
can do hsl and figma
X2 hsl
you know actually I can do this in vs
code
I'll just do a test color here
test
and then we'll click on this and click
this
so it's 228
25 27. it looks like this is a new thing
so I'm going to say
card
hover
and then we'll move this
down where the card styles are
maybe here
so I might call this dark card hover
there we go
now we can copy this variable
go to the card SAS file
so here
I'll add a new selector for the hover
um pseudo element or pseudo class I
think is what it's called
pseudo elements are the before and after
and then
hover is a pseudo class
background far dark card hover
and to make it look a bit nice we'll add
a transition on that
background
150 milliseconds ease in out this is
kind of my default
animation timing
so now
um do any of the colors of the text
change when you hover let's find out
color is 8c98c6
1898c6 so it's the same color
okay so the text colors remain the same
it's just the card colors that are
changing when you hover
cool
and then I wonder if I should add a
cursor
probably the card too
pointer
so this way if you hover over any part
of the card it goes to the hand and I'm
assuming that's going to be because if
you click on one of these cards it'll
give you some more details about the
analytics or whatever
so okay
this looks pretty good
so we've pretty much gotten all the
cards built and styled out according to
the design so the next step is going to
be
we need to look at some of the
accessibility things that we researched
in our research video
for the screener only text
um
and then we can start working on the
light mode and getting the toggle
working for switching between dark and
light mode
and also with the system preferences so
that it'll be dark mode if you set dark
mode in your OS and then light mode if
you said light mode in your OS
but it also gives you control if you
want to explicitly change
this website to dark mode or light mode
hey everyone this is part five of the
fundamentor series where I've been
building the social media dashboard with
a dark light toggle in this video we're
first going to check out some comments I
got on the last video and incorporate
their feedback into the website then
we're going to load either dark or light
mode on the website based on the user's
system preferences in their OS and last
we'll get that toggle working so that
the user can switch between light and
dark mode if they so choose alright
let's get into it
so here is what we have so far in the
challenge and I wanted to point out some
comments that I got in the last video
um which actually was really great
feedback so um this person Amar he was
saying he doesn't think there should be
three options for dark mode it should be
dark light toggle and system is a
default but then the user can switch
from dark to light if they want and what
I had done was that I had three options
for this toggle
um dark light and then system
preferences and I realized this comments
from both Amar and also another user big
squeak they both said the same thing
that you don't actually need the system
preferences option because you know you
can save the option based on your OS and
have the website load that and so you
don't actually need to manually have
that system preferences as an explicit
option and it kind of can be confusing
or distracting so I think that actually
makes a lot of sense so what we're going
to do is first kind of remove the system
option so that the toggle is back to two
options and when we're considering the
UI it's always good to go back to the
design
and we can see in the design that you
know the original toggle was two options
and it's really just a dark mode toggle
so it's sort of like a light switch
you're turning dark mode on or you're
turning it off to go to light mode
so dark mode off is on the right
position and then dark mode on is the
left position so I think I just kind of
got away from maybe what the design
originally intended which you know it
happens So yeah thank you to both Amar
and also big squeak for bringing this up
to me
so
here's our site and let's go back into
our code
and we want to go to the toggle
um and I do have the site already
running with Gulp and stuff so let me
just make this a little bit smaller
since we don't really need it right now
so here is the toggle and yeah we got
these three options here system
darken the light so I'm going to remove
system and I think that's all I need to
do oh yeah remove the labels too so
let's save that
and then go back to our site
okay so now it goes from dark to light
and I think it's a little bit wider now
than I really need it to be
um see what the design says
48. and obviously this is wider I think
because of the third option that I added
in there
and my toggle is 60.
and
let's see I'm trying to see
where I had set that width from
toggle
is one of our 3.75 Rams and one fr
o so let's look in the grid inspector
header toggle
okay so yeah you can see that this is
let me actually maybe zoom in a little
bit just so we can see the toggle a
little bit better
so it's those three columns it is one FR
3.751 FR so I actually want to remove
the oh not sorry not remove I want to
decrease the width of that metal column
to whatever 48 pixels is
so
see where that's set and
go into our SAS files let's find the
toggle toggle.scss
so this is one reason why I like SAS and
organizing all my files like this
because you know I know that I'm working
on the toggle so I can go into the
components folder because it's probably
there and then look for toggle so
splitting the the Styles up in partial
files I think is just it helps when you
have to go back and fix stuff
so here we go so REM 60 so now it's
going to be 48 and I think everything
else can stay the same
yeah so let's save that and go back to
the site and now we have just the two
columns
let me actually there we go
okay so that's pretty good I think also
if we look at the design it's just dark
mode
um
so I think maybe I don't need
I don't know if I need that label so I
need to make the first one dark mode
and then
but if it is a radio button you do kind
of want to label so maybe I can just
hide this second label so that
um it's not visible although it's not
visible but it would still be ready
picked up by screen readers but if
you're using a screen reader you
probably
don't necessarily
care about darker light mode I could be
wrong but
I think maybe I can just delete this
label
because actually the label the dark mode
is really just labeling the entire
switch it's not necessarily the choice
for the radio button so I think
maybe this shouldn't be the label for
dark but maybe it should be like the
the header kind of for the radio button
so I think I might need to look up what
the correct element like the semantic
HTML element I want to use for that so
let's see
let's check this link out
Okay so
Legend oh Legend maybe that's what is
for like the sort of title of the radio
button
yeah I think maybe that's what I want
so instead of label for dark
is going to be
Legend
oops
and then we will move this up
I think
under the field set if I'm not mistaken
see where though
yeah so it's the first element under
field set
okay
and then I might need to switch some of
these Styles since it's a different
element now yeah I wonder if I could
just put it in toggle wrapper
see if I can manually move it in the
browser
doesn't exactly work because toggle
wrapper is oh for the actual toggle yeah
I definitely don't want to do that
so I might need to do field set also
like display grid I guess wait right now
it is the three column thing and that
was originally for the label it was dark
than the toggle and then light so now I
remove light so I actually just need
this to be two columns
let's just test this in the browser
first
so I think it's just one fr
three rims
that right
um and then I don't want
I just want it's all in one row
[Music]
maybe Auto instead of one of our since
oh then I need to adjust the
okay let's just go into the code I need
to adjust the location of the cells
so let's figure out what we're going to
do so I want to set header toggle to be
two columns the First Column is going to
be the legend element second column is
going to be the toggle wrapper so let's
do that
toggle
oh label
um oh yeah so this this is sorry this is
the CSS grid parent
header toggle with toggle and I set the
Styles under toggle
okay so it's two columns
and we're going to remove this because
it's one row
and I think the Gap can be the same
and the label is what's different now so
I actually don't need the dark system
and light stuff anymore since we're not
doing that
I don't know if I do line self either
so instead of label it's Legend
and then the
so Legend and then it's toggle wrapper
is the second column so
Legend will be grid column
one and ends at two since it's just
taking up the first column
and then wrapper will be to
one to two I guess two to three is right
yeah
and then we'll move grid row because
it's just that one
and I think that should fix it
all right
um what's going on
why is it not all in one row like I want
it to
okay clearly some things are
larger than the grid
so weird I think I'm doing something
very wrong here and I don't know what
I'm going to start over
deleting all the grid properties
it's deleting all the grid properties
let's make sure we don't have anything
else weird here
okay
now
this is no grid is going on
so now let's try adding a grid
display grid
grid template columns we'll say two
columns
so
a1fr and then
let's say four rims
just say one of our 1fr
so now let's
okay so now it's already not fitting in
one row
I'm just going to add static things
so we'll do six Rems and three rooms
okay
so now let's place the first one
grid column
one two
what if I did two three
oh
interesting it's not doing anything
I wonder if the display block would do
something
I feel like I need to uh return my CSS
membership card or something so this is
not working it's not positioning this
anywhere which is weird
okay I'm just going to try to set this
as a div and see if that does anything
div
um grid column one two
let's see if two three oh so this moved
it so there's something about the legend
element not working
interesting
interesting so Legend element is not
getting affected by grid properties
which is very strange
let's see if we can do it for the toggle
wrapper
it's a grid column two three
so that's working
so let's look that up so CSS grid Legend
element not working
okay yeah setting the fields up to
display grid which is what I wanted
foreign
Legend is extremely rigid with very
little accommodation for change to the
atmos via display property which is what
happened when I tried to set it to
display the lock it didn't do anything
display grid is not supported on field
sets by any browser whoa when was this
written
18.
hmm
so I think maybe I can't do grid on the
field set
so let's delete that go back to this so
I think
this actually makes a lot of sense
because
I think in Sarah soydon's
example she was using display inline
block if I remember correctly
yeah I don't remember where this was set
but
I do remember that happening I was kind
of curious
why that was happening
so I wanted to display inline block for
the legend
oops
display inline block
explain line block two
hmm
I don't know why this is so hard
okay she has a thing here
um
so listen code pen
okay so the field set and she's using a
div
um oh same switching toggle
wait why is it commented out but it's
still showing up
oh this is just the H1 there
okay sheeted labels
so it seems like the legend
it forces it to be just above the toggle
itself
for some reason it's just not letting
you
control the display
if I this way in line
yeah it's not going to do anything
this is a very strange little thing
yeah so display property on trade on
field set and Legend
oh it said it does support it back on
field sets
the rendered Legend is not a child box
of the anonymous field set content box
oh interesting
so that's why I think that it couldn't
act as a grid child
all right let's read this spec
field set is is expected to act as
follows element will establish a new
block formatting context
this child is a legend element float is
none position none
I think what I'm actually going to end
up doing is switch this back to a label
so that it'll be dark mode on for the
first label and then dark mode off for
the second label but I'm going to hide
the second label
I don't know if that's the right
solution but
I think the legend is not necessarily
what I'm looking for
so
dark mode and then I'm going to add a
little span here
foreign
and I'm going to hide this with the
I think I did I do this last time
I don't remember
um
screen reader I want a screen reader
hidden thing
edit so I guess I can add it in now
okay screen reader
here we go
it's a visually hidden
so I'll take this
put it in our boilerplate
and then if I add this visually hidden
class to the span
then I'll add back that label
and do the same thing for the dark mode
off
I know it seems maybe silly because if
you're using a screen reader you're not
going to really be navigating this
toggle but
at least you'll be able to know that
it's there even if you're not selecting
an option okay so then
we're gonna go back to the toggle
yeah label
and we're gonna go back to display grid
um grid template columns
let's say one of our three rims
then label
what was it for
dark
I'm not sure if that's right but we'll
see um create column
one two
all right let's see if that does
anything
oh yeah toggle wrapper grid column two
three
or sorry right grid doesn't work at all
so
I think I actually need the label to be
before the toggle and then use display
inline block
okay
now it's sort of a line where I want it
and we'll need to get rid of that grid
column stuff
um
line height I think is going to match
the height of the toggle wrapper and
hopefully it'll be
more centered now yay
and then we need to get the space
between dark mode and the label
13 pixels
so we'll say margin right
rem13
Okay so
it's working
with the keyboard
okay that's a way longer than I think it
probably should have so I apologize for
that but now we have the two option
toggle back Bae learn something new
every day field set can't be display
grid or at least the late the legend tag
doesn't seem to be working with display
grid
yeah I guess that's a good lesson of
like don't over complicate things
you don't necessarily have to toss a
grid or Flex box on every single thing
since this is working just fine
um
with uh the label being
set like that
wait I am doing display grid
oh so I guess grid does work but yeah
it's like not turn over complicate
things and just controlling the
alignment with
um the line height property okay so the
next thing we want to do is I want to
start getting the logic working so that
if your system preferences are set to
either light or dark the website will
automatically
load either light or dark mode based on
the media query for prefers color scheme
so I think one of the links from my
notes was the prefers color scheme thing
from mdn so this is a media query
um it could be set to either light or
dark
zoom in a little bit
and then it's here so media prefers
color scheme dark so I believe
we can Target that to set the background
to be either light or dark then there's
another example on piccolilly
um which is a really great blog by
Andy Andy Bell he writes a lot of stuff
on CSS so this is a really good
explanation on the prefers color scheme
thing so let's just see how he did it
here
um here's the CSS
for the regular Styles and he's also
doing the visually hidden thing
um he's really good about accessibility
stuff too
so using CSS custom properties for the
different colors
which is what I did this is interesting
he's setting a color mode variable
setting it to light by default
it's interesting let's see
okay
here we go so the background is set to
VAR background
which is
a far back on a set by default to a
light color okay
and then
if you have your preferred color scheme
dark
then the color mode set to dark
okay
and then
also you're setting
the background to like the different
dark colors for dark mode data user
color scheme I'm not sure what that is
so if you have your OS set to dark mode
then you're setting the color mode
variable to dark
and then this selector is if the root is
not
data user color scheme then you're
setting it to
be confused
um looks like these are sort of doing
the same thing
okay let's read the explanation
if the user prefers dark mode inside the
media queero making the relevant theme
changes
the same media queer we're setting the
color mode which is
color mode dark
the Cs notice how the CSS is applied at
the HTML root element doesn't have a
data user color scheme attribute this is
to prevent the default overriding user
preference
okay so I guess he's setting this data
field on the HTML element if there is a
color scheme either light or dark
detected and it's saying he's setting it
with JavaScript
let's just do a search for this data
user color scheme because I'm not super
familiar with it okay
so the use of calcium equals dark
where's this set maybe user color scheme
do a search for that
okay
and this is the JavaScript part and he's
using
local storage
to set like to save if you have this set
okay so maybe we'll get back to this
later I think maybe right now
we want to
kind of just get the Bare Bones of
displaying maybe we'll just work on just
changing the background color
to be either dark or light
so
I'm sure there's a reason that he's
doing this stuff I think I might just
use prefers color scheme and then
set the variable for background to
um
White
and I think I'm going to
I don't know this is right but I think
I'm going to set the default to uh dark
let's think about this how do we want to
do this so we got this media prefers
color scheme so you can maybe start
setting this media query up
in our colors
and then I set the background color
I think in boilerplate
okay so I said the body background to
dark Background by default
but I wonder if I actually want just a
background variable and then in the
here
in the preferred color scheme the
background variable will be set to
different values
does that make sense I think that makes
sense or you could do the media query in
every single like thing here but I feel
like that
you'd end up adding a lot of media
queries for the first color scheme in
different places as opposed to having
them all in one place
okay so let's try this
um
does that make sense to create like I
don't even know if this is right but
background
and then set it to itself like VAR
dark background
I don't know if that's gonna work
and then
in body
you're just gonna say background
let's see if that did anything okay so
it looks the same
let's check out the body
all right so the background sets of our
background
which is a tavar dark background
I'm just going to change something just
to see if it'll work so let's do this
obvious different color here
I'll set background to the green color
okay so I guess you can sort of
set variables to other variables
is that
I mean it's working I don't know if
that's
great
okay so he said body so he's at body
background of our background too
um
yeah I guess you can background set to
VAR color dark okay
so I'm not totally off here
well since I didn't set it I think
usually people put light mode as a
default so maybe we'll do that
so we'll set it to light
by default and then
if the first color schemes have to dark
we'll do
root
background
dark
oh hey it changed
and I think in Windows
yeah here we go so this is Windows and
Mac will be a bit different but in your
settings color
you can choose dark lighter custom so
let's have our website open
and then have our settings open and
let's see
if this is working if I set this to
light it should change to a light
background so let's see if this works
oh
dang it did work
whoa
change back to dark
goes back to dark
not bad that's pretty cool kale that
part was sort of easy at least getting
the logic down and I think my Approach
is right too
so in light of that
let's work on changing all the colors to
be light the light mode by default and
then
you know getting the dark mode colors
set
and then the light mode color is set
so
started with the background and then we
want to also change the text colors
so let's see where I set this
um color set on body okay
so what I'm gonna do is
I guess just make another variable
let me see how Andy did it are all the
variables just set
yeah so background
it looks like
[Music]
um
he looks like background is initially
set in the same place as all the other
variables so we're just gonna have a
really long list of these things here
but I guess that's okay
so we'll say text color
and by default we want that to be
in light mode it would be the dark color
so
what color would that be
let's go back to design one D1 f29
um
I wonder if you can set figma to use hsl
instead of
hex
um
let's just Google this really quick
okay
yeah default this wave color values in
hsl
[Music]
looks like it's not a feature right now
okay 230 17 14. that was this one light
text too
and
text color
if it's dark we want to oops I forgot
the VAR part
dark texture
okay
and then I'll switch to light
ooh
oh yeah and I need to adjust the um
and you use text color for the text
color
there we go so now
we need to set that thing pug
this is 230 12 44.
light text one
that's interesting
it's supposed to be 230 based on figma
and that is
what element is this
header subtitle
okay so go to header
subtitle
oh no
um
I need to make a new variable
oh boy
text color two
and then we'll use that for here
okay so now
and now it looks closer to the design
yay
I'll need to fix the toggle colors too
for light mode
and then I guess we'll also have to
switch the position of the toggle
for that
um
let's do the toggle last let's just get
these colors set correctly
so the next one is the card background
[Music]
dark card
foreign
background is for dark card
um
and then the text will be the next thing
okay
and then the text
let's get that hover state
looks like the hover is exactly oh and
here we go
what color is that
228 33.91
the dark card hover
I think I didn't make a light card hover
um oh yeah dark card dark hard cover
like card like card hover
hover
228 33.91
[Music]
so then
hover
card hover
okay let's see if that works nice
it's not too bad it's like once you get
things working then you just kind of
have to do the slightly busy work of
just you know Finding and adding each
little item
so we can fast forward through me
replacing the rest of the colors here
okay so we got all the colors switched
and let's test it by changing back to
dark mode
oh yeah so we need to fix this stuff
all right cool
yeah it looks pretty good
now let's work on the toggle stuff
toggle Styles if you're in light mode
230 1960.
what's this used for
okay so I think this color actually
needs to be
1960. foreign
label
toggle
[Music]
we should see toggle
light
and toggle itself should be
toggle White
and for dark it'll be I think it was
just White
yeah
foreign
background
okay
wait that doesn't seem right
I haven't nested like that
okay
and I think it has to be bold
there we go
okay now the toggle itself so if it's
light it's just the background color is
just like
the oval is that really light color
let's do the background
230 22 74.
what was it 2 30 22 74.
that might have been the one I just
deleted
toggle background light
and then I guess we'll just do toggle
background
and then set it to
ggle background light oh that's why I
added that double one
slightly annoying
okay and then for the dark mode then
we'll do that linear gradient thing
foreign
a little
annoying and this is because I'm not
super familiar with CSS properties but
it's hard to find the actual like value
for something so for example I want to
see what the background color of this
toggle background is right now
I go to computed
it doesn't exist because it's set to the
variable
so and then you have to go okay toggle
background what is toggle background
light set to
and then looks like I did that wrong
that's why it's not showing up
so it's just like extra steps
um you know maybe it's not as familiar I
just need to get used to um navigating
the colors when they're set with CSS
properties versus SAS variables which
just kind of compile the regular CSS
but yeah just one thing that I've kind
of noticed
toggle background light
shoot
okay there we go
and then I'll set this thing
toggle button
toggle button and we want that to be
F1 F 228 46.96
okay I need to make a new one for that
um toggle
button
right
46.96
and then set another new variable for
toggle button
okay toggle button light
and then
for dark it'll be
here we go
toggle button and then for dark toggle
button will be set to this
okay nice
cool all right
so I think the next thing we wanted to
do was
get the toggle working yeah
Okay so
for the toggle logic what I want is to I
guess there's a couple things one is we
want the switch to actually control you
know what mode you're using
two
I need to if the user color preferences
are set and we're loading the thing we
also need the toggle to be set so like
right now I have my OS set to light mode
and it's low to the light mode but the
toggle is still set to dark mode because
that's sort of the default thing so I
need to sort of Auto Select on the
toggle
what the preferences are if they're set
so maybe first we will work on maybe
having clicking the toggle I think I
need to adjust it's not quite detecting
the light mode thing
oh yeah because here we go
radio buttons need to be set to
the size
18 by 18.
and it's 20 by 24.
hmm
how tall is the thing itself 24
I think I actually want to be 24 by 24.
oh yeah that's much better okay toggle
input type radio width is 1.5 Rams
foreign
clicks better okay
good so
let's work on if I set the toggle to
dark mode on to the left it'll have dark
mode and then switch to light mode
so let's figure out how to do that
so I think what I want to do is I need
to figure out how controlling the toggle
will set the color scheme because right
now
all I did was change the color variables
based on media prefers color scheme
and let's see how people did that so I
think
what Andy did was he set an attribute on
the HTML element
with the data user color scheme thing
okay so let's think about this
um
so right now let's see
is it to light mode if I wanted to
switch to dark mode I'd click the Switch
and then what I would want is
clicking that switch would I guess add a
class or something to the HTML
and then based on that class it would
switch the variables and then in the CSS
I would have to what if I could just add
another thing here where I mean it
prefers color scheme dark
and if the thing is detected if the data
attribute or the class is selected I'm
just trying to see how Andy did it here
seems a little bit complicated
missiles the media prefers color scheme
all it does is sets the color mode
variable
too dark
um and then I think there's maybe a link
between this variable and then if the
data user color scheme is set to dark
because it's not setting color mode here
so there's some link I'm guessing in the
JavaScript that if it detects you've set
your OS to dark it'll set the color mode
variable to dark
and then
it will set the dead user color scheme
attribute
to dark
okay so OS setting to the color color
mode variable
to set the data user color scheme let me
see if I can find where he did that in
the JavaScript
extract the color mode value
I'm not familiar with this let's look
that up
window get computed style is that what
he was using
I'm just using a function get computed
Style
huh
it's a method of the window object so
getting a style of
you're getting the computed value of all
CSS properties
with get computed Style
okay
it says just getting the CSS properties
so he's getting the CSS properties of
document element and he's getting the
value of the prop key property
all right this is a condensed version of
the function used in this tutorial which
I guess we need to read
get a CSS custom property value with
JavaScript and that is used to get the
value of color mode
it computes Style
okay so this example is using
support scroll snap variable support
scroll snap and then
the JavaScript is saying getting the
component
so he's getting the CSS custom property
wait was this
an actual thing
I can I can't tell if this is an actual
function or if it was created
it's like it's the same
okay he's basically doing the same thing
um
okay it's just linking to this article
I can't figure out if
get computed style good computer style
is an actual function that exists
gets you this custom prop function oh
here you go
oh boy
so you're creating a function to get the
CSS custom property okay that's fine
just seems like a lot of extra stuff
I'm curious if
I think I want to see how other people
implement
a dark light mode thing I mean I know
this is I'm sure this is like the right
way of doing it
just seems like a lot
dark mode toggle and CSS tricks see if
CSS tricks has anything the complete
guide to the dark mode toggle
so we read a couple of these things
toggling themes
okay there's several approaches to do
this using a body class separate style
sheets custom properties server-side
Scripts
okay if you just want to override their
system preference for a site
looks like
he's overriding it with the CSS class so
if you select light theme
it will add the light theme class to the
body
that seems cool I mean it seems like a
lot of extra stuff because you're
setting the light theme in two places
but I guess that makes sense
I mean it seems pretty easy you're
setting your
your using this button to switch it
based on the class
this is interesting to sing you might
have a flash of
I guess a flash of color if
let's say you your OS is set to light
mode
but you manually set the page to load in
dark mode and you save that with local
storage the idea is when you reload the
page you go back to the website it will
detect it'll read your local storage and
then change to dark but if light's a
default when you hit reload it'll
have a light mode initially loaded and
then when JavaScript runs to read the
local storage and see that you want dark
mode then it'll switch to dark mode but
it'll be flashed quickly from light to
dark
so I'm wondering how Andy
got around that
let's go to the code pen
so right now
um
what you're saying so I set it to dark
okay so I said it's a dark
let's enable light mode
so let's reload and see
oh yeah see there's that flash
um
wait
I set it to dark
it's interesting it doesn't seem to be
detecting if I'm in light mode
so I want light mode so if we reload it
should load in light mode
yeah it's the dark give me the dark
default
so that's why it's flashing
yeah so I guess there's no great way
around that
um
unless you're doing server side so that
it'll set it you know before
everything's get loaded
so it's interesting I wonder if there's
a way around that flash thing
use your agent styles
color scheme meta tag
okay so this is light mode even though
I've set to dark
so I said to dark now let's reload
yeah there's a flash here too see
interesting yeah so anytime you use
JavaScript
it'll have that flash if it's different
maybe there's just not a great
way to do it
so let's think about this
um so maybe we'll worry about the Flash
not at all or another time because this
is maybe a bit of an edge case
but let's at least figure out how we
want the toggle logic to work so Andy
Bell did it by adding
um a attribute on the HTML
body on the HTML element
you can also do by adding a class on
like the body
so what I want to do is is there a way
to do it so that I can use the same
logic
for this I can use the same set of rules
for the color scheme and also if the
attribute or the body class is set and I
don't know if I can
because this is technically a media
query let's see if that's possible see
if you can do
CSS selector
media query or has class I don't think
it's possible
um
let's think about this
I just don't want to duplicate these
rules I don't know if there's a way
around that
so maybe we'll let's figure out if how I
want to set the color with the toggle so
if we set it to dark
maybe we want to add the class
if we set it to light
and it'll add the light class to the
body
so I'll see if this works
I'm going to create another selector
where
if the body has class
dark
can you do that
and I guess we'll do another one for
light
so body has class light
root will be
and if we end up having extraneous code
we can just remove it later but for now
let's test this out so let's go back to
our site
so now it's dark mode because my OS is
set to dark
let's add
no
let's just add class
light
to the body element
oops
okay and it's not working
and why
it's not showing up
I wonder if this doesn't work
let's just try something color
I just want to see if the
selector will show up
okay so it's showing up
but I think I just couldn't set the
variables under the body selector
so let's wait to see how they did it
this is a little startup being kind of
easy but then the toggle part seems to
be a little bit more difficult
okay
root level
oh okay so it's just in the selector you
set the variables to whatever so I don't
need this
okay now let's see if it works
add attribute
class
like oh look at that all right
now we're going
yeah I think there's no other way of
doing it
so there's just going to be a bit of
duplicate code here
okay
hey not bad so now
we want the toggle to add or remove the
class
so script
delete this
so what we want to do is
um let's close the others and I want to
open my index.html file
Okay so
the toggle
if it's selects dark we want it to add
the dark class if it's like slightly
long to add the light class
I'm gonna see how Andy did it I'm just
sort of using his code as an example
um
oh he's doing a button which is a little
bit different
let's just close this stuff out
so I'm looking for actually is
the JavaScript for the event when you
click the radio button
all right he's using a button two
so let's look JavaScript
um radio button
select event
okay so it works to find the selected
Rio button find the checked property
oh okay
so I guess
we can see
check if dark is selected is checked or
light is checked
um
if RB is checked
plus test this
so document get element by ID
dark
and checked
it's like checked
foreign
okay so it does work
it's gonna be const
um
dark
how do we want to do this
if I just do without gonna get element
by ID if dark is checked
then
Corey select your body
class list
equals
dark
else
equals light
and
we want to run this uh whenever the
toggle is clicked
so this is setting the click event on
the
button
and where's the button element
wait where is it
button
huh
radio button click
so I think I can do a click event on
what if I can do it on like the header
toggle
input element
um so what is it
maybe toggle input type radio really I
could I think I could add that on
so
input
I guess we just do
toggle wrapper input
const
um radio buttons
and then for each whoops
uh I don't know JavaScript that well
um
JavaScript es6 uh
radio buttons click event
I think I was thinking of dot net
um
foreign
The Click event
there you go event Arrow
um let's just do console log
click
so right now I'm just trying to test
that click one of the radio buttons will
run the console
uh script line two assignment time
declared variable I
okay
click okay
looks like it's working all right so
click event is working
now let us
I think move this logic in here
so hopefully we click this
we'll see the class getting added to the
body element and it should switch
yay
yes
okay well I guess that was I don't know
if it was easy but it's working now
dang pretty cool
okay so we have some toggle working
what we wanted to do now is save your
settings and I guess people seem to be
using a local storage for that so
if we manually change the mode
and maybe we should add some Logic for
like if I don't know if we have to but I
wonder if we have to add Logic for
if the checking if the local stores
matches the prefers color scheme thing
but maybe we don't have to do that so
we'll start with checking we'll start
with saving the mode whether darker
light to local storage then when we
reload the page we want to check local
storage and see if it's dark or light
and then I guess add the corresponding
class to the body
because if we just load the body doesn't
have anything
okay so let's do that so saving to local
storage
let's go back to the handy dandy
um Andy Bells thing
local storage
see
Okay window local storage
okay localstorage.set item and then this
is the key my cat value is Tom
and then get so it's very similar to a
cookie where you can set a value and
then get the value
so local storage set item
so I guess in JavaScript because I want
to add the logic for
if it's
checked so I think I need to
make this a full if statement
I feel like people like don't want to
use if statements nowadays and I don't
quite know why but I guess we can look
that up later
just something I've seen like I think
what the simplified made a video about
that
but we'll just start for now and then
we'll you know if we feel like it will
check it out later so if it is dark we
want to set local storage
set item and I guess we'll just say
color mode
and I'll set it to dark
otherwise we'll set it to light
foreign
I guess maybe we'll also test it so that
um
when we first load the site we want to
locals I'm going to load the local
storage
um get item
color mode
okay
let's see how that looks
so let's set it to light and now let's
reload
and it sets a light
I always says the dirt
is that the dark
so now here's a test I set it to light
or actually I guess we can't test it now
because
we want to
get oh that's not good we need to fix
that too
okay so we want to get
the color mode and then if the color
mode is dark we'll load the add the dark
class if the color mode is light we'll
load the light class
so what if we need to make some more
functions out of this
I think I'm not doing this right
foreign
let's see
I think there we go
yay
oh boy yeah I uh I'm not huge I'm not
super experienced in JavaScript let's
just double check that
um Arrow function
to constant
because I think I've seen it where you
set the variable or the you set the
function to like a const or something or
a let
okay
it looks like that's what I was doing
all right so I'm getting the color mode
and then
should I create another function for
like a Set Dark mode
and another one for set light mode so
then Set Dark mode we will
add dark
to the body class
light mode
and then we'll do this add the light
to the body class
and then
we'll just use these function names
so then we're not duplicating code
I will say set color mode
and then if
if color mode equals
dark
then Set Dark mode
else set light mode
and then we'll run color mode
okay so let's just
I'm going to add some console log
messages just to make sure everything's
running
color mode
and then
I guess we also want to get the
local storage thing
okay color mode is set to light
foreign
looks like it is saving the toggle thing
oh no if I I don't think I wrote Logic
for that
maybe it's just saving
it's interesting
oh yeah I think it's just saving the
radio button position like if I hit
reload when I'm already there but if I
do like a hard reload
yeah
but it seems to be working
um
I reloaded start mode then select light
mode and reload to set to light so I
seem to add some logic to um
sort of Auto Select the thing
so local storage
let's go add another one if if local
storage color mode is dark
else
foreign
what was it oh yeah so if I'm checking
local storage
I want to set the radio button to
I want to auto set either dark or light
on the radio buttons what I'm going to
do this
this work
or do I have to click it
and event listener click
oh no or do I just do click
okay I guess I do just click
mail set a constant for the dark and the
light buttons
so then I can just refer to those when I
need them
so then we'll replace the air
if dark button is checked then select
dark
and then now I will do if color mode
set the dark from the local storage I
will say dark button
click
otherwise I will say light button click
all right see if this works
so I'm set to light mode so I want to do
a hard refresh and hopefully it will
select the light setting
cool
now let's test this by maybe removing
the
where do I remove the local storage
there we go
how do you clear delete all there we go
so now I'll do a hard refresh
hmm
finish I wanted dark to be default
and it looks like
see here no local storage set
um set color mode nothing it's null so
let me see here so why is it loading
light I'm curious about that
happens if I just open a new
browser window
okay so color mode is null
and let's check the body class
oh interesting body classes set to light
why is that happening
we'll add some more console log messages
here
radio button clicked so let's save that
and now
if we do a hard refresh
set light mode is running now why is set
light mode running
set color mode ran
and then local storage is blank so it
returned the null and that set light
mode ran
oh it's because of this
um
because it's not dark so it was null
which means since it's not dark it's
running light mode
okay so now yeah if we do a hard refresh
snow and then it's loading dark mode
so
it's working
yeah
cool
let's also tested
um
if I
empty local storage
delete all
my things set to dark
slowing dark if it's set to light
loads light
okay oh this is not working either
um
so this is just based on the prefers
color scheme
so I want to do is I need to check
the prefers color scheme and then set
the toggle so how do I do that set the
toggle position based on the color
scheme that you've set
hmm
how do I check the prefers color scheme
with JavaScript
let's exhale some of these things
um
JavaScript check
prefers color scheme
so it's the window computed style which
I think Andy was using
hmm
wait where's the
code
oh that's interesting window match media
that's interesting window match media
Let's test it let's change to dark mode
oh
um
that was weird Why didn't it change from
light to dark
weird
okay so we can just use this logic
dot matches
so what I want to do is if the
let's go back to our site so by default
it's in this position
so if I wanted I want to detect if it's
in the light mode
const
um
get color mode
or else do light because we want dark to
be default
and then
um
I think actually all I have to do is
check for light because it's dark by
default
I'm not sure why I was doing this return
stuff
so I think I just need the one condition
checked is white
so if it is then I want to
select document or
light button click
I think that's all I need to do
and then I want you to run this
okay so what I want to do is
if I select light mode
should go to light mode and then the
radio button should switch to light
ah
um oh cause
I need I think I need to reload the page
in order for that to work
yeah so now it's working
but you want to run the thing
when you change so I don't know even if
it's possible to detect the change oh
that's kind of annoying
so how can you detect can you detect the
change of your color mode like through
JavaScript
there's a lot of levels of complexity to
this
can you detect the prefers color scheme
change
when would that actually
oh Flavio
I was wondering how often would it
actually would you actually need this so
if we delete this
do a hard refresh
I think I did set light as a default
right did I do that I can't even
remember anymore
um
okay yeah so default is light mode
because
it should switch it to dark
and toggle's not changing
so we did this window match media
matches
yeah what if the user changes mode while
using the website
can you check the mode chain using an
event listener oh
you can add an event listener oh my gosh
thank you Flavio
I think what I want to do is
make rename this to
or hold on let's
um
let's make a new function Maybe
for uh what is this
um
check
mode change for lack of a better word
okay so we just want to save that there
so I think I need to change this check
mode
and then
make this check for dark
then run this function
foreign
dark
let's add a little console log here
um
oops
all right
oh I forgot to change the
check mode
okay so snow so it's light
now let's change the dark
oh some stuff ran
cool
check mode changed click the radio
button and Set Dark mode
[Music]
hey
now I set to dark mode now let's load
oh my freaking
so I think local stores needs to Trump
whatever your
um prefers color scheme is because I'm
in light mode but I may not select the
dark mode I want that to save
this is quite uh
yeah a little more complicated than I
was thinking
so right now
um let me think about this
so I think I only want to run these
things
if
local storage is not set
foreign
so I set it to dark mode okay let's just
start from the beginning
um storage delete all this stuff
do a hard refresh okay
so by default
we're in light mode which makes sense
now if we switch this to dark mode
okay good switch to dark mode switch the
radio button selector
let's change back to light mode
oh Lord
um I think I need to also
change the local storage if the thing
gets changed
oh this is hard so there's like
there's three things controlling this
it's local storage your prefers color
scheme
and then if you manually click the radio
button
so what I needed and I think is if the
color scheme changes I actually do want
to if it changes
no hold on if it changes
local storage was not set but the radio
button
I think it stayed dark because the radio
button was set to dark okay let's start
over
okay nothing's been set no local storage
has been set
this is the light by default
because I have my schemes at the light
so if I change the dark
goes to dark mode the toggle goes to
dark
and the local storage has been changed
to dark
okay so if I reload everything stays at
dark
everything stays at dark
but now
if I change a color scheme
to light
nothing happens and this is because
local storage is still set to dark
so I guess the question is
we're thinking this because
sure I changed to light
but I can just change the light with the
radio button if I want to
so is that does that seem like it's
desired
Behavior I'll start over again so light
mode light mode
let's say oh I'm in light mode on my OS
but
I want to load dark mode
manually so I set it to dark so now if I
refresh it's in dark mode that seems
like desired Behavior
so let's delete this
now we're back in light mode
so let's say oh I'm going to switch my
thing to dark mode I want everything to
be dark
and it did do that
but if I switch to light mode
it stays in dark mode
but I feel like people aren't going to
be switching their OS all that often so
I feel like
maybe that's okay I think this is an
edge case that I'm thinking where you're
like switching your color mode multiple
times
I feel like this is operating the way I
want it to
yeah
switch to light mode I reload
stays light I think this is actually
okay
so I think this works
um
let's just quickly check about the if
statements
don't use if statements
use object literals
and this might be a little beyond my
current
um
JavaScript skills but let's check it out
all right so there's a lot of if else if
things
because a switch statement which is sort
of the same thing
um here's the alternative
so you're setting creating an object
hmm
I don't know I'm not sure how this would
work with this
hmm well
I think I'm going to keep this as is
um you're welcome to check out my code
on my GitHub repo and if you want to
refactor this to a better way of
checking for the conditionals you know
you're definitely welcome to do that but
I mean
it works I think the code is reasonably
understandable
um in terms of checking the different
you know modes and setting local stores
and stuff like that
so I feel like we can sort of consider
this project complete
yeah
so yeah thanks for
following along with this if you if you
follow it all the way to the end thank
you for doing that I hope this has been
helpful for you feel free to leave a
comment down below if you you know did
make it all the way through I'd just be
interested to see how many people did
that
um and yeah if you have any questions
you can again leave a comment so thanks
for watching and yeah we'll see you in
the next video